e
e e
on housing the first order business as
always going to be Pledge of Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
justice for
all and uh good morning we have a full
day ahead of us um I have a a
significant amount of people here to
speak on hp60 um but we I'm I don't want
to put a time limit on but make sure if
you have written testimony consider uh
not reading the testimony directly and
sending it to the committee um and
summarizing some details that would be
great um but first um the first one that
I'd like to call on first of all I'm
going to open the hearing 102 um the
first one I'd like to call on is
Representative Bob Lynn the prime
sponsor of the bill welcome chairman
Lynn thank you Mr chair and members of
uh of this new new and very important uh
committee uh dealing with with housing
issues my name is represent my name is
Representative Bob Lynn uh I represent
uh Rockingham District 17 that's the
town of Windam uh New Hampshire and I'm
here in support of HB 60 um this bill if
I I think I have my facts correct on
this I believe this bill um has passed
the house three times now um uh over the
last two or four years I don't know I
don't have the exact number but I'm I'm
pretty sure I'm right that it's passed
the house three times now and I hope it
will pass again this time this is a bill
that basically I mean we could if we had
to label this we could um label it I
suppose a contract means what it says uh
bill um I think if you asked members of
the
public if you have a lease for a year
what's the term of the lease they would
say very naturally a year but under our
current law that is not the case if
you're dealing with restricted what's
called restricted property and I I think
it's important to understand that
restricted rest that restrictive
property does not mean that you are a
large landlord and you own you know
hundreds or or what or thousands of
units you can be the owner of
restrictive property if you own a 2unit
apartment a duplex that you don't live
in in other words you live in one house
and you have another duplex it can be as
small as that that's that would
constitute restricted property so it can
apply to a number of very small
landlords and under the law under a
under a Supreme Court decision from 2005
and I have to
emphasize that that was long before I
was ever a member of the Supreme Court
um there's a there was a case called
diesel witz
uh vers versus uh some company I don't
remember the name off hand um but
basically um what that Court decision
said is that if uh if you have a lease
for a term of a year and the year is
up you the tenant can simply say I'm you
know i' I want to leave I'm I'm the
lease is over I'm leaving and that's it
and there's nothing you as a landlord
can do about that nor nor should you as
the landlord be able to do anything
about that you signed a Year's contract
it's over it's over but from the
landlord's perspective the landlord
cannot evict you simply because the
lease is over that does not under the
Court's reasoning in that case that does
not constitute good
cause so to be let me make sure to be
completely fair if you don't pay the
rent of course you can be evicted even
you know not whether it's a year or not
if you don't pay the rent of course you
can be evicted if you're if you um are
disruptive or you damage the property or
um various other reasons sure that would
be good cause but Simply Having the
lease end does not constitute good cause
and I submit that that just is is sort
of a flagrant affront to basic contract
principles and more importantly I think
that that there are there's a practical
implication to this
what it means and if you read the
Court's majority decision um the
majority really sort of Embraces this
reasoning if you read the Court's
decision what it says is that you know
tenants are fungible they're just from a
if you have restricted property the only
thing you should worry about is like
getting your money and not and the
property not being damaged and other
than that you know it's one one tenant
is fungible with another and it
particularly says and I can't quote I
can't remember to quote the language but
it particularly says that landlords
ought to make the decision as as to
whether or not they want to have this
tenant essentially for the Long Hall at
the
beginning because and I guess under this
under what I think is the kind of
convoluted reasoning of the court in
that case um be because they're going to
say if you make once you make that
decision Vision the tenant is there I
mean as Justice Netto pointed out in a
in a uh really I think very U pre and
concurring opinion the result of the
Court's decision is that once you let a
ten once you make a lease with a tenant
the tenant is there for Life unless the
tenant does something else that's a
basis for removing the tenant it's not
enough that the lease is over so stop
and think about this the implications of
this you are a
landlord and you've got to decide about
whether you want somebody to be a
tenant suppose you have somebody uh you
know sort of a a a marginalized a person
that you might that might be considered
a marginalized person in the sense that
maybe they have a bad credit rating um
or maybe they have um some kind of a
minor criminal record or something that
you know as a landlord well do I want
this person or not so stop and think if
if you're a landlord and you have the
right to have a lease for a year mean a
year you might say all right you know
got some questions about this person um
but it's only a year I'll I I'm willing
to take the chance for a year and if
things don't work out the at the end of
the year I'm just going to say I'm not
renewing the lease but and so you may be
persuaded I'm going to I'm going to take
my CH a chance on this tenant but if as
the law is now you allow that person to
come in you're stuck with that person
literally forever now if you know if the
if the per if you can prove that the
person did something wrong and you know
uh um and it's serious enough sure maybe
you can get him out for that reason but
it's not enough but you as the landlord
are going to know I'm going to have to
jump through all these hoops if if if I
think that this person might be you know
might be a drug user of some kind I
better be able to get evidence that's
going to be able to prove that and you
know will will other tenants be be
willing to to testify will I have some
evidence or will they be afraid um you
you have to factor in all of those kind
of things it just doesn't make any sense
and I submit that it really has the
effect of reducing the availability of
housing to PE perhaps people that should
be most um would find it most hard
otherwise to get housing um so I hope U
for all those reasons that this
committee will look favorably on this
bill uh and I'm happy to answer um any
questions that uh members of the
committee may have thank you
representative for your testimony are
there any questions for representative
Lyn representative Holland
Holland thank you Mr chair is there
anything in state law that requires the
tenant to provide notification to the
landlord that they're not going to renew
the lease there's like a timeline or is
that just in the lease itself I mean
unless it I I don't think there is if
it's if it's you know if the if you have
a lease that says a year um I think you
know I I could be I stand to be
corrected but I don't think that that's
that you need to do I mean maybe the
least would say you know you're going to
give 30 days notice or something before
the but if it doesn't say that I don't I
don't think there is but I could be
correct I could stand to be corrected on
that can I ask a followup on that so so
I I think um the the issue here really
is because you mentioned it in your
testimony that you really as the
landlord what you really want is
stability because you want the rent to
come in because you probably have a
mortgage on the building and and your
bank is going to be want your their
money as well and so the issue really
here is in the notification part you're
saying that that the the individual once
they get in there they're going to be
there forever and the landlord can't
make a change but by so so right now the
the tenant doesn't have to tell the
landlord at least we think until the end
of the lease whether they're going to
renew so that adds to instability to the
landlord but the landlord may not want
the tenant and so and and there's cause
you mention it in terms of eviction why
they could get rid of it but it would
seem two months seems a little bit harsh
in terms of like the time frame and so
my my question really is it's hard
during the first year of the lease but
during the second year of the lease the
the tenant would have a one-year record
where they've adequately paid the rent
they haven't done it broken anything
terrible in the apartment and so
wouldn't it be mindful to have a clause
in there that the renewal came up say
maybe in the second year of of his lease
six months in that he'd had adequate
time to to if they didn't want to renew
the lease or the landlord didn't want to
renew the lease that there was enough
time for the tenant to react because a
lot of the marginalized groups that you
met you talked about they don't
representative can you just finish up
your question please I'm sorry was that
enough of a question about length of
notification yes you know what you you
actually I I representative I thank you
for that question because you you
actually raised a very good point that I
neglected to mention last year this bill
as as presented last year had a 30-day
not period when the bill got to the
Senate um I believe it was Senator inis
who raised the issue of well wouldn't it
be better to increase the notice to for
for example I believe he suggested 60
days and so I and I said at the time you
know that that that makes sense to me
and so as I introduced the bill they
still Senate still didn't pass the bill
by the way but nonetheless um but I I
thought that that made sense and I
increased it I should also um uh
indicate
that I've had um discussions with um
with um another witness who's going to
testify here repres uh OT uh Barry from
who a longtime uh and very good attorney
with with New Hampshire legal assistance
um about the the you know would it he
had suggested among other things um
would it make sense to increase right
now you'll notice the bill says uh that
that it applies to a lease of 6 months
or more or a tency of 6 months or more
he raised the question um would it you
know would there be uh some flexibility
and obviously this bill is in the
committee it's not it's no longer my
bill it's it's for the committee's
decision but um would there be some
willingness or at least on on my part as
a spon as a prime sponsor to consider um
extending that six-month period to a
one-year period and candidly from
speaking just for myself and I
understand the committee may have
different views but um speaking just for
myself I that would you know that would
be if if that would gets support from a
significant number of people who who
right now don't support the bill I that
would be a compromise that personally I
would be willing to make understanding
that the committee may have a completely
different view on
that I'll set representative
keran thank you chair um so just to
understand does this Bill enable a
tenant to be evicted without cause um
based on the expiration of the lease
even if that tenant had remained in the
residents with permission from the
landlord for years after the lease has
expired would if yes if the Le in other
words I think under current law if for
example let's say you have a year's
lease and the the year end the year ends
and the landlord doesn't you know both
sides want it to continue under the
under the law the that is converted into
a month-to-month tency um basically so
and and it can go on as long as both
parties want it to this bill would say
that after you know if if the landlord
doesn't evict it doesn't ask the tenant
to leave after the one-year period um
the 60 days would still apply the
landlord could by giving 60 days notice
um have the tenant
leave follow up yes please um would you
object to the addition to the bill that
requires the court to seal the record of
an eviction um based solely on the
expiration of
lease um well you know I don't I mean I
guess what I'm I guess what I would say
is I I'm not sure that I would because
for for for this reason it seems to me
that the the whole idea of this bill is
to say that a contract means what it
says so if if you have that theory if
let's say you have a leas for a
year doesn't shouldn't that mean that
both parties who having signed that
lease have the expectation that at the
end of the year the the lease is over
and that either party can can you know
end it and so if the if in your example
the tenant decides I'm not going to I'm
not going to honor the contract I'm
going to force the landlord to evict me
to go to court to evict me you know
maybe maybe if that's something a future
landlord should know that you know
this because when the leases you know
both sides should be bound by
um by the terms of a
contract right any other questions for
representative Lynn representative
axman
so mik in your initial testimony you
alluded to
uh the willingness of people to invest
in real estate and my question is sort
of
twofold have you looked at who owns
rental properties in New Hampshire my
research says that the vast majority of
rental properties in New Hampshire are
owned by Mom and Pops by small
investors and my experience is that many
people who have owned rental properties
Mom and Pops for lack of a better term
uh
and are increasingly hesitant to invest
in rental properties and own them
because of the difficulty of terminating
Tendencies and the the primary area that
I've I've seen this has been with the
fact that the end of a lease is not the
end of a lease have you looked at that
have you got any experience with that or
is what are your thoughts on that
well in in terms of if if you're asking
have I done sort of Empirical research
on that no I have I have not done
Empirical research on that um uh I think
I I think that um landlords would and I
I and I you know again haven't done
Empirical research but I have no reason
to to doubt your your statement that you
know most rental properties in New
Hampshire are owned by sort of the mom
and pop uh kind of people I have no
doubt about that and I and I do know
that it you know
getting getting a tenant to leave that
doesn't want to leave whether it's
because of the end of the lease or they
haven't paid the rent or whatever that's
you're you're right that is you know
that is a hassle and and
um this isn't going to be a Panacea
passing this bill isn't going to be a
Panacea for ending that but I think it
does it does help it does move the ball
in the right Direction um and so um I I
hope again that's why I hope you'll pass
it okay um representative um
Miner thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr lynon I apologize if you've
answered this in some way and I might
have missed it but if this the contract
ends at the end of the
lease and then now there other co uh
just month-to-month tenant as at the end
of a lease and you've decided I don't
need to evict them or they don't need to
leave and I'm going to keep them because
they've been great right so after the
end of the term of the lease now that
they're month-to-month
tenants you still can't well can you use
the expiration of the lease and just
have them leave say no I'm tired of it
or will they still have to be evicted
for other cause now at this point as a
month-to-month tenant well well under
under if this law were to pass
um you you would be able then to give
the 60-day note in other words Once the
lease is up under under current law they
become month to- month tenants but under
current law as per that case you can't
evict them um just because you know
they're they're month-to-month tenants
they they're they're basically entitled
to stay theoretically forever um under
If This Were to pass um you would have
to they're month-to-month tenants but
you would have to give 60 days notice so
you would have to allow them to stay for
2 months um you know you'd have to give
them notice that they before you could
uh evict
them thank you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for coming to
testify this morning um just uh this is
basically a follow up to the question
that was asked by my colleague on the
other side of the room um and just for
clarification um based on this bill if I
have been living in a rental unit for 7
years and I've paid my rent on time
every month and I've never damaged the
unit or bothered the other tenants or
annoyed anybody um and the lease has
expired but the landlord has been happy
to have me say since I was a good tenant
that at after 7even years the landlord
could evict me with 60 days notice and I
have to tell you this actually happened
to me so I haven't I haven't made this
story up um So based on this bill after
7even years of being a good tenant I
could be
evicted uh that's correct and I guess
you know one of the things that that I I
don't think that that's a harsh result
and I'll say that for this
reason
my my belief you know I I actually W I
actually was a landlord back in the
1980s I owned one two two uh one duplex
but since I've not i' so but I haven't I
sold it in the late 80s have never been
a landlord since then so I have no skin
in the game for landlords um but
my my understanding is and I think it's
it's it's a very you know uh uh
worthwhile business uh something that we
need but that landlords are basically in
the business of investing in real estate
and renting properties because because
they want they want to make a a living
at that they want to they want to make
money at and so what I would say is if
that's
true it it strikes me that it would be a
very unusual situation for a landlord to
decide to evict a tenant just you know
well I you know by flipping a coin I
think today I'm going to evict this
tenant or that there there normally is
some reason for that
um and you know again I you know if
you're saying it it could it could there
have been only a really bad reason in
your case I I maybe I'm not saying that
that never happens but all I am what I
am saying is that it strikes me that
that it's not a big problem of landlord
sort of you know just arbitrarily on a
whim deciding to get rid of somebody
because for the very reasons that your
that your colleague pointed out it's a
hassle to get somebody out and then to
get somebody in the landlord is almost
always going to lose some money so
presumably they don't want to do that
unless they feel they have a good reason
to do
it may I just make a follow-up Point
real quick is it a question or is it a
point it's a point all right this is a
public hearing I'm going to ask you to
only ask questions to the the witnesses
please representative
Paige thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for being
here so I think I'm I'm sympathetic to a
lot of your arguments and where I'm
struggling is in the Practical effect on
the ground today when we have
effectively a 0% vacancy rate and I'm
thinking about my own
community so what I'm struggling with is
what happens to these tenants when they
are evicted without cause in this
particular Market um my question to you
is
what do you see that practical reality
looking like where do you see these
tenants going and do you think that
passing this bill will further
exacerbate our huge homelessness crisis
that we have in this state you know I I
this uh I I thank you for the question
and I I I guess the short answer is I
don't see that because you know if you
stop and think about you know I know
that that's been an argument in fact I
think that apparently it had some
persuasive effect with at least enough
members of the Senate to but I think if
you stop and analyze look at this
analytically let's assume and I agree
with you that you know there's a very
low vacancy rate I mean there's no
question that there there's housing
shortage but let's let's take it even
further let's assume that there was no
vacancy rate there was absolutely zero
vacancy rate the argument that this is
going to somehow increase homelessness I
think doesn't really with stand
analytical scrutiny because it basically
is a one in and one out situation if you
assume that that there's absolutely no
vacancy rate and that you know everybody
that is that is not in a rental property
is homeless then even if you assumed
that this would increase the number of
evictions and and you know candidly
perhaps it would to some extent but even
if you assume that that's true okay so
you have one person who is newly
homeless that person in with No Vacancy
rate is replaced by somebody who now
become who was homeless and now becomes
un homeless and so it it seems to me you
know if you logically now if you know if
you logically carry that through there's
no even in a you know not perfect No
Vacancy rate there's no reason to
believe that it's any more likely
that someone who is evicted will become
homeless than there is to to believe
that somebody who becomes a new tenant
doesn't come from the homeless I mean I
I I just think it you know it's a it's a
nice talking point for people who oppose
the bill but I think if you look at it
analytically it just doesn't really
hold okay seeing no further questions
thank you representative Lyn thank you
okay so we have um over 20 people um
looking to testify so I'm going to ask
everybody to keep their testimony at two
minutes I'm going to ask the uh Vice
chair to keep track of that for me um
next up is representative stop
welcome to the committee on housing
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my testimony um for the record my
name is Kathy stab I represent Hillsboro
uh 25 which is W five in Manchester and
um by my Reckoning at least half of the
people probably more of the people who
are my constituents are renters um in
New Hampshire um approximately
151,000 uh people are renters or there
are
151,000 renter households I've sent out
two um uh pieces of paper one is my
testimony the notes for my testimony the
other one is from the national uh
low-income housing Coalition um which
has some data about um the um uh
availability of of housing in the state
um and um I also emailed my testimony to
you because there are some links and I
wanted you to have them live so you can
just look at their um research
um as as was reported the vacancy rate
in the state now is 6% and a healthy r u
vacancy rate is considered about 5% um
half of all the households renter
households in New Hampshire are cost
burden which means that they are
spending more than 30% of their income
on housing over 30,000 of those
households are severely cost burdened
which means they are spending 50% or
more of their income on housing I spoke
to an um a retired person who is
spending six 60% of her income on
housing and um she's on social security
so she doesn't have a lot to spare
um most of the people um who are
severely cost burdened 64% of them um
are of the people who are severely cost
burden um make both less than $30,000 a
year and they rely on social security or
suppl
security income for their um for their
income landlords require prospective
tenants to demonstrate that their
monthly income is representative I'm
going to ask you to wrap up if you can
please okay um if this bill is passed
this will create chaos um there will the
people who are being forced out of their
housing um will be uh sent out into a
market that they cannot afford most of
these people are paying more than they
can afford on rent they they're hanging
on by a thread and uh they don't have
the money to move they don't have the
money for security deposits so I'm
asking you not to cut that thread um and
I am open to questions thank you very
much for your testimony questions for
representative
St representative boo um uh so I have I
have a quick question um you know given
the uh issue regarding the length of the
lease agreements should lease agreements
have terms that Define the length of the
agreement at all should they even be in
the
lease um well uh leases do protect
tenants from you know increases in rent
um I spoke to a woman who at the end of
the her lease saw her rent go up 650 per
or $650 a month so she has was at that
time looking for a second job in order
to keep that apartment because she can't
qualify for another one um yes so I I
agree that aase is a good thing I think
at this point in time with the housing
crisis we have and homelessness crisis
that we have which was has been a a big
um
um a big issue um in the last election I
I don't think that now is a very good
time for us to be ending 40 Years of
protections for
renters um in order to you know make
contract law more more consistent in the
state we're talking about the human cost
here there are going to be a lot lot of
people that are going to be forced to
move some of them are going to be
um some of them are going to be homeless
some of them are going to move in with
their families others are going to quit
their jobs and leave the state and so
that is the ground truth that is what is
likely to happen if we pass this Bill
thank you representative Reed thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative um
we heard just now in previous testimony
that ostensibly this would not add to
our fast in the nation homelessness uh
growth rate um in your
expertise would you say that a person
coming out of homelessness to attempt to
rent has working against them the fact
that they are homeless and in other
words a market that is heavily skewed
towards landlords and landlords have
their pick of any tenant they want they
are unlikely to give a homeless person
or person coming out of home
homelessness that unit and in addition
if a person has been evicted that makes
it all the harder for them to get
housing yes that's that's true I would
agree and and furthermore I would say
that you know the cost of of moving and
the cost of getting a new apartment you
know uh the average cost of a
two-bedroom apartment in New Hampshire
is $1,800 a month um to prove you make
three times that would mean that you
would need to prove that you make
$5,400 a month
you have to have that first month's rent
you have to have um a security deposit
which is usually the same as a first
month's rent and um you need a moving
costs um you know you may have had uh um
um your furniture and storage um and in
general one of the things that um we're
seeing with people with homelessness is
that they they have other issues you
know they have mental health issues they
have and those and and or they
disabilities there are people that
cannot work and make enough money to
satisfy landlords and it's a landlord's
Market because of the vacancy rate being
so low people are building more houses
that takes years between permitting
construction and then you know getting
people into into houses and many of the
houses being built in Manchester are
renting for $3,000 a month you get
kicked out of a $1,200 a month apartment
you're not going to rent a $33,000 a
month um one-bedroom apartment on on on
Canal Street for $3,000 a month that's
just not going to
happen see no other questions thank you
representative all right thank you next
up I'm call on Senator
rear
welcome oh um representative stop if oh
no she submitted testimony
oh no if they have I'll talk to you
about that go ahead Senator um good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
uh the housing committee um my name is
Tara Reen I am the senator from district
15 representing Bo conquered and
Hopkinton I'm a former practicing
attorney and a large part of my business
was representing landlords I have done
hundreds of evictions over the course of
my career and I was never at a loss to
find a cause for that eviction not only
the list in 540 uh colon 2 Roman 2 um is
there but the other good cause um is a
very broad excuse for um evicting
somebody and we never came upon um uh an
eviction that um couldn't be done for
some reason uh I will also note there's
nothing in a statute anywhere that
limits raising the rent and sometimes
that is a landlord's way of evicting
somebody is that um that huge rent
increase that they know that they can't
uh
afford um I will say um that housing is
such a crisis nowadays it's the very
reason this committee is has been formed
and is sitting here um there is um such
a dir of Housing and I and over my last
10 years of my career I worked at the
New Hampshire Community Loan Fund with
low and moderate income uh tenants and I
will say yes if they are evicted and
they're very low income they are going
to be homeless I guarantee you they're
going to join the um the uh roles of the
homeless so housing is extremely
critical at this point what else happens
when housing is lost is the per where
that person lives and their whole
support Circle disappears with that when
they leave that location um their
neighbors that help them watch their
children maybe the schools that their
children's go to the ride share that
they do to get to their job so a loss of
housing for a low moderate income person
is um is more than just housing
sometimes Senator I'm going to ask you
to wrap up if you could absolutely thank
you um so I would say that letting
tenants remain in their housing if
there's no legitimate good cause is the
fair and Equitable thing to do and it's
easy to dehumanize it and say it's it's
a matter of contract law and I suggest
that maybe we revisit this topic in 5
years orever how many years it is that
our vacancy rate is at 5% um instead of
under 1% as it is now thank you Mr
chairman thank you senator for your
testimony any questions representative
buolo yes um I have a question so you
mentioned something very interesting
which is that under good cause a
landlord for economic reasons could
raise the rent and then use that as
presumably something to push the tenant
out or um to to end the lease otherwise
um if term expiration was a uh good
cause to end a lease wouldn't that then
stop the perverse incentive of landlords
having to raise the rent to get rid of a
tenant and they could just say because
the lease is over I I I think I I think
what you say has logic to it certainly
but there's uh landlords do lots of
things that aren't increasing the rent
they say they're going to remodel the
apartment and when the tenant moves out
they they paint a wall and that's the
remodel and they rent it to somebody
else so landlords find ways around this
now um without uh there's the the the
part of it at the end of the expiration
is there's no judicial involvement at
that point it's the landlord telling you
that your um your lease is up that
you're going to leave so we will never
get eyes on if there are not legitimate
parts to why that tenant's being evicted
okay see any other questions thank you
Senator thank you next up I'm going to
call on representative
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
committee for the record I'm state
representative hope Damon I serve half
of Sullivan County I won't list my nine
towns takes a while um I am also a
former landlord sort of in another life
decades ago my husband and I owned an
old in that we converted to apartments
and had cottages and we had nine units
for a number of years um I'm here to
speak in opposition to the bill
primarily because new law is supposed to
solve a problem or have a purpose and I
don't see what problem this is
solving the law is very clear in 540 col
2 all the rules or rather all the
reasons why tency can be terminated
including the other good cause statement
so it's not clear to me what legitimate
reason a landlord would have for
terminating a tenant that is not
included in that statute
already and therefore reading between
the lines I wonder what not so
legitimate reason would be covered by
the proposed
statute the current vacancy rate for
rental properties in New Hampshire is 8%
% it has been below 1% for The Last 5
Years 5% is considered a balanced Market
we need to keep people in their homes as
Senator re noted in their Community
where it works for them so that we have
them as
employees as parents as people that we
serve so I won't take more of your time
except to say I simply don't see the
purpose thank you thank you
representative questions for
representative Damon
seeing none thank you parenthetically I
appreciate all your work I enjoyed being
on this committee last year thank you
for being a former
member Sarah
Holland good morning thank you for
having me I'm Sarah Holland um I am a
realtor and I am currently the the chair
of public policy for the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors I am here to
show our support for this bill um and I
will make this short and I will submit
my written testimony um but the
important thing to note about this bill
is that no matter which way this goes
it's not going to solve the housing
crisis um it is simply going to provide
more certainty for both both sides both
landlords and tenants to understand the
terms of their agreement and their
relationship that they entered into it
provides guard rails it provides notice
um and the current interpretation of the
law as previously um noted here today
um it doesn't take into account the
landlord's property rights and how they
use their property and the important
life changes that they may also be going
through um they may have signed up to
take on a tenant um for a year or two in
order to you know maybe dabble in it to
provide um opportunities in their
Community um but maybe they go through a
life change and this is not something
that they can take on for life um and
they need a way to get out for a lack of
a better phrasing um representative
Thaxton notic noted earlier that Mom and
Pop landlords and this interpretation
don't you if they're not bringing more
units online because they are afraid of
getting tied into these leases and a
legal battle that they're also not in in
um anticipating um as taking on as a cop
so there was most recently an article I
think it was last week and I'm happy to
send that along to you that contractors
and other folks who are looking to bring
to convert units from commercial to
residential and make rental units more
widely available that they're not able
to get through that zoning approval
process so there are other ways that we
can look at this to provide more housing
for a lot of folks um however you know
providing more notice and transparency
for both parties of a of a rental
transaction um is is not the way to
solve housing so we support this Bill
thank you for your testimony questions
representative
Paige thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chair just seeking clarification
on sort of the the case you're you
provided of somebody who gets into being
a landlord for a couple years and they
want out so so my my understanding is
that if they want out and they decide
that they want to stop running this
property that that is good cause under
existing statute am I wrong about that
what kind of getting out are you talking
about what are you your imaginary case
study here yeah it's not necessarily
imaginary right so there are a lot of
folks who who get into this and for a
variety of reasons including the legal
implications and having to take somebody
who who they have had a relationship
with over the years to court in order to
vacate that property
um that's a reason for folks to number
one not get into offering run
widely available um or to have them um
pull back and maybe open their rental
units up to other members of their
family or um to other folks who are are
deserving in other ways for variety
there's many different reasons why this
could happen um but just a a property
owner changing their mind about how they
wish to use their property they
shouldn't have to go through a legal
process in order to do
so representative Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you taking my question you
said one of the um benefits to this was
the introduction of certainty for both
parties and I think we can all
understand easily how the certainty on
the part of the landlord is beneficial
for the landlord the landlord has
complete control over that situation
after the um expiration of the lease um
can you please explain to me considering
there are far more renters in the state
than landlords how the certainty that
you will lose housing at the end of that
contract contract as opposed to the
certainty that as long as you continue
to pay your rent on time continue to be
a good tenant uh that you will keep your
housing how is the certainty that you
are going to lose your housing
beneficial to the vast majority of
people who are tenants and also the
workers that we desperately need in this
state sure thank you for that and I
understand that this is a very divisive
issue um and I have clients that are on
both sides of this so I definitely
understand and empathize um however as a
as a property owner um you should have
the right to decide how to as a
fundamental property right dispose of
your property and being able to provide
notice based on the terms of a lease a
contract that you signed with that
tenant that explains the terms of that
agreement you're just providing them
notice that yes I agree that at the
beginning of this lease term we have we
have given ourselves 12 months to be
able to have this Arrangement and we
know I know longer wish you to be in my
property that that gives them at least a
small amount of time I understand that
for some and in this housing situation
that it is
not the most appropriate amount of time
sometimes given the availability of
property um in rentals
that there is transparency that the
lease is what it says it is and I think
every tenant should go into that lease
under understanding what those terms are
and if they don't like them to advocate
for something that makes sense for them
so I again you know I understand that
this is divisive but this is relative to
a private property right and those
property
owners are who we are representing at
this
moment quickly please thank you I
appreciate you appreciating that it's
divisive that that was not my question I
don't think I heard the answer to my
question which is how does this help
people who currently because of our law
go into that contract with the
understanding that they will have
security afterwards how is the certainty
that they will not have that housing um
something that's beneficial to tenants
the benefit to tenants is the
question the contract as it is written
and the terms of that contract should be
what the tenants should be understanding
and reading there should be no unless
the lease States and it's previously
agreed
that they can stay over then they should
not have that expectation that they can
stay
over
okay um representive
Grant can you tell me if a tenant
decides they don't want to leave how
long it takes to get that tenant out of
that apartment or whatever and how much
does it cost to the landlord
so it does take quite a bit of time so
the end so when an eviction process has
begun it can take um several months to a
year and possibly longer depending on
how that judge um receiving that case
decides to accommodate that tenant and
may require or allow them to stay in
that unit um for additional an
additional time period so the there are
a lot of uh metrics associated with this
but it is a large cost in time and money
associated with
eviction thank you represent
Paige this may have been a better
question for Senator Reen but following
up on rep Grant's question do you have
an an estimate of sort of a typical cost
for going through that proceeding I I
don't it ranges from Court filing fees
um which um could be you know under 100
to you know hundreds of dollars um plus
the survey as well as the time and and
sometimes lost rent as well because a
tenant may not continue to pay rent at
during those that process and I'm sure
there's um other people willing to speak
to that as well representa so um thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you um Victoria Mark
ktz Mark hoodz
welcome you just turned it off there hi
my name is Victoria maritz um I live in
Manchester I'm originally from the Lakes
Region but I left for school and moved
back for uh for work um I live in a
studio apartment in Manchester and um it
took me four months to find that
apartment um this December a couple
months ago my heat and hot water were
out for most of the month um and I
complained to my landlord about it and I
started searching for another apartment
that maybe wouldn't have those issues um
but of course I couldn't find one um
because there aren't other apartments
and now with this with this law
potentially going through I'm scared
that my landlord will end my uh lease in
March because I've complained about
maintenance issues to find someone who
who is willing to put up with those
issues given the current housing market
um even with the generous 60 days notice
with this law it's still it took me four
months to find this apartment it's
likely going to take me the the same to
find another if I can find one um and it
just feels like I if I'm evicted or if
my lease ends and and my landlord
doesn't want me to stay my mom and pop
landlord doesn't want me to stay then I
will likely have to leave the state like
most of my my siblings and most of my
friends have people my age to
neighboring states that are easier to
rent in um and I just feel like that the
just cause eviction law was put into
place to override this you know issue
that everyone is talking about about
leases being a contract because the
landlords have so much more power than
the tenants especially I mean they have
the privilege to own property and they
also and especially in this housing
market have so many more options than
tenants to
um to replace to replace someone when
when they don't to put someone into
their
housing thank thank you very much any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony Nick
Norman and I know you asked for five
minutes if you could keep it to two
that'd be great thank you totally
thank you chairman Alexander I
appreciate the opportunity to speak
there's so much to talk about I'll talk
about as much as we can and the time
allotted I represent and advocate for
housing providers our organization
connects organizations of housing
providers across the state we have a
membership of about 3,500 people and put
out legislative updates every week
advising on housing
issues so there's several things about
this to consider um I do agree it should
be balanced between landlord and tenant
in terms of ending uh the
contract uh housing providers absolutely
do not want to evict it's a measure of
absolute Last Resort it's fairly painful
to evict it's expensive it's time
consuming you end up with an apartment
that has to be renovated before it can
be um put back on the market so there's
no rash of evictions that I can possibly
foresee If This Were to pass uh however
there are times when it is very
difficult to evict someone that is
causing uh an issue that not non-paying
of the rent if you're attempting to
evict someone let's say that's uh a
disturbance um Dam um causing harm to
other people or threats to other people
that say or someone that's dealing drugs
uh there's a number of reasons why you
would want to evict somebody that's just
become a nightmare of a tenant and all
of those have to be proven in court um
so there are reasons that you can evict
but there they're many times just
impossible to prove so having this
provision would be good and I do think
it would be beneficial to people that
are marginally qualified tenants I know
landlords that have marginally qualified
Tenants come to them and say I'd love to
take a risk on this person but if I'm
going to be stuck for for life you know
I'm not going to take the risk Mr Norman
I ask that you wrap up if you could okay
well there's there's so much more I've
been in the business for 35 years I have
48 units I have some experience I I open
to questions and and do please read
through all the testimony there's a lot
more to be said Thank you any questions
for Nick
Norman seeing none thank
you cara an uh Roden Hiser please help
me with that if you
could it's Cara Anne rhen Heiser
sorry um dear chairman Alexander and
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity this morning to address
House Bill 60 um as I mentioned my name
is Cara rodenhiser and I'm the director
of the home forall Coalition and I'm
here today on behalf of the coalition to
voice our strong opposition to this bill
and underscore the significant harm it
would cause renters and communities
across New Hampshire the bill threatens
to destabilize housing security for many
renters permitting landlords to evict
individuals who have lived in their
homes for 6 months without providing any
reason it opens doors to arbitrary and
unjust evictions leaving families
vulnerable to sudden displacement and
creating a pervasive climate of fear and
uncertainty for renters but particularly
those who are low-income or in
marginalized communities the
consequences could be incredibly
devastating
including increased risk of homelessness
and economic instability which are two
issues New Hampshire is already
struggling to address furthermore
eliminating good cause predictions
undermines Decades of progress in Fair
Housing and anti-discrimination efforts
when landlords aren't required to
provide a reason for eviction it becomes
far easier to conceal discriminatory
practices targeting individuals based on
race disability family status or other
protected characteristics
Beyond those legal concerns the bill
threatens stability of entire
communities severing vital connections
to Schools jobs and essential services
and this bill is not really about
creating fairness or ensuring landlords
have adequate tools to address problem
tenants these tools already exist and
are utilized when necessary data from
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute has shown that eviction
filings in the state have uh risen 66%
between 2020 and 2023 uh returning to
pre-pandemic levels these numbers
demonstrate that landlords already have
sufficient mechanisms to pursue eviction
when it is warranted what landlords need
are stronger support systems to ensure
successful ten tencies not legislation
that further erodes housing stability
I'm going to ask you wrap up okay and so
it's been noted that this bill has been
defeated uh several times over the past
year for good reason uh lawmakers have
recognized harmit poses and introducing
this bill again during a historic
housing crisis is deeply misguided um so
on behalf of home forall I urge you to
uh consider opposing House Bill 60 and
work towards solutions that strengthen
our communities rather than weaken them
thank you thank you for your testimony
any questions representative Paige thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony um so we heard from a uh prior
speaker who was concerned who was a
tenant who was concerned concerned about
having complained about maintenance
issues in their
apartment um so if this bill should pass
that tenant could be evicted without
cause at the end of their lease period
right if this bill should pass does that
person then have any recourse if they
feel they've been retaliated against
for making a VI a legitimate complaint
about their living conditions in their
building so I am not a legal exper
expert but I will say in my experience
uh working with landlords um as part of
my role uh with home forall uh that is
something that um tenants uh there's a
power differential landlords hold a lot
of power and tenants um are often afraid
to go to their landlord with um concerns
even something as simple as not having
heat um in their unit already because
they want to have a positive
relationship with their landlord if
there is now a fear of if I bring an
issue to a landlord's attention I could
be evicted I think uh that power
differential will grow um and whether or
not um a tenant has access to supports
for recourse um I would say that uh they
might feel in that moment they
don't represent
Miner thank you Mr chairman thank you
for speaking do you think
that taking away the security of the
contract ending at the end of the
contract would cause more housing
providers to do month-to-month
tencies rather than even giving them
that one-year lease and now causing them
to only be secure for 30 days
potentially I think that could be a
possibility which could be devastating
to um folks with um assisted uh rental
assistance so a housing Choice voucher
um where often a 12-month lease is
required that would make it even harder
for voucher holders to utilize their
voucher in New Hampshire uh but I can't
speak on behalf of landlords but I
imagine it could it could have further
exacerbate the crisis we're seeing
now okay seeing no other questions thank
you for your testimony thank you um I
see you had written testimony if you can
get it to the committee that'd be great
yes thank you uh David
Klein thank you Mr chairman I realize
the time is short um my name is David
Klein I have rental properties in the
Sea Coast Area I only want to because of
the time short I just want to address a
couple of questions that I heard um in
terms of time of evictions that that
time will vary depending upon the case
and what the defendant does and how it's
handled I had an eviction that ended up
the end of last year it took 11 months
because it got appealed and it got cut
short because the defendant did not file
a brief on time and the Supreme Court uh
dismissed the eviction short probably 90
60 to 90 days fees vary depending upon
whether you're hiring attorney you do
have court entry fees Sheriff's fees
second set of sherff fees when you get
the rid of possession um there are and
reasons why landlords are reluctant to
evict are you always almost always lose
rent on these things the apartments come
back more damaged in eviction cases than
they do on ordinary tenants who want the
security deposit back that means not
only do you have to pay to fix up the
apartment but you have to pay for the
Lost rent During the period of time then
for someone like me we've hired a
management company we have to pay the
management company a one month's fee for
rental of the apartment so it's very
expensive we do not evict arbitrarily we
think about it we try and work it out
with the tenants and one of the things
about the homelessness eviction on the
record if the tenant
leaves after the at the end of the 6
notice period there's no grounds to
evict they will not have an eviction on
their record as far as other apartments
the general statistic Nationwide is 33
to 40% of Apartments roll over every
year so there is a constant Supply and
and taking up of that Supply throughout
this state and every state even with
this bill the defenses to eviction set
forth in RSA 540 colum 13 still exists
they're uneffective there is a statute
against retaliation by the landlord
against the tenants particularly making
complaints about maintenance two public
uh authorities so that those defenses
are still there the rent withholding is
still there none of that is affected by
this bill given the time constraints and
to not make you stop me I will stop
myself at this point perfect thank you
for your testimony Mr kle any
questions uh representative Cole thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question how many times during your
career have you done
evictions um I was a practi attorney at
one point so I'd say probably about 100
I'll set thank you right any other
questions thank you very
much an Mar Rook
good morning my name is Ann Marie oook
I'm a 76 year old soon to be 77 divorced
RN who lives alone I am unable to resume
my career as an irn due to medical
issues I live on a limited income uh
Social Security and a small monthly
annuity I live most of my life in four
houses owned by me um I no longer own
homes I lived in my previous apartment
in a house owned by by the same family
for 18 and 1/2 years I always paid my
rent on time and was a good tenant it
was home for 2 18 and 1/2 years in 23 it
sold I did writing on the wall and
started looking for a new apartment
start of two uh 24 rent was doubled I
could not afford to stay I scrambled to
pay rent which which meant going to town
welfare St Vincent dep Paul and other
groups in town I was notified never
finding myself in the situ notified I
was never finding myself in this
situation I felt like a beggar I
received ation notice in February of 24
for other good cause Rena bu new owner
to convert some of the units to
Airbnb I could not find anything I could
afford I signed up for senior housing in
three areas waiting list is two to three
years I I had to find a rental I could
afford it took almost a year I have to
come up with uh security deposit I also
had to find moving
money uh and in the middle of the
hottest summer I can remember I was told
by fair to go sign up for in the
homeless shelter my answer was I will
live in my car before that it's called
dignity I found after searching for one
year a tiny apartment I could afford I
find myself facing an unsure future in
my new apartment due to the fact that
the building was sold on the day I moved
in if if you could wrap up for us that'd
be great thank you Mr work pardon if you
could wrap up for us that'd be great
okay got lots of rentals going on I have
month-to Monon lease I have knowledge my
old apartment has remained the same it's
empty no rentals have been done for six
months in my old apartment um my life is
still upside down I I stretched
financially I feel hopeless I was
embarrassed to share with friends my
respect was tremendously decreased and
medical issues have
increased 6 months and I'm still
unsettled I would want anyone maybe you
or your constituents with mothers and
fathers in rented Apartments to think
about this and hopefully to be able to
live in peace not with thoughts that the
landlord could put you out for no
reason Miss yes please think of uh the
human factor it could change a loved
one's life and not for the good I think
my life will never be the same I oppose
HP
and hope you understand why thank you
for listening thank you very much for
your testimony are there questions from
Mr represent
Reed thank you so much for your
testimony I think your story is a
powerful example of the actual human
cost rather than treating people like
numbers um so my question is do you
think your particular situation and the
story that you provided and I welcome
you to uh provide any more details to
your story that you didn't have time to
I would be interested in hearing that do
you think that your story is unique or
unusual in terms of how housing is
affecting your
life I don't think so but this there's
also this senior Factor you have to
think about I'm not able to go out and
make more money to afford someplace you
know that it is really you know livable
and that's just a fact of life at this
point I do what I can um it's just me
living alone um I think there other
seniors you don't want to see your
mother or father on the street you know
you have to stop and think about that
too what this bill would do um they need
time if you're going to move you need
time to find someplace and they're just
not out there
anymore it took me a
year before I found anything
and and you know I'm really in a much
smaller place than I had before and the
one I had before was
Tiny which like I said sits I'm rented
and nothing has been done to it so I
just don't know what else to say thank
you other questions thank you very much
for your
testimony Mary Smith
hello I am Mary Smith from Manchester
New
Hampshire and I am strongly in support
of this bill um if anything I think it's
been watered down to make it more
passable I would encourage this
committee to make the um the mandatory
60 days shorter to 30
days um I deal with bad tenants all the
time I'm not a landlord myself I'm a
rener and even in my personal experience
Renning I've asked my landlord for a
lease because I was interested in that
security that you can get for a
long-term lease and she said no and I
think that's perfectly acceptable
because that is her right this is a
property rights issue and there is a
human element many people here have
talked about the human element and I
think landlords help protect communities
from Bad tenants who are not a nuisance
to just the landlords they are a
nuisance to everybody who lives on the
premises or around the premises and so
giving landlords the ability to
evict and making that stronger in these
cases I don't think representative Lynn
would put this in if there was no uh
particular reason uh he is familiar with
the courts because he served as chief
justice on the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and if this was being upheld by
the courts then uh this bill wouldn't be
in front of you today and you wouldn't
be listening to people's testimony on it
so um if you have any questions relating
to you know any of my testimony I'm I'm
welcome to hear them thank you very much
for your testimony any questions
representative
Reed hi Mary nice to see you again hello
representative Reed thank you for your
testimony um in your opinion which is
more of a nuisance maybe a tenant that
has like you know loud music or whatever
might be a nuisance uh in your situation
or having unhoused people everywhere in
your community and you yourself looking
at the chance of being unhoused which is
more of a
nuisance I think the solution to I mean
you describe the unhoused people as a
nuisance I don't believe they're a
nuisance but um I think the solution to
that is something we've already heard in
testimony today which is loosening the
restrictions on building housing and
there's no part of this bill that's in
front of you today to be approved by
this committee that speaks to uh like
loosening those housing restrictions
this bill is just about what the
contract that the tenants sign with the
landlords and the landlord's rights to
their property
thank representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming this morning to
testify um given the current uh housing
situation and the housing crisis in New
Hampshire is this the right time for The
Spill I think uh any language that that
people have brought today about the
homelessness crisis and the the very low
vacancy rate less than a percent here in
New Hampshire uh that it is tangential
to this bill and not related and so
specifically to your question do I think
this is the right time yes I think any
time is the right time for this bill and
it's a shame that this bill even has to
be put forward because this is something
that should already be upheld by the
courts that is not being and that's why
this bill is in front of you thank you
very much testimony appreciate it
sure Rebecca
sky and I I know we're we're running a
bit behind I plan on powering through
lunch but if there's members of the
committee that need to leave um for
whatever reason um feel free but um I
didn't realize I thought an hour was
enough time but apparently not so um
we're going to keep moving forward go
ahead okay thank you uh um thank you
representative Alexander members of the
committee uh for allowing me time today
my name is Rebecca Sky I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging um and the uh New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging um
advises against providing landlords the
rights to evict at the end of the lease
within 60 days of um of Advance written
notice
um given the housing crisis that our
state is um is in at this time um this
is not the right time for this bill um
the one on one in and one out argument
suggested by representative Lynn puts
the most vulnerable at greatest risk for
homelessness take for instance um an
older adult who ask for grab bars in the
shower and other accessibility features
in the apartment that will cost the
landlord for a landlord looking to
maximize their income who can fill that
um apartment easily
why would they not hesitate to evict a
person at the end of the lease putting
that older adult out on the
street re reinforcing why this bill will
disproportionately impact the growing
older adult population in our state
older adults experience poverty at
higher rates than the general population
income generally declines as one as one
ages um the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute uh in a recent report said
that the supplemental poverty measure
rate in 2022 for Granite Staters age 65
and older was
14.4% higher than the general uh uh SPM
for granite Staters aged 18 to 64 which
was
8.4% uh those with mobility issues face
add added hurdles uh the US Census
Bureau issued a report in October 2023
that found that less than 20% of housing
stock in New England is age ready that
is having step-free entry and bed and
bath on the first floor I know of a
couple who um moved to a Residence Inn
during the winter months um because the
accessibility issues of their apartment
are exacerbated during the winter months
as you can imagine um and they choose
that because they can't find alternative
housing um Miss if you could yep um if
you flip to the backs side of um this uh
testimony picture speaks of thousand
words um we had at the commission
meeting in November 2024 we had a Dr Dr
Samara Sheckler from The Joint Center
for housing studies at Harvard
University come and speak to us and uh
this is uh from one of her slides and it
represents the housing cost burdens for
adults age 65 and older in New Hampshire
and yes it represents those who rent and
those who own thank you thank you Miss
Sky um I see in your test mod you have
some links so if you can send us an
electronic copy of that that' be great
absolutely thank you any
questions represent bu um so I'm I'm
really glad that you brought up uh the
disproportionate impact especially you
know people who are elderly my question
is there are quite a few housing
providers who are elderly so what would
be the impact of a lengthy and expensive
eviction process if you're a housing
provider that's elderly who depends on
this income that they get from a rental
when they have a rental property that is
not
providing so I am unclear um as to the
difference between so a landlord going
through an eviction process after the
passage to this law versus going through
an eviction process um that's already
available through the law how's the cost
any different they're going to have to
go through the same steps and processes
I'm not um I'm an expert on the older
adults Nur State not necessarily um in
the housing field okay all right thank
you for your testimony thank you Kristen
Evans
I have given my uh written testimony and
will be brief so uh thank you for the
opportunity to testify in opposition to
HB hb60 for the record my name is
Kristen Evans and I am the director of
policy for AEL New Hampshire AEL is a
disability Justice organization and we
are a nonpartisan nonprofit organization
that fights for the civil and human
rights of children and adults with
disabilities as a disability Justice
organization dedicated to advancing the
rights of dignity of individuals with
with disabilities we strongly oppose
this bill this bill poses significant
threats to the housing stability and
well-being of individuals with
disabilities across the state this bill
eliminates vital protections for tenants
including those with disabilities that
change this change would
disproportionately impact individuals
with disabilities who already face
significant barriers to accessing safe
and affordable housing research
consistently demonstrates the challenges
that individuals with disabilities
encounter in securing stable housing
individuals with disabilities are more
likely to experience housing
discrimination limited housing options
and financial instability placing them
at a heightened risk of homelessness and
housing
instability House Bill undermine House
Bill 60 undermines the principles of
fairness and Equity by
disproportionately impacting
marginalized communities including
individuals with disabilities it
threatens to amplify housing insecurity
and homelessness among those of our most
vulnerable members of our society in
opposing House Bill 60 we urge policy
makers to consider the human impact of
this legislation on individuals with
disabilities and prioritize the
preservation of housing stability and
security for all residents of New
Hampshire thank you thank you for your
testimony any questions from Miss
Evans representative
Daxton hi so in reading this and
thinking about it as a as a real estate
agent and as a property owner I and I
recognize that there would be greater
challenges for somebody with
disabilities it's easy to picture that
why would they not see a longer term
lease I
mean they You Can a tenant could
negotiate for a longer term lease if I
if I was disabled which I hope that
doesn't happen
soon uh I would and I was concerned
about housing why would I immediately
accept a one-year lease why wouldn't I
say to the landlord I'm going to I need
to stay here for a period of years and
negotiate for a three or four or five
year lease and and build an escalator in
or something like that thank you for the
question um uh I think people with
disabilities and Chase is here also he
can speak to this but um have a really
hard time finding um apartments to rent
so that going to someone already and
then asking for like a 5-year lease
would pose more problems for them to
then uh be able to rent an
apartment well I I don't followup
followup I I don't mean to be
argumentative but a a tenant like that
which has probably got fairly stable
income well if you're disabled and
you're you have you have a fixed income
it's stable right but not large I I
totally totally understand that totally
agree with that uh but they could they
could make the case for themselves that
they they it could be most landlords as
almost everybody in here has agreed
regardless of what side you're on are
looking for Dependable stable tenants so
if I know that I have someone who's
disabled and they are looking for long
term and they have stable income which
is honestly the biggest issue most of
the time with a tenant and I can agree
to a term of
increases uh built into to the least not
un unheard of I would think that would
make them more desirable as a tenant
rather than less desirable and I
understand it may just be an
uncomfortable question that they're
wanting to just whatever I can get I'll
take but they may be able to move
themselves up the list by saying not
only will I take this for one year but
I'm willing to take it for a period of
years and I will I understand that your
costs are going to go up so I'm willing
to deal with that now just
a okay um I think I can get back to you
with more detailed information but not
everybody starts out renting as disabled
so people become disabled um as they are
renters and this law would allow
landlords to just evict them because of
the because they because they want to
for no no cause but that happens but I
think that
um I will get back to you because I
don't know why Miss Evans um I we have
the council for developmental
disabilities here hopefully they can
help answer your question as well that
they'll be able to answer that better
but thank you for the question
appreciate it uh representative Reed
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I had a I have a follow-up
because I had an original question but I
need to kind of piggy back off of what
was just said so in the
example that was just offered to you by
the Committee Member that a landlord
might be willing as we don't frequently
ever see negotiate a longer term longer
than one-ear lease because the person
has stable income would the current
law not benefit that landlord more in
other words you could negotiate for the
12 months and if you decide later you
need more rent you are free to raise the
rent and if the tenant can't meet that
rent demand then you could then evict
would that not be more beneficial to the
landlord currently I think so yes I
followup Mr chair please thank you um so
aside from the very poignant human costs
that you've pointed out and has been
pointed out repeatedly we know that the
human cost argument does not get
traction with everybody so I want to go
to the economic kind of realities is it
not true that many of the members of the
dis ability Community also hold jobs
even if just part-time and that they are
filling those worker needs that we
desperately have and so when you put
their housing at risk once again we are
pushing out the people who do the jobs
that we desperately need
yes thank you representative Gibbs thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming
this morning to
testify do you have any information on
whether any tenants with disabilities
have actually um had any success in
negotiating long-term lease and whether
those long if if they have whether those
long-term leases have um continue to be
affordable given that they would
probably include an escalator for rent
thank you for the question at this
moment I do not but I will definitely uh
get that information to you by the end
of the day that'd be great thank you all
right thank you for your testimony thank
you I'm going to call on Chase Eon um
from the Coalition developmental
disabilities believe you should already
have my testimony uh my name is Chase
eagleson I serve as the policy and
planning coordinator for New Hampshire
Council development disabilities we are
a federally funded state agency that's
mandated in all states uh to advocate
for the rights and responsibilities of
individuals uh within the development
disabil disabled community
um we come uh as may not be surprised in
opposition of this bill uh as was
previously mentioned 2005 uh this type
of lease which is a hold over lease was
uh unanimously uh
determined
uh uh that they need to protect tenants
uh with holder releases and again was
unanimously uh upheld in
2015 uh overturning this decision would
create uh significant hard ship for
individuals within a disability
Community it's already very difficult
for individuals within that Community to
find safe stable and especially
accessible housing you know less than 2%
of housing in United States is
accessible uh and that's for individuals
with physical disabilities and uh
physical disabilities don't just
manifest when you're born they can
develop over time uh they come with
aging they come with any sort of thing
throughout life
and uh allowing for this type of
eviction to occur would allow for a lot
more tenants uh who are developing any
type of disability or who have a
disability to be evicted due to their
disability and in my opinion that is not
just cause that is discriminate
discriminatory against people with
disabilities that's what this is opening
up uh and based in historical memory
this is something that will occur if
this
passes already without this bill being
in place individuals with disabilities
face a two to three times higher rate of
eviction than individuals without
disabilities we ask you wrap up yeah of
course uh and displacement uh that
occurs from eviction
shatters fundamental security forcing
children forcing families forcing people
who desire to be part of the community
to benefit the community it shatters
their ability to continue to do that and
I'm open to any questions thank you Mr
eagleson is it not true that there's
already mechanism in law to prevent a
person with a disability from being
evicted under current law and um in the
case you described wouldn't you say that
those individuals who are evicted at
higher rates would have cause to sue
under the human rights law
under the human rights law they might
but if this bill passes they could be
evicted and they could not be said that
it's because of their disability they
could just be evicted and told that they
want to end the lease so it wouldn't
really be something they can
prove okay so just to follow up there's
there's currently a renovation eviction
right so if I say oh I need like you
know to renovate the property for to
make it an Airbnb you can already evict
based on that I guess I'm I guess guess
I'm confused at how you're making the
connection of landlords will
arbitrarily evict because they are
disabled I I don't see the connection
there I think that's the exact point
they already have enough mechanisms to
evict someone because of their
disability doing adding this will only
add to the amount of options they have
and
that's again adding more discriminatory
purposes for evicting someone with
disability okay thank
you represent Reed thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so I
just want to clarify so what you're
saying is whilst currently there's
enough ambiguity in law that perhaps
landlords could be evicting unjustly
whether it's uh the unprotected oh I
didn't like the fact that he's a Yankees
fan or the very protected um they're
disabled and I really kind of that that
puts me out a little bit um there's
enough ambiguity in current law that
that is already happening and we can't
really go after it cuz it's kind of
ambiguous but this being absolutely no
cause would allow landlords to just kick
anyone out if they didn't like their
skin color or how they express
themselves or a disability or
anything thank you for your question yes
that's exactly my point uh this opens up
for any type of discrimination whether
it be again due to their race due their
disability due to any preconceived
notion of not wanting them to be
there thank you for your testimony
representative I'm going to ask to if
you could refrain from asking would you
believe questions and ask legitimate
questions of witnesses that'd be great I
appreciate the the um request Mr chair
that was not technically a would you
believe that was technically I was
asking for clarification on what he had
previously said great thank you thank
you for your
testimony I'm going to call on Elissa
Antman good morning honorable members of
the House housing committee uh I will be
brief thank you for hearing my testimony
today my name is Alyssa Antman I'm a
resident of conquered and I am here in
opposition to
hb60 this bill as you've heard would
already um harm marginalized populations
including the lgbtq plus and disability
Community leaving people without a place
to live while we can assume best
intentions from landlords in my
experience not all landlords are
supportive of all identities um my
identity as an lgbtq plus and disabled
person puts me at a higher risk of
housing insecurity and this bill only
exacerbates this issue and I'm going to
share my story very briefly like I said
in 2016 I rented a studio apartment with
my partner at the time it was small our
kitchen sink only a few feet from our
bed and one window that only stayed open
when propped up by a piece of wood it
was home however it was never truly a
safe space for us when we signed the
lease to the apartment our landlords
warned us you girls need to stick
together and no boys over which was not
a problem for me um however it was clear
that they didn't understand or want to
understand that we were romantically
involved they touted their traditional
family values and quickly it became
clear how unaccepting they would be of
our true relationship we were living out
of different motels at the time and had
nowhere else to go and only enough
savings to cover one month's rent and a
security deposit um the longer we stayed
the more question we got from our
landlords they began to overstep and
intrude and they poked around our
personal lives and during regular
maintenance of our apartment our
landlords even interrogated us as to why
there was only one bed in the apartment
it was incredibly intrusive and it's
extremely demoralizing to hide and mask
Your Existence because you're in
constant fear for your housing security
as someone who also lives with a mental
health disability a landlord could
decide they don't want to rent to
someone with a disability and it
wouldn't be the first time I've been
exposed to hurtful and dangerous stigma
around that this bill gives landlords
the power to evict people like me by
providing them the tools to do so in
State statue hiding my identity is not
an option if I need to access emergency
services in a crisis moment the last
thing I should worry about is their
presence leading to my possible eviction
my story is just one story among
thousands of Granit stators who would be
harmed by this bill this could happen to
someone in a similar situation today if
this bill passes
everyone deserves equal access to
housing um for that reason I'm asking
you to vote in expedient to legislate so
that people from already marginalized
groups aren't left without a place to
live thank you for your time thank you
Miss Sam and for your testimony is there
any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you Jennifer chisel
helloo thank you for the opportunity to
be able to speak to you about hb60 um my
name is Jennifer Chisum I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
coalition to end homelessness and we are
in opposition of this bill as you could
probably imagine um and so I have
submitted some written testimony um and
we'll also be Distributing our um state
of homelessness in New Hampshire reports
as well so
um that should happen later this week um
I will keep my comments brief today
however um so given the state of
homelessness and housing instability in
New Hampshire right now an ounce of
prevention is currently worth at least
10 pounds of cure and instead of pre
preventing evictions hp60 would
unfortunately move the needle in the
wrong direction and so we do understand
that sometimes evictions do need to
happen and New Hampshire already has to
just cause statutes in place that are um
effective um the question had come up
about how hb60 would impact homelessness
and so on its surface it may seem that
evicting one family when their lease
ends and replacing them with new renters
is a net zero situation but it's just
not that simple once their housing is
lost for no cause under hp60 many New
Hampshire families who pay their rent on
time and comply with the terms of their
leases will require significant
community support and resources from
places like nonprofit programs or local
welfare offices in order to restabilize
and obtain new housing that is safe
stable and affordable it's a lot of work
especially right now um for individuals
families households um to find new
housing as you have heard already from
other people um so we are extremely
concerned about families even those
families of median income um and so the
number of people and families who were
homeless in New Hampshire from January
to December of 2023 um jumped to
2,335 individuals which is an increase
of almost 50% over 2022 is numbers um
and so just to note these numbers do not
take into consideration anybody who's
doubled up um and so staying in an
unstable situation with maybe friends or
family um we are also particularly
concerned about the post potential
impacts of hb60 on Aging adults in the
granite state no cause eviction laws
such as hb60 have been shown to
negatively affect uh the elderly
disproportionately ask you to wrap up
yep um and so just given the
vulnerability of this population the
current eviction laws offer
significantly more protection to aging
tenants um in New Hampshire is an
quickly aging State the number of older
adults um is uh projected to double
within the next 20 years um and so with
effective eviction laws already in place
and the negative effects of no cause
evictions um on families and vulnerable
populations um we respectfully encourage
uh the committee members um to vote
against hb60 thank you thank you for the
thank you for your testimony are there
questions seeing none thank you oh oh
representive Paige see that's why I like
you sitting over
there um I have a a question on you
mentioned that it's been demonst
research has demonstrated that um
eviction without cause has a dis
disproportionate impact on um seniors or
paraphrasing can you point us to that
research on where this has happened
elsewhere and how that has had that
impact yeah I'd be more than happy to
follow up with an email but I was
looking at um some data from the N um
National Law Center on poly and home
poverty and homelessness as well as the
national lwi income um Housing Coalition
so um I will follow follow up via email
by the end of the day thank you thank
you thank
you Matt
maybery good morning good morning I was
practicing I can just say 90 seconds my
name is Matt mayber I'm the CEO of the
New Hampshire homebuilders Association
and we're going to spend a whole lot of
time together this year cuz we're going
to tackle this Challenge and Conquer it
quick backstory on me because a lot of
you have seen a 50-year-old all right
fine 60 year old white male working for
a whole bunch of Rich
developers I'm gay I'm a disabled
veteran I lost my housing during the
economic downturn I lost my housing
because I was gay been there done that
we oppose this because we actually would
like to see it go from 60-day notice to
30-day notice because we have to
remember these are all adults and at
leas is a contractual relationship not a
moral
obligation this is not a onesided
agreement we're not making you stay
we're not making you
leave I've been a housing provider and
I've been a tenant and I can guarantee
you that the minute you serve that
60-day notice or a 30-day notice the
tenant stops paying rent you start
losing money and they stick around
you're going into court and you're
losing more
money any tenant can ask for a new
contract they can ask for an extension
in
writing if they choose not to do that
that is upon
them also one thing that we should
factor in that costs go up taxes go up
my taxes in Rochester went up $1,400
this
year oil and heating have gone
up but yet no one's talking about that
the tenants should participate in that
in their rent
payments it keeps getting pushed back
onto the housing
provider and I'm glad you find it funny
ma'am but there are folks who actually
make a living from providing housing and
when you're asking them to do more
putting more constraints on them will
close that siphon of housing down even
further so chairman I see you moving
forward so I'm going to shut up but
happy to take your questions I said
we're going to spend a lot of time
together and landlords don't arbitrarily
throw people out we like the
consistency I'll stop thank you for your
testimony Mr bber questions
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify this morning ma um
when the costs for a landlord increase
when the taxes increase and when the uh
cost of oil and and other expenses for
heating and so forth um when those
increase don't the landlords raise the
rent yes
ma'am but if you're if you're in a lease
and you're in a contractual agreement
signed by two
adults you're locked into that rent so
when your contract has an expiration
date on it and you've known
for 11 months 29 days when the
expiration date of that contract is
that's up for
negotiation follow up follow up Mr
chair when the lease is up doesn't the
landlord raise the rent then you're
making a lot of assumptions ma'am
because sometimes people like to have it
the consistency of a long-term tenant
you know uh the representative mentioned
about negotiating a multi-year lead with
a rider in
there my my members and myself would say
absolutely yes please we'd love to have
you stay for multiple
years housing providers don't look for
opportunities to ask people to
leave profits come from having someone
stay for multiple years but if the rents
and cost of providing housing go
up isn't it fair and appropriate to ask
a tenant to participate in that
increase or should they just be locked
in for
Life quickly representative Gibbs thank
you sir um but when those costs go up
and the lease is expired doesn't the
landlord raise the rent can't the
landlord raise the rent is there
anything stopping the landlord from
raising the rent or not raising the rent
they may choose to eat that cost they
may like the the 10 that they have they
may whatever their situation is it's not
an
automatic it is a choice it is a choice
to stay is a choice to move is a choice
to increase the rent is a choice to ask
for a multi-year contract or in advance
if you're nine months into a lease you
could say to the housing provider hey in
a couple months it's coming up can I get
a new contract I want to
stay there are options on both sides
ma'am represent
re thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Mayberry and as you know I uh you all
in oh my apologies I think I did that go
ahead so rude Mr
chair um agree on what has been
mentioned today as one of the solutions
or perhaps even the the biggest solution
to the housing crisis which is the
easing up of restrictions on buildings
so I want to start with the fact that we
are in agreement on at least that much
um my question and I may have follow-ups
um is that you talk about the contract
and much has been made about the
contract this is a contract between two
adults contract is it is it not true
that contracts inherently have to be
within the bounds of the current law in
other words you cannot sign a contract
in violation of Law and so when you sign
that contract as to grown adults you are
signing the contract with the
understanding that whatever is in law is
also applicable so in other words when
the people are entering into contracts
currently they're entering into a lease
with the knowledge including the
landlords with the knowledge that you
cannot be no cause evicted at the end of
that lease that's already negotiated in
is that that not
accurate I'm perplexed by your
question the contract has a beginning
date and an end date and the terms and
conditions within that are agreed to by
two adults and if you have questions of
that I would suggest seeking legal
counsel so just to be very clear in case
you may be able to answer it now um so
the terms and conditions in that
contract have to be legal they cannot be
illegal and so all parties both parties
are aware of that when they come in to
negotiate that contract so they are
negotiating the terms and conditions of
that contract
that is within the bounds of the law
currently that means that the
understanding between both parties and
if landlords don't like this they don't
have to rent anything out that the
understanding is that yes you get to
stay here because it's the law so long
as you don't violate the the conditions
of that lease that's already being
negotiated in is it
not I'm not an attorney so I don't want
to okay representative Reed quickly
please
thank you um actually if I can defer to
the the I know there was another
representative I I I hate to go on a
tire but I'll come back around if the
chair would allow
me representative kwin do you have a
question okay represent bolo uh thank
you Mr chairman um I have a it's much
much a lot of us have been talking about
the housing shortage which I think a lot
of us recognize as a major problem in
New Hampshire my question is um in your
experience um representing home builders
um does making it harder to end a tency
making it harder to end a tency does
that incentivize or disincentivize
investors to invest in building
additional housing
units it
completely
disincentivizes it why why do they need
to go to the
hassle be people want to make you know
their business model is to provide
housing at terms that everyone can live
with and go with
the harder you make it the less excited
people are about providing it when you
have that extra room in your basement or
thanks to Chairman Alexander we have a
kickass Adu Bill coming through that we
help sales through this committee
hint that should provide additional
housing for
folks thank
you representative Reed thank you Mr
chair
thanks to my Adu bill um so you said
that uh that landlords at in large do
are not looking for reasons to PE kick
people out I would argue that the fact
this bill exists and has kept coming
back is in fact the landlords looking
for reasons to kick people out that are
not currently allowed things like what
we've heard um who we love and and what
we like and how we live so my question
is when you're talking about that and
you're saying that as soon as you evict
someone they stop paying rent are you
aware that that if you go to court with
them the fact that they stopped paying
rent puts them in a much weaker position
in court and so in fact they are advised
largely to continue to pay the existing
rent and many of them who are listening
to the legal advice actually do continue
to pay the existing rent are you aware
of
that I've been there I've lived it and
the you know it's nice living in Utopia
but they stop paying the rent and so
when you have to take them to the court
it's more legal fees upon the housing
provider to try to go get the rent that
is legally obligated to you so you're
ring up more cost and you're allowing
you're losing even more rent
representative I and representative what
you can do I can gladly meet with you
separately we have a one-on-one
conversation we can't we're going move
forward this isn't fit others yeah we're
we have plenty more people to speak on
this thank you Mr Mayberry for your
testimony thank you chairman will ar ar
Val
Val good morning my name is Will arell
for the record I'm the executive
director of Crossroads house which is
the second largest homeless shelter in
the
state we um take care of individuals and
Families both in Rockingham and straford
counties uh we also serve as the warming
shelter for all of Rockingham
County um we currently are maxed out in
our beds and we have about 112 beds so
they're all full uh we have a waiting
list of a couple of hundred
people um both of those in terms of the
filling the beds and in terms of our
weight list those have have been
increasing over the last several years
um and
it'd be interesting to note that the
folks that are coming to us are not
typically what you would Envision as
homeless uh these are for the most part
not individuals that are drug addicts or
individuals that are ex incarcerated
these are individuals like that women
who was here earlier
testifying um people in their 60s and
70s um with underlying health issues
disabilities who have been pushed out um
out of their homes most mostly because
they're unlimited incomes and can't
afford to stay in their homes and as a
last resort as the uh they come to us uh
unwillingly um many of them having
transition from their houses to a car
and then to us um because they see it as
a as a a a an issue of dignity
and um so I'm speaking purely uh uh in
opposition to House Bill 60
because we see this continuing in terms
of um having people come to us and this
is not just crossover's house it's the
whole shelter system is really at
capacity and bursting at the seams and
we really uh anything like this that we
that we think is going to uh impact um
the whole housing system and our ability
to house individuals in a negative way
we have to stand up and say no because
we know we're going to we're going to
continue to see more people uh come to
us we can't uh address the the all the
need right now but um we also know that
if if you could wrap up that'd be great
sure um that the average state for us is
about 60 days the fact that more and
more people come to us uh uh make it
more difficult for us to place people
uh in housing and uh so for for those
those reasons we oppose this thank you
for your testimony representative Paige
thank you Mr chairman so first and
foremost thank you for your
work um so my question is we we've been
hearing a lot about uh cost to landlords
the cost landlords assume in going
through an eviction process and I'm I'm
sympathetic to that I'm a landlord I
understand what folks are talking about
um we H what we haven't heard a lot
about is the cost of serving folks who
are displaced through bills like this uh
and I'm curious what you've seen in
terms of increased costs um as you're
seeking to serve more and more people
affected by this crisis yes so that
there is um ju just uh in terms of what
we do on a day-to-day basis there's a
cost to that and there's a we we uh our
cost is about $120 a day and that
includes bad meals uh case management
and and so forth um there is additional
cost to the individuals uh that uh would
they they have to pick up from their
communities um bring their children to
the shelter and and all that get disrupt
gets disrupted so breaking up of
communities and families and so forth so
that's huge um and then there's the cost
of trying to get those individuals back
into housing and and what that costs um
one of the things that we believe
believe very strongly in is that uh in
order for us to help both individual
residents and families stay in housing
um and build these really good strong
relationships with landlords there has
to be supportive services and Supportive
Services also come out a cost but we
believe that that is serves the the
tenant and it serves the landlord um in
very strong ways and I think that
there's um as you go forth and you have
these conversations about uh how do we
better house individuals particularly
individuals with uh disabilities mental
health issues and so forth that that has
to be part of the equation and that
comes at a cost so there there are many
costs along the
pipeline any other questions yes
represent read thank you um and thank
you for your testimony and your work uh
which is much needed so we heard uh
testimony from a previous person that in
repeated testimony that this is
something that can be negotiated with
the landlord when you move in you can
negotiate a long contractor or what have
you um is it your experience in the
people that you've worked with that they
felt that and I will just add in the
market that is heavily skewed towards
landlords with 6% vacancy that they felt
empowered or emboldened at all to
negotiate with their
landlords I will say that those
individuals uh who are homeless at our
disadvantage first of all many of them
have been homeless for quite a long time
for a variety of different reasons um we
have to be in partnership with them as
we have these conversations with
landlords so that they feel they they're
getting uh well represented and and they
feel like somebody's looking out for
them um it it is really hard and and we
do this every day to recruit landlords
and to get them to understand or or have
a willingness to work with us um so we
do that on a daily basis and they and
and to the credit of some landlords they
are willing to spend with us and W with
our tenants or with our residents um to
get them rehoused but that is the
exception to the rule we really uh again
what this creates is a bottleneck on the
front line on the front end of things
with the weight list and then on the
back side because we can't place people
fast enough because we have to build
those Rel relationships with landlords
and make them feel comfortable that if
anything goes wrong we're going to be
there for them and if something is
broken in those that apartment that
we're we're going to help them get
through that but that's again an
exception to the rule not all shelters
are able to do that we do that because
we know that um residents sometimes need
that assistance and again we're about
really trying to find a middle ground
between the needs of the landlord and
the needs of the tenant and I think
that's the way forward but right now
where we sit um in our housing um the
our tenants particularly I mean our
residents particularly are at a
disadvantage representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify this morning um in
your
experience uh when you try to get your
clients into housing is it in fact
possible for you and your client to
negotiate the terms of a lease with the
landlord are the landlords willing to
negotiate the terms of a lease for
instance to make it a longer term lease
rather than a one-year
lease um unfortunately I'm not that
familiar with it but I believe that when
we negotiate leases we we are at a
disadvantage again and so we are trying
to negotiate leases that are favorable
to the landlord because we want to make
sure we build that relationship over
time and um I'm guessing but I think
that in most cases they're one-year
leases represent Miner thank you Mr
chairman it goes along the lines of
everything that was basically just
answered but in your experience dealing
with landlords do you find that they
would prefer to do a month-to month even
over a one-year lease because at the end
of the lease they still have to deal
with eviction stuff and it's just more
timec consuming we don't we we don't
commit to one two-month leases because
we don't want people coming back to the
shelter so we're looking at at least a
oneyear lease um with the with the
stipulation that we're going to be there
to work with the tenant over time and
we're going to remain with the tenant as
long as they need us um we we just that
would be awfully traumatizing for a
tenant to get a month Le month-to-month
lease and get evicted have to come back
to the shelters especially a family or
somebody who's elderly disabled um that
that would that would not work well and
that's not something that we pursue can
I just follow up yep would be having the
oneyear lease and the landlords or
housing providers being comfortable with
a one-year lease taking on a risk uh
possibly do you think that
having the ability to terminate it at
the end of the one years if things are
not going well makes them a little more
comfortable even accepting them
well it it it happens sometimes I mean
sometimes those relationships don't work
out and they end up coming back to the
shelter I I will say that in uh 90 about
97% of the cases where we place people
in housing those relationships are are
are successful a year after um so they
stay stably housed so our experience has
been that that they're stably housed but
but I I don't uh see um where we gain
any by having a bill that allows people
to uh terminate uh housing for no cost I
just you know again I I fear that the
roles of the homeless are going to
continue to grow in the state and as we
were already somebody already testified
um we had a 50 52% increase from 2022 to
2023 um we're in a very precarious State
um there you know we have to really care
for our vulnerable population so this is
as much as you know
like I understand the contractual piece
uh and the ownership piece but this is
also a
human um um uh story many I mean all the
people that come to us yeah if you are
ever ever on the Sea Coast and you want
to come in and visit and you want to uh
sit with folks and they can tell you
their individual stories it is you know
uh unfortunate that they're there with
us but um these are very real stories
and they they're they're stories about
people who should not be at a place like
Crossroads
house thank you for your testimony Todd
Marsh good
afternoon my name is Todd Marsh I am the
President president of and uh
representing the New Hampshire local
Welfare Association uh my planned
five-minute remarks will be a bridged
and I understand why um it's great to
see so many familiar faces in front of
me and behind me uh the New Hampshire
local welfare administrator Association
is a professional organization that
educates and supports our Municipal
members to Foster humanitarian and
fiscally responsible assistance
practices uh made up of small towns all
across the state including larger
municipalities as well uh
um page two again a bridged um as you
are as you are aware landlord
protections already exist many already
exist imagine a mother of two lease not
being renewed not because of owed rent
not because of her family's Behavior
damages to her their apartment reporting
mold um or planned Renovations but
because she simply practiced her rights
as a tenant she inqu ired to have the
sink fixed Express concern the
electrical outlet Sparks or she
practiced her rights as a human
being by turning down an unwanted
Advance by her
landlord good luck trying to prove that
all of those lastly imagine a state
where a verified good cause for eviction
is replaced by fear replaced with dis
discretionary retribution resulting in
the loss of a very basic need housing
not not practiced by most landlords of
course not but too
many we have heard from supporters that
an unfair contractual agreement exists
weighted towards renters and not it
weighted towards uh renters and not
landlords as renters can choose not to
renew a lease and landlords cannot
different compared to other types of
contracts why because the ability to end
a very basic need to all of us housing
is a power imbalance heavily weighted in
favor of landlords that is why the
existing law focuses on verifiable
reasons to evict and there are many and
not discretionary ones without cause I'm
going to ask you to wrap up please
absolutely
also in the last three tries the change
has been presented as Pro housing by
increasing landlord discretionary
flexibility giving people the chance uh
at housing that may not they they may
not otherwise have our associate our
association believes that too many
consequences would be outweighed and
outnumbered flexible de in outnumber of
flexible
decisions I will lastly say that I know
all of you support increasing housing
opportunities you are sensitive to
taxpayers increasing housing throughout
our state begins not by not decreasing
housing by closing doors behind our
residents
thank you for your testimony questions
representative
Paige thank you Mr chair so my question
is back to sort of Co the costs question
costs of passing this
bill um are your members in Municipal
Welfare Offices seeing increased costs
with the current surge uh in the UN
unhoused and do you think that we could
see additional costs um in Municipal
Welfare Offices if this bill Le to
additional homelessness we are um and we
do but believe that this bill would lead
to additional
costs representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you so
much for your testimony I find it that
was very um enlightening was there
anything else that you were about to say
it seemed like there were other things
you wanted to
say well I appreciate that um you know I
think as you are aware there are many
reasons to evict and thank you for the
question
uh including neglect or refusal to pay
rent substantial damage to the premises
behavior of a tenant or members of the
tenant's family which adversely
adversely affects health or safety
failure of a tenant to comply with the
material lease of the lease
Renovations uh lead pain abatements and
other good causes thank you there are
many reasons to evict thank you thank
you all right thank you for your
testimony I appreciate it thank you
Elliot Barry
and I see you have written testimonies
perfect we'll take
that okay we'll take that thank
you thank you Mr chairman for the record
my name is Elliot Barry for 47 years I
represented attendants at New Hampshire
legal assistance I suspect there's no
one in the state who has been involved
in more evictions than I have although
not
personally um I just want to just by way
of background understand understand that
what we've been dealing with today has
been in the law for the last 40 years 40
years and landlords appear to be doing
just fine if you look at what rents are
you look at what's vacancy rate but most
important and I know you understand this
Mr
chairman landlord developers are not
withstanding the current law developers
are dying to do more to do more
developing they're not running away from
being landlords
now one of the handouts I gave you is
the eviction law itself RSA 54 section
two and I just want in addition to the
laundry list of specific good causes
there is other good cause and this goes
this is just essential it says it
includes but is not limited to any
legitimate business or economic reason
and need not be based on the action or
inaction of the the tenants in addition
RSA 540 section 16a provides
specifically for a hearsay exception so
when T when a landlord brings a
behavior-based eviction if they keep
basic business records they don't have
to call the
witness
now the one of the things that I think
one of the represent there that may not
there may not be understanding of is
even if there is no leas all landlords
in the state have to have good cause for
eviction except for the few exception
such as owner occupied single family
home I'm sorry owner occupied four unit
or
less um and single family homes
otherwise all tenants leaste or all
tenants whether they're in um any kind
of housing with no lease they still has
to the landlord still has to prove good
cause to evi Mr bar if you could wrap up
for us that'd be great a contract is a
contract the law specifically recognizes
the the adhesion contract where the
bargaining power between the parties is
overwhelmingly uh uh unequal so that
what you get is a take it or leave it
proposition and that's exactly what the
market has
today um I should also mention that the
way the bill is written now it will
eviscerate all good cause protections
because after 6 months every six months
the tenant can be evicted for no cause
at very least no matter what you do at
least extend that to once a year let me
point out that in order to uh to rent a
new apartment you have to have first
month's rent and a security deposit
that's almost $4,000 if you have to do
that twice in a year that's as much in
total income as a person on SSI has
probably three4 of the income of
somebody on Social Security that's just
not doable Mr Barry thank you for your
testimony are questions take any
questions thank
you Nick
Taylor thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm the
director of housing action New Hampshire
we're an organization that advocates for
pro housing policies in increasing
access to housing our members include
developers landlords housing financers
property managers homeless service
providers and Supportive Service
Providers so we run the gamut here we
are in opposition to House Bill 60 I'm
not going to repeat many of the points
that have been made you all know it's a
tight housing market and that if someone
is evicted it's going to be really
challenging for them to find a place to
live that they they can afford in their
Community that's going to lead to more
disruption disruption for their children
in their school system disruption in
their unemployment the status of
employment when we know we have a
Workforce challenge as well there are
many existing legal Avenues as has been
discussed to evict someone there is also
uh free mediation for eviction and
eviction diversion at the judicial
system so there are Avenues to deal with
challenges there's no reason to create
more housing instability at a moment
when Market is unlike anything we have
ever seen we look forward to working
with this Committee in the coming weeks
and months on a lot of Regulation to
increase access to housing this is not
one of them we urge you to vote in
opposition to this bill and happy to
take any questions thank you Mr Taylor
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Jake
Barry and I believe Judith Jones
together
I know there's two of you but I ask to
just keep your testimony short as short
as you can
please we can certainly do one at a time
if you'd prefer but uh Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is Jake Barry this is my colleague
Judith Jones we both work for new
Futures which as many of you know is a
nonprofit nonpartisan Health policy and
advocacy organization in addition to our
work around substance use and Healthcare
access we are New Hampshire's kids count
organization and we lead the policy work
for the New Hampshire Alliance for
healthy aging all this to say we
advocate for health and wellbeing across
the Lifetime and we strongly oppose this
bill as it threatens to undermine the
health and well-being of all the
populations we aim to serve Judith is
going to talk in for a minute about the
Deep Impact uh on Aging adults uh but I
want to representative uh Lynn pointed
out that eviction is a onetoone exchange
but when considering that I think it's
critical to consider who who is coming
in and who is going out more to the
point who is a preferred tenant is a
preferred tenant uh family with young
children is it somebody who's
experiencing in treatment for substance
use disorder Behavioral Health is it an
aging adult on a fixed income and what
options are available to them should
they be evicted I I will say any of
these folks who lose uh who lose housing
and not only not only they lose housing
stability that it directly impacts their
a their access to child care to Health
Care Services uh and to the Aging
Services that J Judith is going to point
out I can't imagine why we are in the
midst of a housing homelessness housing
and homelessness crisis like we are a
child care crisis like we are an aging
crisis like we are why we would do away
with this basic B uh uh basic tenant
protection and with that I'll turn it
over to Judith good morning I'm so
grateful to be before you I know you're
tired and I'm probably hungry so let me
be quick many people have highlighted
the impact to older adults in New
Hampshire but thought just two
statistics might be helpful in this
nation the fastest growing population of
unhoused are the elderly in New
Hampshire the report from the New
Hampshire coalition to in houseless
homelessness in 2024 show shows that
this is happening in New Hampshire what
did it show that there's an increase in
homelessness for
individuals who are 55 and older of 23%
from 2019 to 2022 so what we're talking
about today is not hypothetical the
other theme that you've heard that's
important is that these are human
stories but I know this body having
grown up in New Hampshire thankfully is
impacted by human sto stories but these
human stories are also economic stories
so human hardship results in economic
hardship so want just to
translate that honoring the need for
economic stability for older adults and
that house bill 60 would increase inst
stability increase costs through Health
impacts create isolation and
disenfranchisement so we stand strong in
our opposition to House Bill 60 well
thank you for the two of you for
testimony are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank
you Jessica marginson and I'm going to
call on Rachel gagy as well to come up
and
speak
maybe good afternoon now um my name is
thank you my name is Jessica
Marson and I am here um as myself or by
myself with Rachel though to oppose hb60
I'm going to hurry up and get through um
with what I like to would like to speak
on what I commonly like to do is listen
to
everybody's um speech
and try
and um
make there's sometimes there's
misinformation and I don't think they
mean it as misinformation but when you
withhold a few words or you say things a
certain way it could be mistaken and I
think that you guys um need some of the
answers better um so and a background on
why I'm able to answer these um the way
I am I have run a tenant Clinic out of
Manchester since um September 27th
2022 and in that course I've even helped
two tenants win their Supreme Court
appeal so I've seen many different types
of court cases um and how long they last
and what the problems are and why they
don't go through for some of these
landlords and a lot of times it is
discrimination or they apply the law
incorrectly don't do the right dates
don't do the right time so when Mi um Mr
Nick Norman spoke about very difficult
to evict tenants stuff like disturbance
there there's right to quiet enjoyment
of premises so there's a very quick
eviction um one of the quickest out
there so if you're uh harming the
property you're dealing drugs you're a
threat to your neighbors um that is easy
to prove with a little bit of effort you
have some cameras you have police logs
documentation it takes documentation
like it takes due diligence to pick out
the right tenants for your buildings it
takes effort um the other things I'd
like to make sure I speak on are Noah
naturally occurring affordable housing
so a majority of our housing was lost um
through renovation evictions we saw how
renovation evictions were used used at
their will and as they spoke when it's
hard to evict a tenant one way the legal
way that is used to make sure it goes
through we've heard that before um many
landlords commonly prefer not to resign
a lease and keep the tenant month to-
month they are then able to raise the
rent as needed if they want to get that
tenant out of there they have good cause
evictions and they can also price that
tenant out which I've seen many times
I'd also like to remind everybody
um tenants might get upset when they
hear that the landlords have had it hard
when we've had our rent almost more than
doubled in many occasions especially
with that naturally occurring affordable
housing I'd like to remind that the
largest portion of the homeless um I'm
sorry I'm trying to hurry and it's
making it harder for me to actually
speak properly um the largest portion of
the homeless population is elderly and
disabled which also takes up the lowest
of the Ami um and what that brings me to
is
um the length of time it takes to find
an apartment commonly I hear of those
with modest means talking about it
taking them up to 3 months to find an
apartment 3 months being very common
those are those with 100% area median
income and up so when you're speaking
about those with the lowest at 30% to
50% area median income which is your
fixed income such as me and Rachel here
um those take commonly a year Rachel
took well over a year to find her
apartment many of my tenants have um I'd
also like to speak about the human
rights violation I have a tenant that
over a year ago the eviction process was
started but before it was started she
was sent messages from her landlord
telling her that the apartment is not
for disabled people I can tell you that
in 17 years of doing this it's not very
common to get it and writing so
explicitly and direct but even with
something that explicit and direct it's
been well over a year and there's been
no movement on that um complaint but
what has happened to the tenant in that
time period is they went through the
court process they got evicted they
appealed to Supreme Court there was a
the appeals are hard for tenants to go
through I can't do it for them I can
show them how I can lead them to the
water it's their path to go forward with
that
some things were um done wrong she had
it dismissed on her she was locked out
the rid of possession I'd also like to
remind you when um the person spoke
about tenants not paying rent soon as
you a victim once you go to court and
you argue for a discretionary stay
there's a thing called pay to stay you
don't pay you don't stay you don't pay
they go to court and they move to get
the rid of possession it may take 2 to
three weeks for that to actually happen
but they're going to be out of there
they're getting their money to stay and
commonly it also includes the amount of
back rent that is owed to the
landlord um Miss margus I'm going ask
you to wrap up if you could yes
sir um so many landlords um I can't
speak to why they do
it um hold on there there's one last
thing if I can pick just one last thing
oh the biggest thing there is no safety
net for those who are disabled or
elderly none whatsoever I have watched
Mr Elliot Barry argue for a client that
had just recently had brain surgery
couldn't walk up her steps was
discriminated against herass and it was
a retell eviction he fought to keep her
in there and it was very hard but it was
the laws that are in place such as the
ones we have now that keep these tenants
protected and in their homes and they're
there because sometimes they're not done
correctly sometimes they're used as
retaliation and it's there to be able to
spot it stop it it and do the right
thing thank you thank you Miss gagy
would you like to add some
quicker hi my name is Rachel Gagney and
I live in
Manchester and um I'm here to speak on
hb60 myself I was here last year about
it and um to me that law if you pass it
you're just going to cause more problems
because you're going to end up with more
homeless people than you do now because
the landlord is going to use it like
like a weapon okay it's going to be very
easy very access accessible to them that
you're going to end up with more people
out on the street because what happens
every time you get evicted that gets put
on your record and it's like a like a um
a bad scar that you cannot get rid of
right and every time my landlord sees a
new scar they're not going to want to
talk to you they just going to push you
aside till eventually you just end up
with nothing nobody's going to want to
talk to you no you give you a chance to
look at a place just because you have
that scar on your record you know and it
it's not right it's not fair especially
if you didn't do
anything I got evicted for renovation I
didn't do nothing wrong it took me 2
years to find the place that I had have
now and it needs maintenance work
landlord won't do anything
the real estate company don't do
anything but you pass this law My Le
gets comes to an end next
march they could easily just kick me out
just cuz I complained that my heat
stopped working during the course of the
winter it stopped when the temperature
dropped really bad it stopped working I
was just lucky I had space heaters I
could use they've yet to fix it the
Plumbing's all screwed up they've yet to
fix that so come next march if I keep
complaining about it you pass this law
they can evict me then what do I
do I can't do
nothing it took took me two years the
first time to find an apartment how long
is it going to take me this time you
know what I mean you can't do that it's
not fair not for fair at all for any
tenant it's I'm disabled my husband's
disabled I got my granddaughter with me
that's 13 she's she's handicapped
herself so it's even harder for the
three of
us you know so a normal
person they might have a little bit
more easier but for us it'd be even
harder because we don't make that love
well thank you for your testimony are
there questions for these two
witnesses seeing none thank you very
much I hope I gave you enough time go
ahead can I add something really quick
that I forgot I find it really ironic
since I told you I like to um add to
what was said while I was sitting there
waiting for my turn and someone
mentioned that developers um are not
very incentivized I actually got an
email from a developer that's trying to
do a project in Manchester seeing if
there's anything new out there as
incentives that's how much they're
looking forward to developing that I got
that message while I was sitting here
during this thank you thank
you uh Jack
rman thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Jack rudderman
I'm the legislative affairs advisor at
New Hampshire housing New Hampshire
housing is a self-supporting public
corporation our mission is to promote
support and finance Housing Solutions
for the people of New
Hampshire um this bill raises the issue
of whether or not a supreme court state
supreme court uh case decided in
2005 uh was decided correctly I'm not
going to weigh in on the legal argument
I just want to speak briefly about um
the housing market that we are in uh and
what we know about it as a Housing
Organization that actively researches uh
the state of the housing market um and
issues like um annual rental costs and
changes in costs um Supply uh factors um
and and numerous other characteristics
of the housing market so you've heard
already the market we're in right now is
very tight we did a housing needs
assessment a couple years back and it
found that by 20 by
2030 the state will need 60,000 new
units of housing to meet the state's
housing needs by 2040 we will need
990,000 new units of
housing we're not building enough units
of housing to hit those numbers if we
look at the number of building permits
issued over the last five decades we see
that in the mid
1980s there were roughly 18,000 build
permits issued per year in the Years
2000 through 2005 that number was around
8,000 and even though that was um a
sharp reduction from what we had seen in
the mid 80s when we look at the last uh
five years well actually 2018 to
2023 um we are now building just over
4,000 units per
year um other speakers have mentioned
that the vacancy rate for rentals is
very low it's below 1% I just want to
note that economists generally consider
a housing market to be inbalance um for
there to be fairly um uh equal uh Market
power between landlords and tenants um
that kind of a market exists when there
is a 5% vacancy
record vacancy rate sorry um and we
haven't been there for for quite some
time so um we do know that there's an
imbalance right now
um the landlords uh unit owners uh have
most of the power for renters the the
market is um in a word brutal there are
very few units available uh and what
that means in in Practical effects and
again people have already said this um
so I will get through this very quickly
um if you lose an apartment in today's
market there's a substantial risk you
will have trouble finding a new
apartment or finding the financial
resources to rent a new apartment and
therefore there's a substantial
likelihood that you will become homeless
so that's the market we're seeing those
are the practical impacts that that
we're aware of and I thank you very much
for your time and attention for the past
two and a quarter hours thank you Mr
rman questions seeing none thank
you um Marta
Horan hey everyone my name is Marta
heran um a few people have said they're
not lawyers good news I am so if you
have questions about the legal process
I'm happy to answer them I'll be very
brief I work at New Hampshire legal
assistance I'm a housing attorney we
represent tenants occasionally landlords
it um and I just want to briefly explain
a little bit that when I go into court
what I tell tenants and most tenants
don't have a lawyer but when they have
me what I tell them is um you're in a
tough spot already as a tenant but if
your landlord has good cause they also
have to prove it to a judge that it's a
legitimate reason and with this if this
law passes what's going to happen is if
people are outside their lease term
which many tenants are at this point I
would say most tenants their lease
expires and if they remain on as
month-to-month tenants and they go into
court and they say I complained about my
heat like we just heard from another
tenant or I have children that are loud
or I have a mental disability that makes
people uncomfortable and if I say has
your lease expired and they say yes I'm
going to say too bad this eviscerates
that retaliation argument this
eviscerates whatever you know good cause
we may have to pursue that this is not a
legitimate eviction because the judge
will say you know I'll say you know
judge this tenant complained about her
heat two months later she got an
eviction notice a week later she got an
eviction notice when her children were
too loud for the people below her and
the judge will say has your lease
expired yes the end you know the end it
doesn't matter if you complain about
your heat it doesn't matter if your
children were loud it doesn't matter if
you're in an interraci interracial
relationship what matters to a judge if
this law passes is has your lease
expired that will be the end of the
eviction hearing cuz what else is there
so you haven't paid your rent why would
anyone bring an eviction notice for that
you get an eviction notice sooner but
with this you don't have to prove
anything it's not hard to evict people
in New Hampshire this is what I tell our
tenants as well if your landlord is
motivated and you're outside your lease
term you will be evicted it's not hard
okay they want to increase your rent to
something you can't afford they want to
take it off the market no one has to be
a landlord in New Hampshire you're going
to court and tell a judge I don't want
to be a landlord anymore great rid of
possession you're going to go and tell I
want my aunt to move in okay rid of
possession they can't pay the rent rid
of possession they're making my neighbor
uncomfortable rid of possession it's not
hard the only thing we have right now is
to prove to a judge that this is
retaliatory this is discrimination and
we've made a lot of work in New
Hampshire to make it so that tenants
have the ability to do that right now
and if you pass this law what am I
supposed to do as an attorney what am I
going to tell tenants here here that
will be the the convers we have when
people apply for our services has your
lease expired there is nothing we can do
for you period and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you attorney hjan our
questions representative
kwin hi thank you chair um
representative Lynn when he was up here
he said that with
hb60 that a tenant who had paid the rent
and stayed for years with permission of
the landlord could be evicted with no
cause um and that means that a tenant
who had done everything right um up till
then could end up with an eviction on
the record how much harder would an
eviction on a record make it for someone
to find housing especially in this very
tight Market I mean it makes it it makes
it impossible I mean a lot of the work
we do now if we interview a client and
think there's legitimate reasons for
eviction that they haven't paid their
rent or that the landlord actually
intends to renovate most of what we do
right now is negotiate move out
agreements for the exact reason you
articulated that if you go into court
and are evicted even if it's for
renovation for no fault of your own to
apply to the next apartment and have to
check the box on the application that
says I've been evicted that's usually
the end of the conversation with a
prospective landlord we tell people you
can advocate for yourself and explain
the reason but I mean in this rental
market you know it basically makes it
impossible so a lot of our job already
is negotiating move out agreements
that's pretty much what we do to
preserve people's housing Choice
vouchers and to make it possible for
them to find another rental apartment my
job as a lawyer right now is usually
delivering bad news and negotiating move
out of agreements and I'm and I
represent you know New Hampshire legal
is represents you know 1% of tenants in
New Hampshire the vast majority don't
have our help at all and they will go
into court and get a and get an eviction
judgment on their rental history which
isn't like a criminal history but it's
what most landlords rely on in this
tight Market to find their next
tenant represent Paige thank you Mr
chair I just want to make sure I'm
understanding clearly um because we've
talked a little bit about retaliation
and I appreciate that you're here to
answer that question
um so we've heard several examples of
people expressing concern about sort of
an underlying reason for the eviction
right um sort of a covert reason whether
that's talking about something not
working in the
apartment uh you know a denied unwanted
sexual advance from the landlord any
kind of you know discrimination based on
a protected
class so if I'm hearing you
correctly my understanding is basically
there will be no point in trying to
prove that that eviction is retaliatory
should this law come into place as a
practitioner weekly in New Hampshire
district courts doing landlord tenant
law thank you for question repres page
that would be my assumption of how this
law would function in practice if a
tenant is outside their lease term or
their lease has expired if they're
currently in a six-month lease which
don't exist at this point which may at
this if those law passes unfortunately
but let's say they're in a 12mon Le I
would argue that there's still a need to
be good cause like non-payment of rent
they violate a lease term there's
adverse behavior and if a landlord had
to prove one of those reasons I think it
would raise the opportunity for a tenant
or their attorney to raise the prospect
that this is retaliatory for one of the
reasons you articulated like raising a
concern about a code violation or other
discriminatory reasons however if a
tenants lease has expired and they're
being evicted for lease expir you know
their the lease has expired I don't see
how a tenant could really articulate
this this is retaliatory because if this
is quote unquote just contract law how
can you retaliate for the end of a
contract right so I think if this law
goes into effect what a district court
judge is going to say they'll have a new
form on their box that they check when
they do these judgments is has the lease
expired and is that the reason for the
eviction how could you say this is
because I complained about the rent
because the the judge is going to say
well under RSA 542 you know parentheses
J if the lease has expired that's good
cause for eviction what further inquiry
would I need to make to determine if
there's lawful grounds for eviction
because this reason has been clearly
articulated in this new statute so I
don't see how retaliation could be a
successful defense to something that's
quote unquote just the end of a contract
I as a practitioner I don't see how that
would be a successful argument in the
vast majority of district courts and may
have to go up to the Supreme Court to
articulate some sort of way that could
be successful but as someone who
practices these cases currently I see no
path forward for retaliation once El
leas has expired under this current law
thank you representative Daxton
this was interesting
so you and this has come up before but
where is this eviction record I I'm I've
been a landlord for almost 35 years in
this state and there is is there the you
mentioned several times an eviction
record I don't know where that would be
can you tell me yeah that's a great
question so unlike criminal records
which um are you know federal and state
records that someone can request if
someone signs a release there is no
quote unquote eviction record as as
people use it colloquially there are
certain private websites like landlord
connection or other private websites
that a lot of landlords use they either
use landlord reporting or sometimes they
scrub court records to try to find what
are often perhaps inaccurate summaries
of whether tenants have been evicted or
not more commonly I think the way I I
use the term eviction record in talking
to our clients and tenants is when you
apply for an apartment almost all
applications will say have you been
evicted or not so that question in sense
is your tenant record you could lie and
say no and hoping that no one ever
figures it out but there is a way they
could because it's a public court record
so anyone can go into a district court
or call the court Paul Center and say
hey has Mar hon ever had an eviction
case and by law that's a public record
and they would tell the landlord yes or
no Mart Heron has had an eviction
judgment against so there are ways that
tenant landlords can verify whether
tenants are being honest about whether
they're evicted or not because those are
all public records in New Hampshire and
kept by the court system followup yes
well given all right that makes sense
okay but this law doesn't the way this
is being you're discussing this is that
somehow this mandates an eviction if I
have a tenant and I send them 60 days
notice of termination and they go and we
don't go to court that's not an eviction
that's just termination of
tency well just as if a tenant gave me
no notice and said hey I'm my lease is
up on March 31st and I'm out of here so
yes and no as always the law is is
slightly more complicated I suppose than
that if a tenant leaves before the
eviction notice expires many landlords
do not pursue the eviction in District
Court because they already have
possession of the apartment the issue in
a district court landlord tenant
eviction hearing is who gets to possess
the apartment however this doesn't
change the judicial process in New
Hampshire if a tenant gets an eviction
notice because their lease has expired
and they remain in the apartment which
they are allowed to do by law after the
eviction notice has expired the landlord
under this law still has to take the
tenant to court file the court CA this
another reason I would say this saves
the landlords no money because you still
have to take a tenant to court to evict
them in New Hampshire whether it's
because their lease has expired or
because they didn't pay their rent so I
would say this doesn't really save
landlord's money it doesn't necessarily
make landlord's life easier as far as
the eviction process goes because they
still need to file the judicial process
and get a judgment against a tenant
before they can lawfully remove them
from the property I'm sorry but I yep
real quick so this law says provided
that the landlord has provided the
tenant with a written notice of at least
60 days in advance of the termination of
date of the lease term that the lease
will not be renewed and that the tenant
must vacate the rental property at the
end of the lease term why would I need
to go to court well if you read my my
former colleague Elliott Barry gave you
the RSA 540 statute if you read the rest
of the statute there are certain
processes that the landlord must follow
with giving a written eviction notice
served in hand with a proper amount of
notice upon expiration of this isn't an
eviction notice this is a notice of
termination I mean what you're proposing
would completely officer all of oursa
540s so I hope that's not representative
just if you could just ask a question if
you have one my understanding I'm not
I'm not trying to be argumentative but
my understanding is this would simply
add another reason for eviction under
RSA 542 but the rest of the statute in
RSA 540 as part as far as how you serve
the court process would remain in effect
so this would simply be another easier
potentially reason that a landlord could
put on the eviction notice but the rest
of the statute would remain in his
effect as far as the procedure that the
landlord would have to follow that's my
understanding of reading this Statute in
conjunction with the rest of RSA 540 uh
representative Howland I'll be super
sucin um you brought up you said that
the majority of renters are actually on
a month-to-month lease they're not on a
or a month to they're leases expired
they're on month-to month they're not on
a formalized lease is that correct my my
my anecdotal experience is that most
people sign a 12-month lease and then
once that lease expires this isn't
always the case some landlords and
tenants are very on it and as soon as
that lease expires they do another one
another 12-month lease usually with a
slight rent increase right but a lot of
time tenant the lease expires in
February the landlord or property
manager has a lot of other properties
and as we've heard today in New
Hampshire the laws you just convert to a
month-to-month tency all the prior lease
terms remain in effect really the only
thing that's lost when you become a
month-to-month tenant is the ability for
your landlord to increase the rent with
30 days written notice so I I wouldn't
say all um you know people are in a
month-to-month tency but I think
especially for a tenant that has been in
a property for a fair amount of time a
year two years three years at a certain
point point you know everyone's happy
with how things are going hopefully and
they become a month-to-month tenant or
there's a there's a lapse between when
the lease has expired oh yeah I forgot
that Joe Smith in apartment C hasn't
done a lease yet and maybe five or six
months later they they didn't they
negotiate a new lease but a lot of
people are in month-to-month tencies and
as rep represent Lynn testified and I
would agree under the the way the
statute is written and as represent kin
has um pointed out through some
questioning you could become a
month-to-month tenant and be a
month-to-month tenant for years and then
you could get an eviction notice to
remember when your lease expired back in
2014 yeah we're good now we're going
forward on that so it it it just takes
away that um you know there's no
obligation for anyone just like there's
no obligation for anyone to be a
landlord no obligation for anyone to be
under a lease in New Hampshire um so I
think a lot of people are in
month-to-month tencies and this could
come as a complete surprise that a this
is a reason they can be evicted and B
it's because their leas expired four
years
ago representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question is there since you're a lawyer
I've been waiting for a lawyer to come I
mean Mr Barry was here and I I didn't
take the
opportunity um we're hearing a lot about
how honorous it is to be a landlord how
terrible and and very put upon they are
and I'm just wondering if you know of
any law since you're a lawyer that
forces landlords to rent out units in
this current legal environment where
they would have to honor a good tenant
past the the lease and that it being
part of the actual contract I I would
say I'm aware of No Such law and again
uh Elliot Barry passed out the current
eviction statute along with the current
eviction form the administrative office
of the courts makes it very
straightforward for people to understand
and follow the eviction process there
are free legal forms for the eviction
notice free forms for the demand for
rent um these cases happen quickly by
law hearings are scheduled within 10
days if someone is facing an eviction
for a reason like non-payment of rent or
adverse Behavior which is a 7-Day notice
itions can can happen within 3 to four
weeks I think it would be incredibly
inaccurate to say the majority of these
take a year six months the the most the
longest time when we usually see is is
two to three months depending on the uh
reason for the notice most happen within
uh four
weeks yep thank you Mr chair um so what
I'm hearing and if you can the question
is for you to confirm this that uh while
there is no law and therefore landlords
are not forced to to be landlords or
rent out anything if the legal situation
is not favorable or profitable for them
people don't have a choice as to whether
or not they need housing is that
accurate unfortunately in New Hampshire
as a lawyer I would say there's no right
to housing anywh follow up last
yep and uh last question in all of your
experience with um representing tenants
against landlords how often were
landlord willing to negotiate what we
would consider I guess unusual terms of
their lease like you can stay here for
five years or 10 years or um anything
else that wouldn't be how often did your
your clients to put another way feel
empowered to make that that kind of
negotiation obviously we see a small
slice of of what uh most tenants in New
Hampshire face I've been a litigator for
12 years in the courts of New Hampshire
I've done housing law for about five
years I've never seen a lease longer
than 12 months ever I've never seen at
least longer than 12 months I never
spoken to any client who had at least
longer than 12 months I've represented
hundreds of tenants at this point um I
would say the vast majority or anyone
I've represented is 12 months or month a
month representative Gibs did you have a
question thank you Mr chair
representative re's last question was
the one I wanted to ask wonderful I love
that well thank you very much for your
testimony um Claudia Isel
and just a reminder for the committee I
don't plan on breaking for lunch so if
you need to go get something to eat
please feel free I will power through I
had a cliff bar Life's good so if feel
free to go and and come back but go
ahead hi I'm Claudia stelle and thank
you um chairman Alexander and members of
the committee for hearing my testimony
um I'm a member of the academic Justice
mission team from the United Church of
Christ New Hampshire conference and I'm
here on behalf of our group to speak
against the bill
um we the United Church of Christ is
formerly known as congregationalists and
we represent um 140,000 congregants in
the state economic Justice is really
important to us in our denomination and
shelter is a basic human need and is a
right um included in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights even if it
isn't considered right in the state of
New Hampshire I've just going to try to
summarize a few things because a lot of
things that I have spoken about are in
my testimony that I submitted on the
portal so you all have that
electronically um I think secure housing
is really important to well-being of
people to have an address allows people
to apply for jobs to and services more
easily having housing is necessary to
maintaining health and hygiene so that
people are clean and ready to go to work
and school and feel secure in being a
part of the community and to be
self-reliant independent contributing
members of society people need a home
base for safety for protection from the
elements for freedom to personalize
their living space a place to care for
their family proximity to work to be a
part of the community with neighbors
local schools and social groups um we've
already heard about Elders families and
uh dis abled people as needing to have
house particularly needing to have
housing and if people are evicted I I
think the landlord tenant um
relationship is one of unequal power
landlords having more power than tenants
um and so tenants are always going to
worry about whether their housing is
secure and that means that they have to
put more energy into work into the
stress of
being able to maintain their housing
then need to be able to focus on doing a
good job um go doing well in school
taking care of their
families um I they think that this bill
is bad for the New Hampshire economy
we've already heard about the housing
situation and the homelessness rate um
it does fall on municipalities to take
care of the Indigent and that further
stretch is uh local budgets um and it
will cause increases in property taxes
which are already straining property
owners and particularly those on fixed
incomes so we do need to have solutions
to housing that don't exacerbate the
difficulties it's important to protect
both the landlords and the tenants but I
think that this bill would deteriorate
the fabric of community for
everyone thank you very much for your
testimony
um are there
questions say none thank you very much
uh Wendy
Santiago take your time getting up here
so my name is Wendy Santiago I reside in
conquered New Hampshire and I currently
rent from a privately owned apartment
complex here in conquered New Hampshire
I have lived there for um over a decade
without any form of um retaliation or
harassment until 2021 when this bill
when this bill I'm assuming just today I
learned started about that time frame um
I have been harassed by my management
office they have um come to my apartment
complex they've listened through my
doors they have tracked my coming my
going they have harassed me about my
handicapped parking spot um recently in
2021 I relapsed in my cancer which
caused a significant disability I've had
doctor letter doctor notes multiple of
them sent to my management office
requesting that I should be on a first
floor due to my disability on
fortunately because they have denied
that claim and increased harassment
instead in hopes that I'd move out
because they have no reason to throw me
out um I've had to get legal aid which
my attorney is present in this in this
room
um
so also um I feel that when I go to talk
about the Discrimination I've been told
that um we don't accommodate people like
your kind um maybe you need to go find
other apartments that do um this is a
sheare form of
discrimination this um experience has
directly violated my fundamental human
rights especially the New Hampshire
human right laws that prohibit housing
discrimination based on multiple aspects
um including disability and harassment
um I also want to mention that has not
yet been mentioned here is that the
Declaration of Independence uh grants me
the right to pursue happiness life and
Liberty unfortunately House Bill uh 6 UH
60 um infringes on my rights to to life
because housing uh secure housing is not
a luxury as it's been kind of portrayed
here by those who are for the bill um
but it's a necessary for survival um the
ability to write to Liberty this bill uh
re uh restricts personal freedom by
allowing landlord to discriminate
against tenants based on abtory factors
or any way they want to um this bill
also p uh refering on my rights to
pursue happiness a stable home is a
foundation for building a a fulfillment
Life House Bill 60 jeopardizes the
rights to create
environments um infringes on the rights
to have an environment free of fear and
um free of feeling uncertain about your
living arrangements even though I'm
currently on Section 8 Housing and that
is why they don't want me there they
want the living working individual there
and not according to her management
office we don't want our taxes to pay
for your housing quote unquote um I am a
full-time college student at Liberty
University I'm pursuing a graduate
degree in clinical mental health because
I see there's a crisis here this bill
will not only increase the crisis of
mental health and housing as people will
become homeless but also infringe on the
rights of um myself as well as my son
who is also a full-time college student
he's 16 finishing High School through
the early college program he's also a
student pilot and was just inducted into
the National Honor Society and
Leadership that would not have been able
to happen if we were homeless I'm I also
would like to point out the factor that
hasn't been said um we already have a
crisis as we already talked about with
the homeless situation we've already
talked about the employment situation
and other things but we haven't talked
about the child protective crisis that
we have it is not illegal to be homeless
and have children but it is illegal to
have your children living on the street
and in a car with the homeless crisis
right now and shelters that are being
filled vers both single and family
shelters there going to be a very big
increase of unnecessary children going
into foster care in the simple aspect of
we don't want you living here are we
willing to trade our dignity our uh
direct um independent rights from our
rights from the Declaration of indep
attendance are we willing to trade our
children and to the foster care system
just because somebody doesn't want us
living there for whatever reasons in my
case it's because I'm on Section 8
Housing and I'm disabled and they don't
want people like my kind living in their
apartment when I have never been late on
rent I have never been evicted I've been
there for over 13 years and even when I
was in the hospital for over nine months
I still paid my rent and made sure it
was on time that says a lot more than
those who actually have jobs who have
evictions and could have paid their rent
I I have a very limited income and I
still made that but yet I'm still being
harassed to the point where basically
it's just so I leave I'm not the only
victim at my apartment complex there are
multiple victims that I know of most of
them fall in the category of um
race um income um and um children who
might be too loud these are all the
people that I know um that have been
victim of this particular management
office um they've and this is her
maladaptive pattern to use harassment as
a way of forcing someone to leave um
Miss Santiago I'm going to ask you to
wrap up if you could please thank you I
appreciate your the time um so um I just
wanted to say um since I've had legal
aid involved I was able to move within
30 days um to a new apartment complex
which I was only given two weeks to move
um she did uh make a way that I would
have 30 days to move versus 14 days but
um in the aspect of Section 8 housing if
someone were to get evicted they only
have 30 days to find a place and it is
very difficult to find a place you will
lose your housing which would
increase the hardship for those who are
on certain incomes but since I've moved
I have been continuously harassed and
the pictures that I asked for the quote
unquote damages to the other apartment
she has manipulated and falsified those
evidence of those photos by transferring
them into black and white changing the
dates and times Etc so but I'm going to
be working that out with my attorney
okay any questions are there questions
for this
witness representative
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the question I thought it was really
interesting that you brought up the
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness um are you aware
that in some elements of the Housing
Community there's a couple sayings one
is in at least in Europe uh housing
first and the other one is housing is
health care because they tie it to the
fact that if you lose your housing you
lose everything else whether that is
your your um hygiene personal hygiene
decreases your access to even getting a
job decreases your access to healthcare
decreases your mental health gets worse
your physical health gets worse all of
those things being entwined and all of
those things impinging on your ability
to live were you aware that there that
that has already been highlighted and
those are those sayings that exist for
that reason um appears that there's a
few questions there I'll answer them one
at a time um I wasn't aware of the two
uh things at housing first and the other
one that you mentioned um but I was
aware that when you're evicted you lose
all your dignity your ability to work
your ability to go to school your
ability to function and my my case I'm
in the hospital a lot I just got back
out of the hospital um December 31st
because of my cancer is in my immune
system I don't fight well I will have
immune therapy But to answer your
question I didn't realize the other
portion but I did realize the second
half of your
question thank you very much um thank
you for your testimony Jane hey did you
want to I see her leaving the room did
you want to testify you're next on the
list next yes thank you for your
testimony thank you very much for
allowing me to
speak I have one more person after this
so think we're wrapping up just gonna
give
up
um so uh my name is Jane hey and I live
in Manchester in Ward one and this is
really just my own testimony although I
do work with the Manchester housing
Alliance and I think as you all know um
we're mostly concerned with having more
affordable housing but
um representative Lynn is trying to make
this about contracts kind of legal
issues with contracts and um I just ask
you to not lose sight of the fact that
it's really about
housing which everybody's mentioned that
and I I um I definitely believe it's
going to make the evictions worse people
are going to become homeless that
wouldn't have to become homeless it's
really a burden on all of us who are
taxpayers because when people first
become homeless or they're threatened
with homelessness they turn to the local
welfare
agencies who usually can't help them
very much or the homeless shelters which
we also
support um so we're in the midst of a
housing crisis and I just have no idea
why you would vote on a bill that will
make it worse I I mean in 5 years maybe
we'll get to a point of a 5% vacancy
rate I would love to see that but at the
moment um we're just um this is just
going increase the chances for people to
become evicted and endanger housing for
as people have said housing for seniors
the
disabled um and I think it just points
to um
fundamental dichotomy in the issue of
housing itself where it's both business
for people who own these buildings and a
private property right for them as they
attempt to rent them out but it's also
they also agree when they take on this
particular business to provide homes for
people and I think that we can't allow
landlords to lose sight of the fact that
they have a responsibility to people who
they're who they're providing homes for
so as people have said it threatens the
stability of communities it threatens
health of people who are being evicted
and um I think I don't have a whole lot
else to add but I would take questions
appreciate your testimony thank you are
there questions for Miss he seeing none
thank you very much thank you um I have
two cards from Chris
Freeman yeah I got one card you suppose
you support an oppose and the other one
you oppose so if you just give us two
minutes that' be two great sorry for the
confusion with the extra card over there
I'll also apologize in advance for uh
any nervousness normally when I choose
to punt it ate my Victim audience is my
mother or my boyfriend and uh their Vibe
is like not nearly as Stern as it is in
here so we're trying not to be Stern but
they um I'm also going to try to give
you I'm here all day to testify on
several of these bills I'm going to try
and give you um a few premises and a
little background up front I'll still
try to keep it within time um so my name
is is Chris Freeman um I wear a few
different hats I have a full-time career
in in corporate finance um I am also the
owner and executive manager of Bell
Tower Property Management which I like
to use the word Boutique because it
makes me sound fancy but it's a small uh
real estate investment company based at
aen New Hampshire but we have footprint
uh along the Connecticut River Valley we
have um couple properties in Lebanon New
Hampshire and um we are under contract
to move into uh Walpole New Hampshire as
well um and then in addition to that uh
I also am a participant in the madok
resource Alliance uh which is a
coalition organized underneath the
umbrella of the madn United Way uh and
partnership with the Community Loan Fund
and a coalition of banks nonprofits and
businesses operating within the manok
region um I want to be clear that today
I'm representing my own views I'm not
representing the views of the MRA um I
think we've agreed that there's going to
be a lot of diversity in the different
opinions of people within that group so
I'll uh I'll preface everything that I
say with that um the other thing I want
to share as a little bit of background
is um the nature of my business so we
we're a little bit Niche um we
specialize in furnished room rentals uh
which we call co-living and so uh
typically what we'll do is we'll take
you know some of these bigger older
Apartments four bedroom apartments and
we will uh outfit them almost like it's
an Airbnb so they're fully furnished
they include all utilities and services
and then we we demise those properties
on uh individual bedroom leases and um I
kind of got into that uh facing my own
challenges with the housing
affordability issues in the area back in
2016 where prices make you know the
prices today look comparatively pretty
horrible
um and the objective is to create a
market-based affordable alternative uh
for folks that are trying to navigate
the the current housing environment um
with this being kind of a more
affordable price point for folks than
going and getting a studio or a
one-bedroom by themselves um we do have
a tendency to work with uh candidates
who might be viewed as marginal if they
were going to be applying for a
one-bedroom apartment um particularly on
the basis of income uh as others have
pointed out in in Keen one-bedroom
apartment is $1,500 you need to make
$4,500 a month to be able to afford that
we have furnished allinclusive rooms
starting as low as you know 765 which if
you're starting at Wendy's um you can
afford um so I'm going to try and kind
of go through a few quick points high
level if you could yeah um that'd be
great so uh let me see where do I want
to
focus um generally speaking I'm in favor
of really strong property rights it's
one of the reasons that I choose to
invest and and keep all of our money in
New Hampshire uh where we are positioned
on the Connecticut River Valley we can
very easily cross over into Vermont if
we decide that the housing regulations
that are in Vermont are acceptable to us
and whenever we consider that Prospect
we look at the strength of the property
rates over there and we think about how
would this affect our decisions when it
comes to approving rental applications
generally speaking my reaction is
somebody that you know cares a lot about
housing access is that we would have to
have tougher approval criteria in
Vermont in order to protect our business
interests than what we're willing to
accept here in New Hampshire and that's
going to be a recurring theme throughout
my testimony here today is that at the
end of the day an occupied rental unit
is fulfilling its function we don't have
a problem here with major corporate
ownership where you know people are
holding empty units as landlords are our
biggest potential expense is vacancy and
we're motivated to keep those units full
Mr Freeman if you could you've already
gone five minutes so if you could that
was five wow it was must be Happ F all
right
um I I I view uh strong property rights
as giving landlords U more options to to
provide access we feel more comfortable
taking risks with marginal tenants when
we know that we have recourse uh and
um I can't even read my own handwriting
so I guess I will oh the only other
thing I would say is that um I would
question with with a new category for
eviction I try to put myself in the
position I've had 180 tendencies in have
never had to go through the eviction
process but if I were taking an
application from somebody that had an
eviction on their record I would be
curious about the details of that and I
would think that seeing a an eviction
for end of lease would be a lot less
concerning to me as a category than an
eviction for something like non-payment
which is how that could end up unfolding
otherwise okay thank you very much for
your testimony are there questions for
Mr
Freeman seeing none thank you very
much um is anyone else here to testify
on hb60
all right I'm closing the public hearing
on that it's 104 so I apologize to the
public we are running a bit behind but
um we're going to continue to power
through um as always I'm not going to
limit the testimony of the Prime sponsor
um it's actually map representative
you're not up yet it's there's one other
one um I'm not going to limit the
testimony of the Prime sponsor but I'm
going to keep everyone at three minutes
uh moving forward so representative C
I'm going to open the public hearing on
hp65 come come on up
thank you so much I thought there was
you what there is I'm so sorry about
that that's okay closing that stretching
yeah representative pataro my apologies
I know he's another meeting I'm opening
the public hearing on HP
yeah I was going a numerical order on
accident so go back thank you Mr chair
thank you uh housing committee uh my
name is representative Matthew pataro I
represent the town of Allenstown marac
County District 11 I'm just starting my
second non-concurrent
term and uh I'm very excited here this
is actually the very very first bill
that I prime sponsoring and uh my very
first introduction and along those lines
I want to take this opportunity briefly
to just uh Express to everybody here
that um I did watch the inauguration
last night and I thought it was a great
ceremony uh we most of us I think had
the day off and so I took advantage and
watched the whole thing and I thought it
was great that we had a peaceful
transition of power but um I bring that
up because there's also
um ideas and themes of uh unity and
getting down and working hard and so in
that respect starting uh a new term here
I'm very excited to uh get to work for
the public and make the state and the
country a better place uh with this
particular Bill there isn't too much of
a backstory with it essentially an
anonymous uh constituent came to me
during my campaign for this race and
suggested the idea I took it down in a
note and I ended up filing it and um I
really didn't know what was going to
happen my bill HB
351 what it does is address a current
inequity in the law where if you are a
tenant at will and you want to leave
you must give your landlord 60-day
notice and in a situation with the
tenant at will If a landlord wants the
tenant to leave they're only required to
give 30-day notice my bill simply and
straightforward changes the 30-day on
the landlord's side to 60 days to make
the same situation in alignment um
finally I would like to say that with
this being my first bill that I'm
introducing I really didn't know what
was going to happen I've been checking
my emails I haven't had much reach out
yet but looking at the blue signin sheet
um I'm um very happy that uh the public
who filled in that blue sheet uh 14 were
for and two were against on last count
and based on my last look my blue sheet
had the most participation on it so I'm
very happy about that and with that Mr
chair I'll be happy to answer any
questions that your committee has thank
you for your testimony um are there
questions for representative pataro
represent
Faxon did you you you actually found
this in 540A because my understanding
and my experience has always been that
the uh notice required on an atwi tency
is equal to the period in which the rent
is paid so if you're a weekly tenant
you're required to receive weekly notice
and give weekly notice if you're a
monthly tenant Etc is
and you you found something different
than that in
548 I did not find anything in that
regard um uh that's an interesting point
though representative I'll be um happy
to connect with you about that
one other questions seeing none thank
you representative thank
you um oh could you fill out a pink card
please yes sir thank you Nick Norman
thank you once again for the opportunity
to
speak uh I've given an introduction
previously um so I just want to say that
um as far as I know having been in real
estate for 35 years and managing the Min
departments that I have it is not true
that the law requires a 60-day notice
from a tenant in fact RSA 540 colon 1
comma Roman two specifies the tendency
at will from month to month may be
terminated by the lesi upon 30 days
notice and as Baxter representative
Baxter quoted I think there are some
additional Clauses that say if the
frequency is less it could be a weak if
it's a weak tendency that's that's been
the the way that has been for forever
and ever as far as I've I've known to
this the place where this provision was
put into the law does
not make
um notice for termination 60 days what
it does is it increases
evictions from 30 days to 60 days so it
would say that every eviction cause
that's presently in the law that's
presently 30 days would now become 60
days so you have a tenant that's that's
um causing extreme disturbance someone
that's endangering other
tenants um someone that's like the
classic thing we talk about about
dealing drugs which oh my gosh it's so
so often happens you would be subjecting
all of the other good tenants into the
building of the building to an
additional 30 days of trying to remedy
that situation to provide good housing
for for people you take the current
eviction
process of a 30-day eviction which can
take about 9 to to 11 weeks and then add
on another 30 days and now that becomes
13 to 15 15 weeks um there's delays in
Sheriff's service in the entire process
uh right now as is a little delayed for
eviction you could be talking three and
a half months to eliminate a a bad
situation in a property where you have a
bad tenant causing Untold grief so we
oppose uh the change present law I think
is totally fine each site can give a
30-day
notice contracts can be made uh through
leases that have other notices it's not
uncommon that a housing provider would
have a lease where they agree to a
60-day notice by the landlord and by the
tenant but just to be clear the present
law does not say a tenant has to give a
60-day notice present law is balanced
with the landlord and tenant giving
30-day notices unless there's a lease
that says something different which is
agreed upon by both parties I'd be happy
to take questions thank you Mr Norman
three minutes and one second appreciate
that representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Norman for coming in to testify um
this is a two-part question the first
part is how many units do you manage and
the second part is how many times uh
over the course of the last few years
say the last five years um have you you
had to evict a tenant for causing
disturbances I have 48 units I've been
managing for 35
years I definitely have tenants that
have caused disturbance and it's an
issue and I have never evicted a tenant
for causing disturbance because when you
go to court to try to process that
eviction you have to prove that case in
course in court and it's virtually
impossible not quite impossible but it's
let's say it's very hard to get existing
good tenants to testify against a bad
tenant in the property because they're
afraid of retaliation so
proving the case in court becomes
exceedingly difficult
so uh we
haven't U go ahead follow up
just put your mic on for us thank you
sorry
uh in that case um
uh I guess another two-part question how
did you handle those situations and what
difference would it make since you don't
go through the eviction process what
difference would it make to have to give
60 days notice rather than 30
days so if you're not using a 30-day
then of course of course wouldn't make
any difference but for the the property
owners that do use 30-day evictions when
there are many
um it would extend the time by way way
way way too long why should you subject
good tenants to three and a half months
of misery living with someone that's
causing
trouble representative
Paige thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Norman um I'm just looking at the the
language in the
bill it says provided however that s
days notice shall be sufficient if the
reason for the termination is a set
forth in and then it references this
part of Statute that gives several of
the reasons us used as examples as cause
for that 7-Day notice rather than the 60
days which include non-payment of rent
behavioral issues structural damage so
I'm not sure
what um what the concern what with those
examples off the table I'm not sure what
the concern is around moving it to 60
days so there's only a few cases where
you can evict for the 7-Day notice one
is
non-payment one is excessive damage or
health and safety
concerns and the other is a tenant that
is going through a lead abatement
process where the tenant is ref has
refused to move so that the lead
abatement can
be um proceeded
with every other cause for eviction
would be extended from 30 to 60 so let's
say you've got someone that's causing uh
large disturbance to the property um
they're selling
drugs uh all of those would be uh extend
Ed to 30 from 30 to 60 you want your
daughter to move into an apartment
because she's moving across country back
into this region it would be extending
the time that she would have to wait to
move in any cause at all that you could
think
of um would be extended besides those
three other questions see none thank you
very much thank you
Cara an um rhen
Heiser she has written testimony yeah
the clerk will get that and we'll make
sure that's just in the bill
file Sarah
Holland good afternoon I'm Sarah Holland
uh chair of public policy for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors thank
you for having us today
very similar to my testimony for hb60 um
we are in opposition of HB 351 for the
following reasons um the longer notice
requirement will likely increase the
chance that a tenant will not pay um
rent for the last month or two I
actually just worked with a a client
where that was the case he had two
tenants and um we did not know that one
of them even vacated the pro property or
was planning to vacate the property
um so it happens for a variety of
reasons um Maine and Massachusetts our
neighbors also um require a maximum 30
days notice so we're staying in line um
our current laws is in line with our
neighbors
um we would encourage tenants to sign
leases as opposed to month to month we
understand that that creates additional
hurdles for them as well um the
month-to-month is uncertain um but we
feel that the notice requirement should
equal the length of of at will tency so
that 30 days um and again this is not
going to solve the housing crisis I
think what we need to do is look for
ways to add more inventory this is a
supply and demand issue um there are a
lot of tenants looking for um lot of
renters that are looking for tency in a
lot of places if we had more opportunity
for them to find housing that would
alleviate a lot of this pressure where
landlords are as testimony showed today
are greedy retaliatory um and
discriminatory so
um I think I also want to be clear that
our position today is very narrow on
private property rights and Property
Owners being able to um to take
possession back of their property in a
timely manner um we are not in favor of
discriminatory or retaliatory um actions
um and but we do wish to preserve
private property rights happy to answer
any questions thank you for your
testimony questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much I will now call on I want make sure
uh David
Klein thank you Mr chairman of the
committee my name is David cleus I said
before I'm a small L Lord one of the
mama pops with property on the coast I
want to start off with the if you go
back to the test testimony of the
sponsor he said that he proposed the
bill because he was told by a
constituent that if they wanted to leave
they had to give 60-day notice one
that's not true Nick Norman gave you the
statutory reference RSA 540 not 548 5411
where it does say the tenants only have
to give 30-day notice which is the same
as a landlord so that this bill is not
what the sponsor is talking about this
bill talks about when there is a breach
of the lease or someone believe it or
not they will not cooperate in the
remediation of bed bugs which can spread
to the whole building that period of
time is a 30-day notice extending that
to 60 days you want to expose good
tenants to the bad habits of a bad
tenant pass this bill we have to look at
what it's going to do to the other
people in the building none of us want
to live with bed bugs this gives this
bad tenant more time to do nothing
because you have to work at getting rid
of bed bugs another area where would
extend is a material breach of the lease
many of the apartments these days the
tenants are responsible for all utility
except for possibly water this means
that if they stop paying heat or or fuel
the landlord has two choices let the
apartment go cold or pay for the heat to
prevent it from freezing up I just think
about how cold it is today you don't
have heat you will freeze pipes those
pipes freeze and burst probably the
entire building will be taken out of
line and all the tenants would have to
move that's a distinct possibility so
what this bill does it doesn't help good
tenants it helps bad tenants and what
what we're saying is don't change it
don't pass this bill it's not doing what
the sponsor wanted to be done and it's
not going to be good for either
landlords or good tenants who take care
of the responsibilities pay the rents
don't breach their leases thank you Mr
Klein are there questions for Mr Klein
seeing none thank you very much uh Matt
Mayberry welcome back hello once again
Matt Mayberry CEO of the New Hampshire
home builder Association please please
please do not pass this bill the
unintended consequences are Prett
substantial as you've just heard before
but if the committee insists upon doing
it please put tenants in the boat with
the property providers if the property
provider has to give 60 days the tenant
has to give 60 days that's all we're
asking fairness that's it I think
questions for Mr maybery seeing none
thank you 24 seconds I yeah just
about um I'm acting as clerk too so I'm
trying to do both um Mr
Freeman all right should be able to keep
this one a little bit more concise I
think some other folks have made some
great points about the fact that this is
how long it takes once you file the
eviction so we won't rehash that um I
just want to kind of continue on the
theme of how we are different from other
conventional landlords in the shared
housing um if you extend the uh timeline
that it takes to complete an eviction
from 30 to 60 days in a shared housing
environment then whatever bad behavior
it is that is leading to that eviction
is something that's going to be imposed
on um in our case up to three other
people uh for that whole 60-day period
um I mentioned before we've we've had
180 Tendencies zero evictions it usually
works out pretty well if you ask them to
leave in my experience um but we take
the the responsibility of maintaining a
uh constructive and positive living
environment Within These shared spaces
pretty seriously and I I think it would
be pretty unfortunate if we found
ourselves compelled to abide uh Behavior
that's not specifically um not
specifically
a health or safety per se but but
perhaps a personality mismatch that's
causing you mental anguish uh within a
shared living
space thank you for your testimony other
questions seeing none thank you all
right is there anyone else here to
testify on HB
351 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on 351 and immediately
open the public hearing on
hb65 representative seelig thank you so
much for being patient with us today
thank you so much to the committee and
um first of all if you need to stand up
and stretch while I'm testifying I take
no offense I know I've stood up and
stretch during some of the other
testimony today um so thank you very
much for hearing my bill um I just want
to give you a little bit of background
if I may over um some point last summer
I had a meeting with Congressman Maxwell
Frost from the Orlando area of Florida
and he was talking about his experiences
um ultimately becoming homeless for a
variety of reasons while he was running
for office um and the challenges that
came up as a result of that and he bemon
the fact that as a tenant he didn't have
a way of increasing his credit score in
the same way that a homeowner paying a
mortgage would and I stopped him and
said that's not accurate rental payments
are also can also be reported to credit
bureaus and he said no they only report
negative ones in other words when people
don't pay and I said well you know high
quality landlords also report positive
rent payments to the credit bureaus
because they understand the benefit of
helping people build their credit score
so after I completed that conversation
with him I reached out to um a number of
property managers that I know from my
previous work as a real estate agent in
the SE coast region of New Hampshire and
I asked them do you report ontime rent
payments to the credit bureaus and um of
the ones that I spoke to several said
yes one of them said that once they
instituted that as a policy for the
company they had a 95% ontime rental
payment rate and were chasing down far
fewer people for rent um which was
saving them time and money as an
organization and so now they actually
have that written into their lease that
they report all rent payments both on
time and late and as a result they have
people paying very much on time their
tenants are building their credit scores
and because that's a company that also
does property sales um when they turn
around and are able to then use their
higher credit scores to buy a property
they've got a real estate AG agent built
right in so it's helping them feed their
own market for potential buyers and then
they get new tenants and help them do
the same kind of thing of building their
credit score by paying their rent on
time so I proposed this bill um when I
started working with some other people
it got a little bit more complicated
than I had initially intended we modeled
it after a bill in California and the
bill has gotten expanded well beyond
where I might have chosen to have it so
I've spoken again with the landlords
that I worked with previously and I
sorry I have to take my glasses off so I
can read um so essentially the property
managers that I spoke to said they would
actually like to strip out the language
of this being an opin Bill instead they
would prefer if it were a landlords will
either landlords shall do this or just
not have it at all um so that it's up to
the landlord to make a determination
because it's very complicated if one
tenant wants a credit reported and one
doesn't and trying to figure out how to
manage that the ones that are using
professional software such as AppFolio
it's literally a toggle switch on their
software that allows them to just
automatically report credit scores as
they enter rent payments into their
database um so it doesn't add any extra
cost um to their to their plans um so
ideally we would uh make an amendment to
this bill that would reduce it down to
the essential thing that landlords and
and I'm talking about professional
landlords so I said in the bill 15 or
more properties we can make that number
whatever you think is appropriate but
that landlords will report positive rent
payments to the credit bureaus um and
just keep it that simple that would be
fabulous to make it that simple um the
goal is really about helping people
build their credit scores helping
landlords collect rent on time so that
there are fewer cases of rent not being
paid um I also wanted to share some
information that I
received um from the credit Builders
Alliance um so if you'll bear with me
while I read their statement um they
said positive rent reporting is an
accessible and safe way for renters to
build credit without taking on
additional debt reporting positive
rental history opens stores for
individuals who face barriers to credit
building or rebuilding for example
survivors of domestic violence veterans
young people transitioning from foster
care and homelessness and returning
citizens to name a few rent reporting
also allows individuals renting
affordable housing units to build a
stronger credit history and places them
on a path toward its improved Financial
stability and possibly even purchasing
their first home rent reporting when
offered as an opt-in program with
positive payment information is a
low-risk method for building credit
strength negative information concerning
overdue rental payments is already
incorporated into rental reports and
scores through actions including account
sent to collections and evictions so
positive only reporting allows renters
to get credit for their record of timely
payments the credit Builders Alliance
CBA has been actively involved in rent
reporting as a credit building strategy
since 2012 during that time CBA has led
over 80 affordable housing providers
through the implementation of rent
reporting programs at their respective
agencies research from these landlords
the credit reporting agencies and the US
Department of Housing and Urban
Development have all shown that rent
reporting to be an effective way to
build CR credit and encourage ontime
rental payments um and then there's more
details about Colorado's program about a
program in Prince George County Maryland
Etc and I will um send this to you as an
email afterwards because I know it's a
lot of data and there's some links in
here as well and I know I spoke really
fast but I also know you've been here a
long time and have many bills after me
so I'll be happy to take any questions
oh I appreciate that represent C
represent Miner thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for your testimony I had
just have a question about what about
landlords that don't have the programs
like that you spoke of like some like a
1980s program that doesn't have that
option and some that don't use any
program just use like the data sheet
they create themselves what's the cost
going to be to them so uh for the most
part my understanding from reaching out
to I think it was ex
experion I think that's how you say it
um there I reached out to several
different places they don't actually
charge a fee to landlords to report the
information so it's the time um but
again I'm looking not at the people who
have like you know Grandma living in the
backyard but looking at people who are
managing who are doing this as their
profession right and that's where
identifying what that number is whether
it's 15 whether it's 20 properties is up
to you um and I would specifically keep
it to residential um property management
or landlords can I just follow up thank
you yes um I I personally am aware of a
few different landlords that own quite a
few properties that have none of the
those programs because of the I know
that some of those programs cost money
to even have per unit so they don't they
choose to just do it the oldfashioned
way I just do you have an idea of what
the cost would be again it there's
there's the credit bureaus don't charge
a fee to have the information reported
to them so it's what their time spent
okay would be submitting the information
rather than um you know having a simple
Software System that might save them
there so I have yet to find a fee for
providing the information thank you I I
I have looked it's possible I have not
checked
everywhere representative Aaron thank
you very much uh Mr chair and uh thank
you for coming in to testify and to
sponsor this bill is my understanding
that tenants can ask for this reporting
now is that correct and if so is this
bill going to compel landlords to do
this so in the current housing
environment um people have been afraid
to ask tenant uh landlords for anything
beyond what's offered in an initial
lease and if a landlord is not already
offering this as a part of the program
um I have found most tenants afraid to
ask for any supplemental anything for
fear of not being able to access an
apartment however the landlords that
I've spoken to who have worked to make
sure that they have tenants who have
good you know reasonable credit scores
and are consistent in paying or who are
encouraging their tenants to continue to
build themselves have all welcomed using
this program I spoke as I said I think
to seven different property managers and
uh four of them were using this and
finding great success and one of them
said she realized she needed to use it I
also spoke to someone from the Housing
Authority um the Portsmouth Housing
Authority who said that this would be a
useful tool for them thank you
representative Paige and then
representative
Gibbs okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr shair and thank you
for coming in to
testify um you mentioned that you
believe the bill should be amended do
you plan to present an amendment to this
committee so I would be happy to present
an amendment to the committee I thought
that I should find out from the
committee given how uh overburdened OS
has uh been reportedly um that I should
find out from the committee what
language you would prefer to have in the
amendment so that when I reach out to
them to simplify it especially in terms
of things like how many landlords or how
many prop units a landlord might manage
that we would have some consensus so
that we could have them draft a single
Amendment rather than going back and
forth than having them have extra
work go ahead thank you um how would you
obtain that information I I don't know
that the committee would necessarily be
in agreement as to what we would
want um I I would hope that your
committee would have some sort of
conversation and that a member of your
committee would be willing to work with
me I more than happy to um to work with
you in any way appropriate I will be
here many many days as I've been
appointed to the education
administration and policy committee and
so I will be here many more days than I
had intended
well representative without having to
overburden this committee which I know
is very busy would you consider an
amendment that would turn this into a
study committee so the legislature could
study it this term um if if you wanted
to uh have it as a study to bring back
for next year we could do that or if you
wanted to do a short-term study
committee you know I'm happy to do that
if you wanted to have a few study
meetings we I I would be open to that
again my goal is really trying to seek
that win-win to help landlords increase
their on Time Rental payments and to
help tenants build their credit scores
okay thank you
simultaneously all right thank you very
much thank you next up is um
representative new she in here oh
hi yes I've been hovering for quite some
time welcome um I know that y'all have
had a long day so I'm going to keep it
short and sweet as I like to
do uh my name is Jody NL and I represent
chesa in Keen
um consumer credit reports are meant to
reflect an individual's likelihood of
repaying in debt in applying for my
mortgage 9 years ago it was made very
clear to me that my credit report and my
credit score were the most important
factors up until that point I had been
renting for 17 years and I had never
once missed a payment in spite of the
fact that I often didn't have enough to
cover everything while I may not have
had enough to pay my cell phone bill or
any other report worthy bills that month
I made sure that I did not jeopardize
the one thing that would ensure I had a
roof over my head and a warm place to
tuck my kids in at
night therefore if a mortgage company or
a landlord um wants accurate data and
indicating whether or not an individual
is likely to pay their rent or mortgage
which is what a credit report is for um
in this is in fact the best data point
that they can
have further if my mortgage payments are
reported and they are and included in
calculating my credit score and they are
so should my rental payment hit
uh if I so choose and the last Point um
just kind of considering this um from a
landlord's perspective um in a changing
landscape of property ownership often
towards corporate ownership in
management it's cumbersome and frankly
it strikes me as outdated to expect to
be able to reach a previous landlord uh
to confirm good payment history so this
makes it easier all around um the times
have changed and I think we need to
adapt the bill would not only allow for
a more accurate picture of an individual
likelihood to pay their housing expenses
it would ease the burden on previous and
prospective landlords and mortgage
companies at the same time thank you for
listening to my testimony happy to take
any questions thank you very much
representative other questions for
representative
new seeing none thank you thank you uh
Chris
Freeman all right hello again um so uh
when it comes to the credit reporting um
we're we're really big advocat for home
ownership um part of the value
proposition of our room by room model is
that compared to the cost of a
one-bedroom or Studio within one or two
years you could save up conceivably
enough money for a down payment on your
own home um after just a few short
leasing cycles and um uh we have a
provision in our lease uh that allows
any tenant uh to terminate as if it were
a month-to-month tenancy if the reason
that they're doing that is to become a
homeowner um so pretty pretty committed
to this I also freely consult with my
tenants on matters of personal finance
I'm a finance professional and it's what
I think is fun which is probably weird
but um uh credit's a huge component of
that and uh we do advise our tenants on
matters like building credit with things
like secured credit cards um with rent
reporting options uh our software does
have the ability to do rent reporting uh
after very careful consideration I opted
not to enable it because I did not feel
that uh there was enough transparency in
how the software was functioning for me
able for me to be able to validate what
was going out to the Credit Agencies
would be accurate and the last thing I
wanted was to be part of a chain of
events that resulted in a deterioration
of somebody's credit score um that could
be things like miscellaneous charges
that were posted after the rent was paid
but before the grace period expiration
was calculated um reading through the
bill it is a very very honorous Bill and
so while in general I'm in favor of the
concept of um rent reporting for the
purpose of building credit I think that
the specific way that it's implemented
is really important um even with
software that theoretically can report
uh payments uh our software still
doesn't have the ability to comply with
the technical requirements for example
disambiguating uh rent payments that are
done on time versus uh the participation
fees that's just not something that we
can do so even though we have the
technical capability we'd still be
looking for a third-party solution um
the other thing I would say is that some
of these Solutions already exist out
there and some of them exist on a free
of basis uh for tenants to participate
in if you do a quick Google search uh
there's a lot of platforms out there
where you can um I think you have to
upload a copy of your lease to prove you
know which monthly payment is coming out
of your bank account corresponds to your
rent um there's some verification work
that goes into that uh but then it's
connected they can see oh I paid you
know 850 bucks on the first for the past
12 months and it's done uh leveraging
the technological capabilities of
companies that specialize in this versus
the ineptitude of um you know landlords
under 15 who probably wouldn't be able
to navigate um navigate the technical
complexities or the fer compliance
aspects of it um you know so I think if
you if you wanted to take another
approach uh when I think about what I
would consider to be not not too
burdensome um I would I'd be happy to
have a solution where if one of these
platforms reaches out to me looking for
verification that the details provided
by a tenant are accurate I'd be happy to
respond to a request like that um but as
written we won't be able to comply with
this without adding significant
administrative burden that um you know
frankly uh you know we just everyone's
just got their Spotify wrapped I got a
wrapped from my my uh business VoIP
system telling me that in 2024 I sent
35,000 text messages and this is my my
side gig you know um people go Chris how
how do you do it all and I say I don't
do everything we let stuff slip through
the cracks and we just we can't take on
the administrative burden of the bill is
written thank you very much for your
testimony um questions for Mr
Freeman seeing none thank
you um Matt
Maybury Matt maybery CEO from the home
builders doing a hatrick with the
housing committee
today we like the idea of it study
commital work but please
don't there are 14 apps that I found in
90 seconds that will help you
self-report because some of the
unintended consequences of this are if
you go from a large complex that does
report to a small complex that does
not to a three years later you go to
another large complex then you go to buy
a house they can say what happened here
go find it there's a gap in your credit
report what happened there's an app out
there right now that will work with with
you they will pay your housing provider
they take it automatically out of your
checking account for a small fee they
pay the housing provider and then they
report the ontime
payments the corporate world does this
now one of our members is a large
company that's the second largest
provider of housing in New Hampshire
they're bringing this on as a value
added for their
tenants please don't regulate things are
fixing themselves and there are options
out there if you wish to do that I'm
going to shut up thank you thank you
questions representative Cole thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question yes sir did you consider this a
mandate
absolutely thank you um representative
kwin I'll say okay thank you very much
Mr M thank
you Nick Norman
thank you very much once again for the
opportunity to
speak unfortunately there's actually a
lot of things to say here and this time
I'm going to remember to pass out my
testimony because there's a lot in here
to
read
so we have not done rent reporting
because we have at times been members of
credit bureaus for the purposes of
getting credit reports and screening
tenants as they apply for apartments and
what we've experienced over the years
has always been very difficult to be
able to report uh payments to the credit
bureaus one of our members owns perhaps
in the range of 2,000 units so they're
what you might consider a big property
owner
and what they said was it was very cost
prohibitive to um use that software very
use different software platforms to do
this
um and so they they're looking into it
but the cost and administration of doing
it in compliance and setting up the
different systems is is U quite
large there is a credit
reporting service I looked up one Matt
Maybury mentioned within a few seconds
he had found a Bunches of them there's
one called self.inc which is free for
tenants to use to report their rent
their website says get credit for paying
rent plus your cell phone in utilities
they apparently lots of bills they can
report this way 100% free no credit card
or credit check
required so there's many services that
can already do this to mandate it onto
Property Owners at a large cost um you
know just doesn't make sense anyone can
build good
credit you just have to be
disciplined every tenant that gets into
one of our Apartments if they're having
trouble with tenant uh credit we we talk
to them and tell them here's a strategy
that's simple doesn't cost you a dime
and will build you credit you just have
to be dissing with your
discipline with your payments if you
want I'll tell you how that
works
um how would a housing provider actually
calculate the cost of administrating
this there's no guidance in the bill do
do you track how much time that you
spent doing this what about you're
paying employees what about their cost
and their time what about the benefits
and social the Social
Security employer portions of that what
are the costs that you would calculate
to figure out the cost that you would
charge them most M most landlords
throughout the state as you've heard
over and over and we certainly in our
awareness think it's true our mom and
pop landlords they don't have the means
of doing this um it is is quite a a
burden to be reporting all of it Mr
Norman I as you wrap up if you could
please uh there's there's so much more
there's so many problems the way it's
written so we don't have
an objection to the idea of reporting
rent in fact that could be good on both
sides but to burden Property Owners is
they have to do that and increase their
cost Administration when there's free
options already available it doesn't
make any sense there there's so much
more and I would take questions thank
you for your testimony questions for Mr
Norman seeing none thank
you and last up is uh David clein
thank you to the for hearing me to the
chairman and the committee um the
overall concept of per of reporting
rents I understand why the sponsor is
pushing it and I think for me the
problem with the bill of the mechanics
of the bill and just as a very brief one
it says we can get $10 per month or
actual cost which is whichever is lower
I don't know how to calculate actual
costs and if the tenant challenges it
how am I going to prove that my actual
costs are lower uh for instance I was
using and use QuickBooks QuickBooks does
not communicate that type of rent
payments and I'm a small landlord and
what am I going to have to do go through
every single tenant file on QuickBooks
to and report it monthly that they paid
um and that's a lot of time and that's
not fair I think at this point I would
like to pick up on something that the
chairman said that this bill should go
to study committee let's find mechanics
that work well for both landlords
tenants and the credit reporting
agencies the bill that's written the
sponsor said was modeled after
California we know California does
things a little differently than we do
in New Hampshire and I think we really
should do it the New Hampshire way let's
study it let's think about it let's get
input from everybody and I would suggest
to the committee please send this to
study committee and take it and let us
work it through in a manner that can
find a solution that everybody would can
live with thank you questions for Mr
Klein seeing none thank you is there
anyone else here to testify on um House
Bill
65 I'll give her a couple minutes yep so
um we're going to take a 5 minute break
and we'll be back at
1:2 122
ch
e
e e
I'm going to um finish up the hearing on
hp65 and call on representative
Alexandra
Murray
welcome thank you very much chairman and
the rest of the committee for indulging
me for a couple minutes um I appreciate
your time I am a co-sponsor on this bill
and I am in support of passing the bill
um this has something that has actually
affected me personally when I was
younger and first moving out of my
parents house I couldn't find um someone
willing to rent to me without a credit
history and the only way I was able to
get an apartment was basically sneaking
onto a friend's lease getting a credit
card and then uh starting to build up
credit that way and as we know housing
is scarce right now a lot of landlords
have the ability to have really high
standards for you know potential tenants
because of the lack of
availability and I think it's important
we provide every tool possible to help
um people be able to build up their
credit have a more established and
secure place in society
and I think it I've heard some of the
concerns I was watching the testimony
remotely from um landlords and housting
providers regarding the implementation
of this and I do understand that there
could be some concerns and that there
are ways already for tenants to self
report on those payments but I think it
makes sense for the burden to be on the
person who's receiving the money to
report that they receed the money just
like it would be for an employer for
someone who's um you know giving a loan
out it's on them to facilitate that
transaction um and I think
objectively the housing providers have
more time money resources than the
renters do and so the most effective way
to ensure that renters can um you know
take use of such legislation would be to
ensure that the landlords are carrying
that burden so I just wanted to share my
personal thoughts on it thank you so
much well representative thank you for
your testimony are there questions for
presented
Murray seeing none thank you so much
thank you all right at this time I'm
going to close the public hearing on
hb65 at 154 and open up the public
hearing at on HB 309 we're almost almost
caught up um and recognize the prime
sponsor representative Mooney and after
that I will continue to enforce a
three-minute rule on testimony
welcome thank you very much Mr chairman
and good afternoon to you and good
afternoon to members of the committee
for the record my name is representative
Moren money I represent the town of
marac that's Hillsboro County District
12 I am the prime sponsor of House Bill
309 that's an act relative to making
electronic payments optional I've
provided written testimony to each of
you and one for the
clerk House Bill 309 prohibits landlords
from taking payments only key word here
only by electronic means this bill would
then require landlords to take payments
in various forms not just limited to
electronic
means now this bill idea came to me at
the request of a constituent who is here
today who will testify after
me I would say this uh to the housing
committee
our legislature should be mindful not to
strain or further complicate any
relationship between landlord and tenant
especially during a housing crisis House
Bill 309 will open the options of
payment from tenants to landlords so as
to not limit or rule out renters based
on method of payment
House Bill 309 supports accessibility
and flexibility which are two Essentials
toward rental agreements so I'd ask that
you keep that in mind as you deliberate
on House Bill
309 thank you I also oh go ahead ask
that you recommend House Bill 309 ought
to pass and with that I'll conclude my
testimony thank you Mr chairman and
members of housing committee thank you
representative and thank you for your
patience today are there questions for
representative Mooney
seeing none thank you thank you I'm
going to call on um Robert Beville to
come up next um to give his
testimony and if you could keep it as
succinct as possible that would be
great just um take turn your mic on for
us there we go thank you thank
you my name is Robert bevel I'm a
resident of marac New Hampshire I'm in
here in report of House Bill 309 to make
electronic payments optional first I'd
like to thank Representatives Meen
Mooney and Bill Boyd for sponsoring this
for me I was contacted by a senior
citizen who I know very well who told me
that her apartment has informed her that
when her lease is up for Renewal she
will not she will be required to make
all future rent payments electronically
by automatic draft this was not a
negotiable term in her rent contract she
is frightened about doing any banking
business on on the internet and prefers
to continue providing a personal check
for her rent payments she has never been
late on her rent payments and has never
bounced a check under federal law 12 CFR
1051b regarding electronic funds
transfers it requires that authorization
must be in writing in order to take
authorized funds out of somebody's
account by forcing consumers to make
rent payments electronically by
automatic draft takes away their freedom
to consent to such transactions and
shoot can be considered an abuse of an
unequal bargaining power between the
landlord and the tenants recurring
electronic funds transfers are not
limited to any dollar amount but allow
businesses to raid consumers accounts
for what they believe they are owed not
limited to the amount stipulated in the
lease agreement consumers would have to
issue a stop payment if the businesses
took money from their accounts if the
consumer believed the amount was
transferred in error incurring a costly
stop payment fee this also affects
homeowners when mortgage service
businesses utilize something called a
pre-authorized draft or a pad to deduct
mortgage payments based on the
information on the face of your
homeowner's check without receiving
authorization from the homeowner another
critical point uh about recurring
electronic funds drafts in the pads are
that there aren't no papers created in
the transacts with a check the consumer
has an auditable proof that they made
their rent or mortgage payment on time
and the landlord or mortgage company
cash it on a particular date with efts
there's only a line entry in a bank
statement for a tenant or homeowner to
prove that they have made payments
regularly and on time they would have to
produce a stack of bank statements
rather than cancel checks and they would
have to argue about what transactions
were based on in our rush to do away
with hard currency using checks
maintaining audible transactions between
consumers and businesses forcing EFT
rent payments on renters is an
uncontable act of Oppression against
people already with limited means all
for the sake of saving a few steps in
processing payments for the landlord's
business Enders please pass this
legislation I'd like to refer to uh it's
a little more Draconian in some states
in Connecticut Illinois New York and New
Jersey landlords cannot require
electronic payments however we're asking
for the middle ground which is similar
to California and Texas and Washington
that the landlord must accept at least
one other form of payment besides EFT
thank you for your
time thank you very much for your
testimony questions for Mr
bevel seeing none thank you thank you
Nick
Norman thank you once again for the
opportunity to speak I have written
testimony once again
so while housing providers don't really
have much of an objection to the concept
that's
here um there's an extreme objection to
where it's placed in the
law
um- a colon three is the section of the
law that's called prohibited
practices that car cares with it
automatically fees and penalties of
$1,000 per day plus court costs in
attorney's
fees which is just AB absolutely
absurd to be charged for someone that
requires rental payment
by uh electronic means and doesn't know
that that's not allowed we can just if
they are told sorry you can't do that
the not change it you have to accept
payments as people would normally do it
shouldn't be $1,000 a day court costs
and legal fees and when does that ,000
per day
stop there's no way to to regulate or
Define when that ,000 per day would stop
suppose that particular tenant doesn't
have email
phone doesn't speak English how do they
get noticed that the the housing
provider is uh turned um reversed their
policy and that they can pay now and
other
means so uh if if it was carved out that
that fines and fees don't apply which
has been done in many other categories
if you'd like we could prepare an
amendment which might be like five or 10
characters long to say add this car out
to those fees uh we could do that for
you we've been there many times um so
I'd be very happy to take
questions thank you for your testimony
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr Norman for your testimony I
regret to inform you that you have
incorrectly cited the penalty in 540 um
the penalty cites the consumer
protection act and in the consumer
protection act the penalty that I think
that you're getting representative I it
will be a question Mr Norman is
providing public testimony sure you can
state that that was incorrectly stated
during an executive session but if you
have a I have a question you can ask the
question that's right keep going to the
question please were you actually
referencing though maybe inelegantly put
the fact that the penalty cited in 540
is the consumer protection act and in
the consumer protection act there's a
penalty and the only time $1,000 a day
comes up is when the person in this case
the landlord is in direct violation of a
court order and it ends when a landlord
complies with the court order is that
what you were actually referencing there
is a reference that says there is $1,000
per day it
continues well it says the fine is
$1,000 per day it continues every day
that
the violation is still in place so if
there's no definition of when that ends
it would continue at $1,000 per day
thank you thank you for your testimony
all set thank you Mr
Norman Chris
Freeman all right so I was playing with
my GameCube when this one came through
my fax machine um I don't really
understand why we're going to compel
landlords to take such a big step
backwards
um listening to some of the other
testimony I just want to make a few
quick Corrections one uh individual said
that um there's no paper trail when you
have an a uh transaction and I think you
actually have a tighter paper trail with
an a transaction than you do with a
papercheck uh merchant services accounts
track everything from the date and time
of the origination the amount the
institutions that are coming through uh
if there are any rejected payments it
keeps track of what the reason for the
rejection was uh so it's pretty good
paper trail if you ever do have a
dispute over the payment um in terms of
the accessibility of the payment means I
can think of a few areas where you could
make a case that uh alternate means of
payments are are beneficial to the
individual renter um some of those would
be if that person belongs to certain
protected classes uh like if they have a
disability or if they are of an age
where the the technological aspects of
sending in online rent payments uh is a
barrier for them and I would just point
out those individuals already have
protections under the federal fairhouse
act to submit a reasonable accommodation
request and the landlord would be
obligated to comply with that um we have
we I personally require online payments
um it eliminates first of all it
automates the accounting we have another
proposal today to uh mandate that
landlords report uh rent payments to the
credit bureaus and there's a a
recordkeeping aspect that comes in with
that which is what happens if that
payment uh gets delayed in the mail or
doesn't get processed in a timely manner
with electronic payments that can happen
automatically and there's no concerns
about about the timing of the payment
um yeah I guess that's all I have well
thank you Mr Freeman for your testimony
any questions for Mr
Freeman yep seeing none go
ahead representative Paige that's just a
a question for the chair I don't know if
um representative Mooney would like to
speak to the question of the um the the
fee here or the fine here but I would
certain love her input if she has any to
share on that question yeah
representative Mooney yeah can you
please come up again if you
available thank you I appreciate that
and the opportunity I haven't given it a
tremendous amount of thought having
heard it for the first time like
yourself by the witness that spoke I
guess the important thing is that it
appears in the law at some point uh and
this where where it goes you know that's
one thing I mean if it were to be with a
fine or without I think that's that's
fine as well I have no preference off
hearing it for the first time the
important thing is that we not again in
my testimony I revert back to it that we
not strain unnecessarily relationships
between tenants and landlords
particularly on things like method of
payment and preference of payment so
that's my bottom line thank you okay
well it's in the committee's hands but
um I've heard the input from various
people so thank you very
good okay is there anyone left to
testify on HB
309 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing at
207 open up the public hearing on HB 296
and I'll recognize the prime
sponsor representative lad is not here
so
um yep I'm going to recess that public
hearing until representative lad comes
back and it is 2:00 so I'm going to
um open the public hearing on HB 342 and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative
long welcome representative thank
you good after Mr chairman members of
the committee uh so this bill is a
alteration just introduce yourself for
us that' be great uh I'm Patrick long
representing Hillsboro 26 uh which for
anyone who doesn't know it's Manchester
w 7 uh and I'm the prime sponsor of the
bill and so this is an alteration of an
idea that was in the homeus bill last
session and was rejected at that point
and I think it addresses some of the
concerns that some people had about that
proposal uh and also actually does a
better job than that bill would have of
addressing a specific problem that I've
heard from several of my constituents in
Manchester uh so the previous proposal
was
to uh set a maximum of 10,000 square
feet for the minimum lot sizes that
municipalities could uh require uh and
this instead of setting a uniform
maximum uh
would uh set the maximum such that they
couldn't require minimums that are
significantly less dense than existing
construction uh in the neighborhood uh
so municipalities that have a a an
interest in preserving existing local
character or that have you know issues
like not being uh connected to Municipal
sewer could address those concerns uh
and could require people to build
consistent with what's already there but
they couldn't do what has been done in
Manchester over the last several decades
that I've heard a bunch of complaints
about which is that uh a lot of the
housing in my ward is built on 5,000
foot Lots which was perfectly legal at
the time it was built uh but the city
has ratcheted up the requirements over
time uh and is no longer legal to build
on a lot of that size even in
neighborhoods where all the surrounding
construction uh is on that size size and
several people have actually bought
neighboring lots that were 5,000 sare ft
thinking they could build on it uh build
something for their in-laws or you an
extra rental property whatever uh it
turns out they can't build a house on
that lot because the minimum is now
6,500 or 7500 Square ft or whatever it
may be where they're zoned
so uh this would help address our
housing crisis it would address the
actual expectations of property owners
when they buy a property that they could
build something that's consistent with
what already exists in their area uh and
it would still give municipalities
flexibility to prevent people from
building something that's not consistent
with the existing neighborhood
character okay and I'm available to
answer any questions that any of you
have thank you representative for your
testimonial questions representative
Holland uh I have a question for you
actually and thank you for taking my
question so so in this case you're
saying that as long as I've met this
density Conformity I I put my thousand
foot tape ruler out I go out there and I
look and I I'm in essence you're
allowing me to bypass the variance rule
so I guess my first question would be uh
you're saying that the that the planning
board then is going to look at your
density Conformity study and then from
that they'll approve your project why
would you not have the the
zba since since in essence what you've
done is you've cut down from the five
requirements for a variance to One
requirement the One requirement being
that you have your density study why
would you not have the zba judge if
you've met what's required to get the
variants um that was the way that OS
wrote it I guess if if the committee
feels that the zba is the more
appropriate body to make that judgment I
wouldn't have any objection to amending
it uh and I guess you know potentially
different municipalities might have
different processes set up where they do
this so if you are going to amend it it
might make sense to have something that
accounts for see whatever the planning
body with u that discretion is in that
municipality can just a quick followup
so
um you know ask somebody I just forgot
my followup go ahead okay all right
representative
Gibbs thank you um and thank you for
coming in to testify um but isn't the
point of the bill
that if the proposed
building uh meets the neighborhood
character as specified in the bill you
don't need a variance so it's not a
requirement for a variance isn't it just
a situation where you don't have to ask
for a
variance yes that's correct as far as
the intent but I think you would still
have to prove somehow that you have met
the neighborhood density
requirements represent how I'm sorry I
remembered it finally so um the the
second question is is like you put your
thousand foot radius out there and
you've already mentioned it that you
said that there's several because a
variance is actually meant for a an
unusual ual circumstance it's kind of a
one-off you just have this weird
property the variance isn't meant to
override the actual Town ordinance per
se the spirit of the ordinance but what
you're saying is that you think that
when I throw that that that thousand
foot radius out there I'm not going to
catch one property I may catch multiple
properties and that the actual zoning
ordinance doesn't work and that you
think the zoning ordinance should change
so rather than give a variant shouldn't
it be the planning board that's
reviewing your Z loing ordinance and
changing
it ideally uh municipalities would
review it and make those changes but I
think we're running into a situation
where a lot of
municipalities have not done that
um and the local governments are
preventing people from you using their
property as they see fit and using it in
a way that's consistent with what's
already there uh because in a lot of
cases they have uh tightened the rules
significantly since existing
neighborhoods were built and I know
that's what's going on in Manchester and
it's that process is starting to reverse
uh the city is in the process of a
zoning ordinance overhaul right now but
over the last several decades uh they
have tightened the zoning ordinance in
ways that are not consistent with the
expectations of property owners
there represent baxton then represent
Aon so if I understand the point of this
bill correctly and please clarify in a
town like mine where we have a village
District of 200y old houses that have
sidey yards that are from zero to two
feet under our current
zoning you can't rebuild any of those
houses because they we require a 15ot
sidey yard in the village district and
this is a conversation that we our
planning board has had and the selectman
have had so if we pass this bill I could
go and say I have an existing lot of
record and every other house on this
street has a two- foot sidey yard so
therefore a two- foot sidey yard is
reasonable is that the intent of the
bill uh yes I think that would be
allowed under this Bill thank you
represent Aon in your bill you state the
th000 foot radius is that th000 foot
radius from the property lines or from
the building on the property that could
make a huge difference in a rural
District uh the intent was it it be from
the property lines I think there are
some places where 1,000 ft from the
house or the whatever the central
building is in the property wouldn't
even reach the end of the
property um so representative I'm hoping
you can speak to um a density conforming
Conformity assessment and talk to me
about the requirements involved in that
and maybe if there's an additional cost
on a land owner if you know the details
if not if there's somebody else that can
speak to that uh I don't know the
details um that was 's proposal for how
to go about actually proving this so I
would be comfortable with any
clarification or amendment of that to uh
prevent or reduce costs on a land owner
uh I would just note that there are a
lot of existing costs on land owners who
wish to seek a variance um to build
right now uh and I I would not like to
see those costs increased in a situation
where they would already be able to
build as of right um but my hope is that
in a situation where they would now be
required to get a variance uh and spend
a lot of money on attorneys and
Architects to do that uh that this would
provide a streamlined process for uh
building what they want to build okay
thank you anyone else thank you for your
testimony thank you um Margaret
Burns good afternoon Margaret Burns
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association I did Mark a pose on the
pink card that I handed in but mostly I
would like to provide some comments to
the committee for your consideration we
understand the concept behind the bill
which I would describe sort of as an
exped Ed variance procedure and I
understand the goal and the purpose of
the piece of legislation my suggestion
for your consideration is to make it
perhaps a local option the reason that I
suggest that is because what is
happening with this bill is that
Authority that is traditionally reserved
for the Zoning Board of adjustment which
would be the variance granting Authority
is really being delegated via this bill
over to a different body which would be
the planning board so one suggestion to
make this workable would be to make it a
local option where the legislative body
would vote to approve this delegation of
authority from one body to the to the
other and then the planning board would
have this authority to Grant these types
of um special relief without the need to
go through the zba another solution
could be to keep this Authority with the
zba but to make it sort of an additional
Authority additional to the regular
granting of variances which does require
going through those five criteria which
is has been mentioned here already in
the hearing so those would be my
suggestions for your consideration and I
very much appreciate your time thank you
for your testimony um representative
Hicks thank you Mr chairman so as I'm
envisioning this I'm thinking about a
maybe a Granda non-conforming
neighborhood um that then someone that
maybe is more densely built as was
described earlier that somebody then
extends and then somebody then extends
and then somebody then extends um so at
some point it basically makes zoning
moot is that could that be even though
it may be theoretical could that be
possibility it thank you for the
question it is a possibility and that
sort of scenario that you described
would be sort of the basis of why I
signed in opposition to the bill um
despite the additional comments that I
provided you might we've heard this
described a little bit um with relation
to to Downtown City Zone in where it was
much denser before zoning went into
place but I don't think that's the only
place that we might be concerned about
this there is a lot of very dense
building around lakes that um predated
zoning zoning by quite a bit and I think
we would all be concerned especially for
the purpose of health and septic and the
other things that go into building
around Lakes I think we would all be
concerned about um that potentially be
expanded and made even more denser in
those scenarios so that that is a
concern that I think is a potential
consequence of the
legislation represent
Faxton well I'm going to skip past the
lake part because I'm not sure I agree
with you on that but
uh if we leave it the bill the way it's
written and it goes to planning and
planning turns it down for whatever good
or bad reason I would still have the
opportunity to go to the
zba I can appeal any decision to the
planning board to the zba so leave
sending it to planning actually gives a
potential applicant Two
Shots um thank you for that question I
think typically when you appeal to the
zba from the planning board you're
appealing and interpretation of the
zoning ordinance and so perhaps another
piece of this that might be important to
clarify would be that if the uh property
owner loses at the planning board under
paragraph three they would still have
the opportunity to either go through the
traditional appeal or even I suppose go
through the traditional variance process
if they wish to do so so it would
preserve those mechanisms if they did
not succeed through the planning board
process any other questions for Miss
Burns
thank you very much thank you for your
time Drew
Klein thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Drew Klein and
president of the Josiah barlot Center
for Public Policy New Hampshire's free
market Think Tank we've done a lot of
research on zoning and have been heavily
involved in this in the last few years
and just wanted to um chime in on this
bill without you know endorsing every
single um aspect line by line of it I
think the concept is um
is welcome uh one of the major
justifications as you guys know for
zoning is to um prohibit negative
externalities right so you're going to
try to prevent um a a cost being opposed
on your neighbor and the problem with
the way it's done in top down zoning is
that you do sort of lock in these uses
and Zoning changes over time as you all
know so the Manchester example from
representative laog as a great example
and we have examples of from a lot of
the older towns in New Hampshire and
really all throughout New England where
you have a
beautiful pre- zoning Village or town or
even larger segment of the town and then
that is frozen in time because later
zoning was built up around it and then
you have an example where you've got
somebody with a lot that is perfectly
reasonable to build a home that look
looks like the rest of the
neighborhood it may even be exactly like
the rest of the neighborhood for example
a lot of these older communities do have
uh duplexes or triplexes right next to
single family homes and they've been
there for literally over a century
sometimes more and yet it's illegal to
build that one lot over the way we
currently do our top- down zoning so the
concept of this bill is it switches that
to sort of bottom up so it takes in the
account of the currently built
environment and I think that's the real
strength of this legislation it looks at
the currently built environment and says
we're going to do the th000 Ft if it
conforms with 90% of the currently built
environment in terms of density then
that should be an allowable build
without a variance and I think that's
the really important part here is it's
allowed by right just for two of those
uh factors so you can still have other
factors apply that you might have to get
a variance for but for the two listed in
the
bill if that's all it's pinging then you
can build it by Riot and I think that
what you're looking at is um
neighborhood Conformity that's been one
of the biggest complaints or the biggest
resistances to changing zoning um so
this one seems to be in pretty good
sweet spot in trying to keep that
neighborhood Conformity while allowing
some flexibility so we think it's a
positive development think it would lead
to some um good neighborhood
consistent um development in addressing
a housing problem so questions for Mr
Klein um my question is the density
Conformity assessment do you are you do
you know about those and can you talk to
me a little bit about what's required
with one of those yeah I we've done just
a minor bit of research on that because
it hasn't come up before in New
Hampshire in the way that we've wanted
to address so I wouldn't want to get too
much in the details of of research we we
have looked at some other cities so um
there have been cities around the
country that from from cities as large
as I think Denver and La have tried
something not exactly this bill but sort
of um looking at that sort of densing
Conformity thing um Asheville North
Carolina has taken a bit of an approach
sort of like that to try to get to the
same sort of thing we're still sort of
waiting to see what the Asheville
results are that was changed in 2017 but
um I don't want to get like decree one
way or the other on it but it but it is
something that's going around the
country as a way to address the top down
problem so you're seeing a lot of it
it's not entirely
new represent Howen really quick one so
does that the ruler the whatever you're
going to pick in terms of like how big
it is sure does that only apply within
that zone so in other words the problem
would be is if let's suppose I had a uh
a residential Zone that I have like half
acre or quarter acre lots and it butts
against like another Zone and the spirit
of your ordinance really was the next
Zone was a conservation subdivision it
was more Rural and if I'm able to reach
out with my thousand foot ruler and I
can cross over to the next Zone in the
rural zone or or I'm in the rural Zone I
cross back over the other one and say
look I should be able to build that
house it conforms to to that that thing
but it's not in the same Zone it's not
in the spirit of zoning yeah so I I hear
what you're saying I think the intent of
doing it this way is is that again
you're capturing the neighborhood right
so part of the problem with zoning is
it's rigid and it's line bound so you
can have a beautiful neighborhood on one
side of this line and a neighborhood on
the other that are right beside each
other it can even be the same
neighborhood but you've just simply
drawn an and they are arbitrary often
you've just drawn an arbitrary line and
said okay we're going to decide that
this side of that line you can only
build X on this side you can only build
X and it ignores the neighborhood
character so the advantage of doing it
this way with the Thousand ft is that
you're getting rid of the more rigid
arbitrary lines and you're making it um
more of a neighborhood look and I think
that I think there's a real advantage to
that rather than just forcing these
little blocks that somebody came up
with set okay no other questions thank
you Mr Klein thank you um last up is
Sarah
Holland good afternoon Sarah Holland New
Hampshire Association of Realtors um we
are here in support of this bill um I I
won't repeat some of the
um some of the items that were already
mentioned but when it comes to
zoning folks sometimes selfish exclude
because it is a long process sometimes
to get that variance that they're
looking for and it's not a guarantee
it's a possibility so folks will go
through um the application process they
will um sit through hearings they may do
designs expend money and time just for a
maybe this would be an opportunity for
them to look around their neighborhood
and go oh I see this I might be able to
do this here um there are still the
requirements that they do um the density
Conformity assessment whatever we are
deciding that that is going to be going
forward um to prove kind of their point
and make sure that it does align with
what is happening in the neighborhood
but this is one of those bold moves that
we need to do to move the needle on
housing and to create more opportunities
and create that infill that we're
looking for as opposed to creating new
neighborhoods that require um uh New
Roads new Bridges new amenities um and I
will remind you that most recently the
median sale price in New Hampshire was
$514,000 um and the average household
only makes 58% of what is needed to
afford that median income median
purchase price so we do need more
housing and this is a a common sense
approach to be able to do so happy to
take any questions other questions for
the
committee thank you thank
you um so I just want to gauge the
committee's appetite on this bill I I
think personally it needs a little bit
of work but um is there any interest in
creating a small subcommittee to look at
this representative
Paige I would be okay with that
yep yeah okay um so I'll just need
members from both parties on there so
I'll just take volunteers for it I want
all on there representative Allen
representative
Dumont representative
Boris representative
Grant and representative Gibbs
okay so would you like to serve as well
uh what would like what would the
overall commitment be just because I'm
coming from Littleton it's kind of a
commute for me well so a subcommittee
needs to be noticed 24 hours ahead of
time um it basically you the the
committee would get together and really
discuss um how to formulate this into a
workable document for the committee uh
we have until this isn't an early bill
so we have until um march to really get
this done so um it could take one
meeting could take two could take as
many as the committee desires but
um with that I just want to ask if
that's I mean I would be interested
because I think it is really important
okay so with that I'm going to um
appoint a subcommittee representative
Howen will you chair that committee all
right we're going to put representative
howand in charge with those um six
members representative Dumont Grant
borus bolo and Gibbs and with that I'm
going to recess or close the public
hearing on HB 342 and O un recess or re
recess uh uh representative Lads Bill HB
welcome well good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the housing committee
this chair is like a
couch um I didn't get that the other day
at education funding I don't think oh we
got one in there now too so come on down
sometime okay um I'm here today my name
is Rick lad I share education I'm a
house uh funding education and I'm here
today to uh present HB
296 I come from hail New
Hampshire and where I have been a select
board chairman on the planning board
there on the zoning board also water
commissioner and also on City Council in
Homer Alaska for three terms there and
dealt with a lot of these issues which
you're dealing with dealing with housing
and to start with I'd like to read just
one sentence that came from governor aot
in her inaugural address several shorts
weeks ago Governor aot stated in her
inaugural address quote if we're going
to remain the economic Beacon of New
England we need to start by tackling our
housing crisis we need to get serious
about housing production streamline
state agent gency approvals and partner
with our local
communities that's just not a message
for our state in terms of our government
agencies and departments and bureaus
it's a message for our local
municipalities as well the housing
crisis in the area where I'm living
right now is
horrendous our property taxes have just
been doubled the rates supposed to go
down proportionately uhuh they didn't
and we're going to see things going
higher and higher so we're being tapped
out but there for the young people we're
trying to attract on the Upper Valley
area it's very difficult for them to
find housing right now it's just not
available and we need young blood in
that Community as we do all through this
state so the bill that you have before
you is an attempt to try to streamline
and put in a fourth um fourth element
there in terms of how we issue building
permits off of private
roads the private road permitting
process can be unduly long costly and
may delay in push construction as I've
seen many times when I've been dealing
with this to a later season so
contractors miss that next season or the
season they're in and it's often times
delayed because the regulations and all
the roadblocks that are put forth in the
planning
board and we're talking about building
and getting permits off of that private
road so this legislation drives at the
idea that if the
municipality has approved a policy
dealing with building and building
issuing permits off a private road then
the permit for erecting a building uh
buildings off of that built private road
may be done by the governing body and
after review and comment by the planning
board doesn't say
approval and the issuance of the
building permit can move forward I
believe that is a process if you're in
compliance and you've dealt with all
those issues drainage e access to the
the highway you're trying to get on to
uh gradient uh slope all those issues
that planning boards look at I believe
that can be handled through policy so um
I'm not going to go any further on this
CU I basically stated what I'm trying to
do here I know there's others behind me
which um are anxious to speak on this uh
I've in doing this I'm not doing it as a
result of being contacted from people in
the hail area I've been contacted by
people farther down the river and south
of Hanover Lebanon area wishing and to
do the development but being styed by
the delays and time it takes to get
these permits and and and again once
again it's all about our housing whether
it be for the retired individual who
needs to you know uh drop scale down to
a house that's more affordable for them
or whether it's for the new person
moving into our community or just
anybody that needs to have housing that
can't find it and so that's what this is
about and I will stop right here and uh
rather than taking those technical
questions shoot them to the people that
you know you know I I've talked to other
attorneys that're behind me here and and
they have some ideas well this is how
you might amend the bill and all that um
the scope in which I'd like to see it
pass is the scope that I provided to you
right here dink with it a little bit if
you want but uh have
fun perfect well thank you very much
representative um you're all set thank
you very much have a good
one hey um I will now call on George
Hansel
thank you very much Mr chairman my name
is George Hansel I'm from Keane I was a
planning board member for more than 10
years there I was the mayor of Kean I
was a city councelor in Keane seen a lot
of permits come through the city a lot
of development happened I'm also a small
scale developer my partner and I do
about 40 units of new housing a year is
what we sort of shoot for and in all my
time as uh involved in local government
and in development I had never run
across this issue of of building on a
private road until last year and we had
uh an infill project we were building
three duplexes close to downtown keen
and it happened to be one of these old
Legacy private roads that we had never
run into before and the city staff and I
sort of work through this process to
comply with the current RSA and what it
required was a whole additional level of
approval through a planning board and
then to the city council and it was
somewhat of an awkward situation because
we got through those hearings and
attempted to comply with the current law
and there was nothing really there for
them to dig their teeth into I had to go
before my former colleagues and say I've
got this great project um and I need
your approval and they're sort of like
well approval for what are you going to
file the the uh the appropriate forms
with the um County at the County
Register of Deeds to say that you're
responsible for the road all that stuff
and I'm like yes um and there wasn't
much else the only advice I had for my
uh for the city council and the planning
board to give me my approval was some
research I had done on other um other
construction on private roads in New
Hampshire and looking at the minutes of
those meetings where those uh local
governing bodies were looking at this
and they came back to the fact they were
just really basically looking to make
sure that emergency vehicles could
access these these places so if you
built an apartment on a private road
they wanted to make sure that their
Emergency Services could get there um so
that seemed to be the Crux of it
and I got through my process our project
is actually almost almost complete and
going to be occupied in the next couple
of weeks but this brought up another
issue and I think while in my experience
this building on private roads is
somewhat of a rare occurrence I think
it's going to become more uh prevalent
mainly because in the city of and other
municipalities that are looking to
expand opportunity to construct housing
they're coming up with new ideas to
build that housing um in Keen we have
what's called a Cottage Court ordinance
which allows for cluster development uh
to try and create infill opportunities
and opportunities to build more housing
and each one of those cluster
developments uh is going to have a
private road and so anyone who wants to
build that is going to have to go
through the same process that I just did
with this somewhat redundant level of
oversight and so um I applaud
representative lad for putting this
forward I think this is a good step in
the right direction to try and
streamline things um what you have here
is legislation that I think was
originally created to protect the
municipalities from liability having to
do with people constructing roads and
then trying to get the municipality to
take care of them or be liable for
injuries that happen on those roads I
don't think that changing this
legislation in the way that's being
proposed is going to impact that at all
and I would actually encourage the
committee to look at this legislation
now as an opportunity for new ways to
build housing in the state of New
Hampshire and I know that places like
the city of Kean are looking to do that
so I encourage you to pass this and uh
I'm happy to answer any questions if
there are any thank you any questions
for Mr Hansel representative Howen then
representative Grant so so do you think
I mean it's kind of interesting in your
testimony do you think really with
private roads and this is full
disclosure I have a cabin on a private
road at the base of the Bell naaps are
you thinking more towards existing
private roads because if you're going to
do new developments with a cottage
cluster you you you probably don't want
to build a private road you probably
want to build a regular Road and I think
that when the your planning board is
doing your subdivision regulations
they're going to lay it all out and then
you really want your municipality to
accept that as a real Road just so it
would cover all the things that you just
said it the cost would be there you'd
make sure that it met for like emergency
vehicles you could get a garbage truck
down there and so while I can see the
streamlining of process it wouldn't you
want to streamline the the process on
the existing roads that you had those
Legacy roads and not build New Roads
that complicate your life or build new
develop I can see the advantage of both
I mean ideally yes you'd build the road
to the city standards and and hand it
over them for them to take care of but
what I see in the future is a lot more
planed unit developments and and um and
I don't think it's always necessary to
hand it over to the municipality I also
in my experience the municipalities are
usually hesitant to take on New New
Roads because it's more square footage
for them to take care of it's a it's a
future liability and so um the
willingness of the developer to M and
and eventually the community that has
that housing to to retain and take care
of that road is just going to help them
uh expedite that process if they don't
have to hand it over they don't have to
negotiate anything they can just move
forward represent
Grant thank you Mr chairman so I'm I'm a
bit confused here so you have a private
road who owns the property on each side
of that private road is it one owner not
necessarily it could be uh but not
necessarily okay so in your case in Kean
was it one owner that owned that there
were three Parcels that were had
Frontage on that private road Ro that
already had furn so there were already
lots of record per se and there were
existing buildings there so we were just
actually adding a new a new building and
we had to go through this whole process
so you're building private units is and
you're selling those is that what you're
doing uh we build them to rent or uh to
sell yep all right so you don't have to
have like an association that's going to
take care of that road I mean don't you
have to form an association that anybody
on that road is going to help maintain
that road so in this case it would be
the shared responsibility of the
property owners to take care of the road
so you you're kind of in since you're
Sur venting the subdivision process
right in this case it wouldn't your
couldn't have created we couldn't have
created a subdivision because these were
already individual Lots with individual
owners right but some of the private
roads that was one owner these are
followups right but a a Cottage Court
and this is important because it's not a
Cottage Court when likely be a
traditional subdivision it would
probably be one developer that came in
and and ran the private road into the
development and then you'd have um
likely like a parking lot and then
buildings uh usually smaller scale
buildings off of that and it sort of
creates like a what's called a plan unit
development but it wouldn't necessarily
be subdivided it could be one one whole
developer that that then lease the The
Cottages or the the uh the apartment to
folks thank
you other
questions representative
Gibbs thank you um do you think that it
would be a good idea to amend this bill
to require that um when building the con
you when proposing the construction that
somebody spec that the owners specify
who will be responsible that is whether
it'll be a particular owner such as your
cottage owners or whether it'll be an
association of everybody who lives on
that road because I could see if it's a
joint responsibility without anything
being specified that there would be a
lot of problems developing as who's
going to P the snowplow sure I think
that's already covered in the current
legislation because you have to file a a
document um identifying the responsible
party at the register of deeds and that
would attach with the the land on the
road and we're not attempting to modify
that requirement at
all thank you for your question all
right seeing none others thank you Mr
Hansel thank you very much marget
Burns good afternoon Margaret Burns
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we are in support of House
Bill 296 which we understand to be um a
separate another alternative to the
manner in which building on private
roads can be approved this being a
policy adopted by the select board as
opposed to going through the current
existing process which is review by the
select board after review and comment by
the planning board I do have two
comments for your consideration one is
that I do believe that line four has a
typo I do believe it's supposed to read
that the private road
identified complies with the policy
adopted Ed by the governing body um I
think that's just a simple uh correction
my second comment is that if this is to
be added to paragraph D1 and if you've
ever read this statute it is a never
ending list of paragraphs and
subparagraphs there is the paragraph
above it C1 is like a mirror image of D1
but it applies to approving building on
class six roads which are public roads
that are not municipally maintained
image and so there is probably logic If
This Were to pass an alter uh alter D1
that C1 should similarly be amended to
have this alternative approval process
uh by governing body policy thank you
that's helpful thank
you other questions Miss FS
seeing nothing thank you um is anyone
else here to testify on HB
296 come on
up just if you could after you speak um
submit a pink card so that I have
that and turn on your mic for us too
sorry I wrote my name on the blue sheet
not the pink card yeah so the blue is
for those who are not testifying oh
butcome thank you my name is Paul Alano
thank you for letting me speak Mr
chairman I submitted a letter and I'd
like to speak um just on some things in
addition to what's in my
letter and uh just to let you know who I
am I'm a lawyer my office main office is
here in conquer down the street on on
Park Street we have offices in Kean um
Portsmouth and and uh Bedford when I and
they just with actual lawyers in them
I've been practicing for about 40 years
all that time in real estate I've
represented Banks I've represented
borrowers I've represented developers
I've here before planning boards zoning
boards of adjustment uh Boards of Select
select boards I was there at the corner
of uh Handover Street and Elm Street
when the banks failed um wave to my
friends over at Ms G Bank when the banks
failed so we handled a lot of
foreclosures loan workouts dealt with
the Attorney General's office amending
the Condominium Act after that but the
one constant in my practice and the
thing that I'm known for is Rose s it's
a quirky area of the law but and
easements are also a part of that but
private roads class six roads class five
roads discontinued State highways
discontinued railroads who owns the land
who has what rights to use it
maintenance issues and building permits
and um I should also say in a prior life
I was also Senate legal council so I'm
very familiar with this building
although I haven't been here in probably
about 25 years
uh but I this bill did catch my
attention um and so I wanted to come
down and and offer some comments on it
because my clients are basically your
constituents constituents the people
that I represent that proest are really
more the one-offs they have uh property
on a uh one lot on a private road and
they try to get a building permit and
the issue that uh they run into and why
I'm actually I said that I was opposed
to the bill but I I think the concept is
a great concept because it is a problem
that there's no criteria at all there's
no guidance for select boards as to as
to what decision how how they should
approach these requests for building
permits except the one constant I've
seen is the maintenance issue and that's
why I think if you simply narrow it down
to whether excuse me not the maintenance
issue but the um whether or not
emergency vehicle can access the lot and
as written what this bill would do is
what I'm concerned about it's going to
lead to a whole another body of law that
that lawyers and and applicants have to
deal with we got zoning ordinances we
got subdivision regulations we got site
plan regulations we got building codes
and now we're going to have these things
called policies and uh I don't know what
a policy is I don't know what strength
it has to what extent uh someone could
challenge that but I am concerned about
that and I would suggest that you cut to
the Chase and simply have a one crit
which is can emergency vehicles get to
the lot um I gave you some examples in
my letter of some of the crazy things
that I've seen towns well due respect to
the people on the select boards but the
things that are added to these notices
that get recorded all the all the law
requires is a notice that says the
municipal acknowledgement the
municipality is not obligated to
maintain the road and not not liable for
any damage that's it but the select
boards will throw in these additional
I've seen other things too that I didn't
put in the letter but they'll throw in
these additional things and so I I would
the reason for my amendment is to
simplify it cut to the chase if an Emer
if an emergency vehicle can get to the
lot that's it it could be a dirt road uh
New Hampshire has a lot of private roads
a lot of private roads and as you know
and it was alluded to in the prior
testimony uh towns are hesitant to take
over maintenance of a road the cost to
maintain a road and I get that we run
into that all the time those kind of
those kind of uh situations
but if you want to
preserve uh private roads you got to
give people the ability to build on them
I think and all you have to do is make
sure that uh emergency vehicles can get
there as far as maintenance goes you
passed a statute 5 years ago it's RSA
231 colon
881a RSA 231 colon
881a and it requires people who live on
private roads to contribute equitably
toward the Roads Maintenance so you've
already got a statute on that um and if
you had a development like Mr Hansel had
recommended then you'd have probably
have covenants and would be you know it
would be part of the the approval
process um so that's that's uh that's
really all I wanted to say I'm happy to
answer any questions and appreciate your
time thank you attorney Delon um
representative buo yes thank you Mr
chairman um so yes I recognize your name
because I'm an attorney myself and I've
seen your advertisements in the bar news
every month so um thank you for um
submitting this testimony I did have one
question about the proposed amendment um
the uh HB 296 as it's written says or
after and then your change um says and
after and I'm wondering should it be and
or should it be
or well it could um I did intend it as
written that it would be so the current
process is the local governing body
let's say the selectman they get review
and comment from the planning board um
and then they
vote um I guess you could it could be an
or I mean if you wanted to you could
bypass the planning board part and I'll
be frank too I most of the time this
select boards don't bother with the
planning board part they're sort of
familiar with this statute and as
someone said earlier it's a it's a tough
statute it's a it's a tough read um but
I would think or would be would be fine
yeah well if you just to follow that
logic if you say and you're adding
another step to the process and I think
that goes against yeah it's a good point
yeah what I was trying to do was to um
as originally written you're going to
have these new policies so you're
sending this off to Pol policies to be
you know created and you have to make
sure they comply with the policies what
I was trying to do is to limit that part
but I think that's actually a good idea
if you put the put the or then you uh
you can make it even simpler the process
yeah great any other representative
Howen just one quick clarification so um
you can you get the building permit as
long as you can get emergency vehicles
down the road and it complies with all
your local building codes right I mean
all your setbacks your Heights all that
Absolut so that so in in addition to
that requirement that it's consistent
with all your local zoning codes correct
yeah no other questions thank you and if
you could fill out a pin card for us
that'd be great any other other um
people wishing to testify on HB um
296 seeing none I'm going to close that
public hearing and open up the next one
HB
444 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Reed welcome back to the
committee on
housing thank you Mr chair thank you
fellow
members um my name is alen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 that's new
market and Newfield
um so we've talked a lot about landlord
tenant issues here and this is
technically landlord tenant because it's
requiring something of a landlord very
very minor but really what I want to
talk about is ownership not renting
because when we talk about the housing
crisis and it is the biggest crisis in
this state we talk a lot about renting
but I can tell you renting isn't really
going to fix all of our wos because even
before we were here where we are now we
had a R of New Hampshire crisis because
we couldn't attract or keep working
class and working age people in this
state because the vast majority of
people and I know that people will be
like no some people want to rent the
vast majority of people want to own a
home they want to own it's a very
animalistic thing like you have your Den
you have your territory that you're safe
where you don't have to worry about a
landlord and what the landlord can and
cannot do to you and it will they kick
you out at the end of 12 months and what
have you you owning is the gold standard
for every metric in a community
communities that have high home
ownership rates do better than
communities that are more affluent but
have higher rental rates because the
people in that Community are more
invested even if it's be be it ever so
humble right even if it's humble they're
invested in their communities so we are
doing a disservice to this state if we
are not talking seriously about how to
increase home ownership
rates in the 80s a very loow hanging
piece of fruit was taken I think it was
1988 if I'm not mistaken and all it did
it was is what it said is that an owner
of a manufactured housing Park if he's
going to sell the park needs to give his
tenants 60 days notice before closing to
allow his tenants if they want if they
so choose to come together as a
Cooperative even though they're
lowincome and be able to finance and put
in an offer a competing offer it's not a
right of first refusal the landlord
doesn't have to accept it he just has to
allow 60 days notice to give them the
opportunity to decide whether they want
to try to buy their own property now
that sounds like a a little bit of
nothing to me but it is that little tiny
change has has produced over 200
resident-owned communities Each of which
have dozens of
homeowners and the the Manufacturing
Housing parks that became resident-owned
compared to the ones that have not they
have lower lot rents and higher
quality wow we were able to turn a bunch
of lowincome people who were renting
into homeowners thousands of them
thousands of them an amazingly
successful program with one tiny little
thing
60 days notice before final sale all
right so all I've done in this is say
okay cool compared to the number of
manufactured housing Parks we have we
have tons of multif family houses way
more and in other states there are
cooperatives in multif family
housing let's give it a go let's do that
60-day notice for multif family housing
only restricted properties of five units
or more so if it's like a little
fourplex or duplex you're exempt you
don't have to do that
but let's give them an opportunity to
just decide again nobody's forcing them
just decide oh wow I'm going to get a
new landl Lord someone's going to buy
it do you want to go co-op with me you
want to own this there are many by the
way um many different forms of Co-op um
there's nonprofit trusts and other types
of trusts there's condo isation um
there's many different forms and this
allows them an opportunity to choose
which organization to work with um if
they want to
even do it which form of Co-op they want
to choose but at the end of the day if
they choose it then they put an offer
and if it's a competing offer and that's
you know something that the landlord
sees as beneficial to
them they own their homes that's what we
need to be doing here in this state home
ownership and home ownership not just
for people who can afford a
$500,000 man mcmansion on a five acre
lot home ownership
be it ever so
humble
so what I've heard and by the way I'm
I'm having direct experience with this
right now because I'm helping a
manufactured housing community in
Danville go Co-op they just like not
even two weeks ago voted to uh go Co-op
and put in an offer of $18
million so the push back I've heard last
time I put this bill in and some of the
emails that we have received is that it
is very very onerous for the person
selling to have to wait 60 days now
normally with most
um transfer of per private property
deals it takes a few months to close you
need inspections you need lawyers you
need the whole there's a whole process
and so two months really isn't that big
a deal the very specific example given
is what if the person isn't actually
intending to sell because if they're
intending to sell they can just give the
notice right then in there they put it
on the market they give their tenants
notice boom they'll be fine but what if
someone they weren't intending to sell
and someone comes and gives them a cash
offer well that might happen a lot that
closes a lot faster
right okay worst case scenario because
these the again is five units or more
right so we're talking about most likely
structures that have a a value of over a
million dollars maybe several million
dollars so worst case scenario we are um
uh making someone wait a few weeks to
give their tenants a chance to be
homeowners a few weeks on their
multi-million dollar deal I don't think
that's a big deal
I I'll get back to this because I want
to address a few other things but just
put a pin in that concept okay you're
making them wait a few extra weeks
that's such a tiny ask to to address
home ownership thousands of manufactured
housing homes are now home own or home
are homeowners right how many more if it
was multif
family but some of the other issues um
well what if they don't want to if they
don't want to they don't do it it's not
a big deal um what if well if they
wanted to own well wouldn't they have
just bought a condo well no right now
you can't buy anything right now you
can't hardly find anything that's even
vacant and available to to to be bought
but in the case that you can you
certainly can't find one that's
affordable and so no but also some
people won't want to and then they get
to sell that's amazing now they're a
homeowner and they get to sell and leave
right and then they can go rent or they
can say no that they don't want to be go
go Co-op again it's up to
them um another one was uh isn't there a
difference between manufactured housing
Parks which are separate units on a
shared land and a multif family house
which are units that are attached on a
shared land yeah there are some but
there's co-ops of multif family housing
in other places there's HOAs that apply
to buildings have multiple units as well
as uh property that has single family
units so I don't see the differences as
that um pertinent to this
bill and another thing is even if they
don't want to go Co-op I have two
stories from people tenants in my town
of New Market one was uh these are both
uh groups of tenants that found out that
building had sold a after it had sold so
they oh I didn't even know I had a new
landlord until I got noticed that my
rent's going up one was the new the the
person buying had basically pretended
that he was a neighbor and had an AB
buding piece of property and went to one
of the tenants and asked um for the
landlord's number so he could ask the
landlord questions about this tree which
was maybe on this property or that
property turns out it was just someone
who wanted the landlord's information so
that they could he could go he went to
his house during dinner time to
aggressively give him an offer 50% over
asking price so that he could then turn
around and raise the rents three times
what they were paying that's what
happened in that case the other scenario
was a a buyer that gained access to look
at the units by claiming he was an
insurance
adjuster so even if you don't want to go
Co-op and you want to rent and you
decide to turn on the offer to go Co-op
and put in an offer of your own you
still want to know when your building's
going to be sold right instead of being
lied to and manipulated and then
surprise surprise you have a new
landlord and your rent's going to go up
300% and one thing I did not highlight
the last year when this was in was um
the fact that this benefits the seller
the landlord if you have more than one
entity putting an offer in on your
property that benefits you if you have
an offer for $1 million and then the
tenants go Co-op and they put in 18.5
million in hopes that you take their
offer and then this person puts in
another offer you get competing offers
you have a bidding war that helps the
seller I don't understand why anyone
would be against this and in fact in 40
years of this being in place in law
there's been no significant complaints
from manufactured housing Park owners
this has not been onerous no one's tried
to repeal the law no one's coming
complaining that oh my God I had to give
notice 60 days before closing this was
so
terrible so I'm going to go back to the
point that I said put a pin in because I
think very often in this
building we as legislators were kind of
like the analogy of the people who work
at the US Mint and we don't realize that
the we see the money going in front of
us so much that we don't realize that
we're looking at millions of dollars we
don't realize the value of the thing
that we're looking at we look at about a
thousand pieces of law that will impact
the lives of 1.3 million people every
day we look at these laws and we make
decisions on I'll speak from my personal
experience and dealing with other uh
Representatives we make them on the most
ridiculous and atrocious
motives our priorities tend to get out
of whack in this place we tend to get
out of
touch when I hear that we have a loow
hanging fruit that has been incredibly
successful in helping people own homes
and owning homes will solve the housing
or help solve the housing crisis the
graying of New Hampshire crisis the work
crisis all these interwoven crisis that
we could do this with this loow hanging
fruit that's been working for 40 years
but we're not going to because
oh I don't really want to give notice
and wait a few extra weeks for my deal
to
close I think we need to get our
priorities
straight I think we need to get our
priorities straight that we think
inconveniencing people who are doing
quite well in a period of time where
they're making record profits mind you
inconveniencing those people is so much
more important than solving the fact
that people are literally dying in the
gold at the fastest rate in the country
that's my testimony I'm open for
questions thank you representative are
there questions for representative
Reed seeing none oh represent Miner
thank you Mr
chairman hi Mrs Reed representative re I
was premature I apologize represent
that's okay so my question because I
don't see any time here and again this
is all new to me I hate to be about
things but there's no time limit I am a
little bit familiar with how things
co-op in the mobile home park it is a
little timely um is this is this
supposed to be exactly the same format
as when a mobile home park coops or is
this yeah so last year I had OSS copy
and paste RSA 205 which is the thing
that allowed all these manufactured
housing parks to go Co-op these
resident-owned communities I said them
copy paste and in that that time
Judiciary there was a lot of confusion
amongst the members because it seemed
like I was writing that out of scratch
like I had invented that language and
the only reason I had that language is
because that's what existed so in this
version of the bill same exact thing but
instead of copy pasting it simply
references the RSA so it just says that
uh before final unconditional acceptance
which would be the closing um 60 days
notice and an opportunity to make an
offer in the same manner and according
to procedures required of a manufacturer
housing Park in RSA 205 except you don't
involve New Hampshire manufactured
housing Association so it's the same
exact to the to the word the same exact
process happy to maybe email the
committee 205 so they can look at it but
that's basically all it
says okay thank you representative for
your testimony um so moving forward we
have a few speakers I'm just going to
try to keep it to three minutes so we
can finish up hopefully by four o'clock
um so with that I'll call on Chris
Freeman
oh I'm so I'm sorry representative I
forgot you put in a
after representative cyber I'll call on
you
next no turn it on first thank you hello
again um so uh first of all I just want
to acknowledge representative Reed's uh
enthusiasm for home ownership that's
something that um I I feel uh very
personally my daytime hat is with a 100%
associate owned uh employe emper so I
definitely uh feel the the importance of
ownership on a very visceral level um I
I don't uh particularly agree with the
contention that the 60-day notice period
is is not onerous and I would also um
Express that I have some concerns with
the creation of a new law governing
multif family um to be incorporated by
reference from an existing statute I
think that um manufactured home parks
are very conducive to conversion to
housing cooperatives uh based on the
fact that often the individual units are
already owned um by the occupants and
the portion that's being purchased is
the land beneath that um which isn't
necessar or is not the case in um in
multif family uh within multif family
different unit types are going to be
more conducive to conversion than other
types uh if you have something that was
purpose built as multif family where you
have submetered units um and you have a
pretty consistent mix of unit size and
type uh that's pretty straightforward to
do a co-op or condominium conversion on
uh but a lot of the housing stock in New
Hampshire is pretty old you can have
large single families that were chopped
up into smaller units um where that
process might not be quite a
straightforward uh another thing I'd
like to point out uh when we're talking
about specifically whether this is an
onerous proposition or not and the
timeline uh considerations are in uh 205
a21 uh paragraph 2 uh that States during
the notice period required under par
paragraph 1 the manufactured housing
Park owner shall consider any offer
received from the tenants or tenants
Association if any and the owner shall
negotiate in good faith with the tenants
concerning a potential purchase if
during the notice period the tenants
decide to make an offer to purchase the
manufactured housing Park such offer
shall be evidenced by a purchase and
sale agreement however the tenants shall
have a reasonable time beyond the 60-day
notice period if necessary to obtain
financing for the purchase and so one of
the questions I would have is whether
good faith negotiation means
compromising your timeline which could
very well be impacted by other
considerations like doing a 1031
exchange um or engaging in a portfolio
sale I think that that provision could
be problematic and and it creates
ambiguity around what constitutes good
faith and then and then just one one
last point if I could um it is I believe
and I don't have the data on this but I
believe that it is more common in multif
family portfolios for there to be other
uh factors that could impact the
feasibility of executing a co-op
conversion one of which is that
portfolio sales are more common than in
uh mobile home parks uh it's not that
uncommon to bundle 20 properties and
sell them off if you're a larger
landlord and that's the efficient way
for you to do it and there are also
situations where if you are a larger
landlord with these commercial multif
Family Properties you don't necessarily
have in your commercial lending
covenants the ability to get a partial
release uh and sell off units
individually so it also raises the
question of would the um tenants be
obligated to purchase the entire
portfolio from the landlord or could
they go forward with an efficient sale
thank you for your testimony questions
for Mr
Freeman seeing none thank you um
representative
cirt o there we go sorry thanks everyone
for your time today um a co-sponsor on
this legislation just introduce yourself
for us that'd be great what introduce
yourself for us oh yeah I'm Christine
cybert I'm from um Hillsboro district 21
which is W one in
Manchester and um so I'm here today
because this has become a really
important issue to a lot of folks I've
come across um one person in particular
this past summer um had an issue she
heard about me through a friend um who
knew I did a lot of you know I was just
kind of dabbling around in in housing
related issues and apparently it so I
end up talking with a teacher from
Auburn who lives in Manchester and her
building was sold all of a sudden so on
one Saturday just very randomly the new
owner came up and told her that her rent
was changing as of 30 days she had her
rent was doubling and then on top of
that Within in 30 days they wanted to
put in a new down payment or that's what
they wanted from her a new updated down
payment because of the change of
ownership and that would be based on
also that new rent cost so she's like
how do I pay for this she's like is this
even legal like is this why is it okay
for them to do this and I really didn't
have an answer for her you know
unfortunately it's kind of like
Moonlight at a strip Club is like my
only option to tell her um cuz how do
you make money that fast that much money
people don't always have thousands of
dollars laying around even if you own a
home you know um and I just like to add
that within the past you know a couple
of years there's been a lot of instances
where people move out of the state
because they cannot find housing a lot
of them are young couples they had been
saving up they're looking for their
American dream and people were watch
walking into these open houses and they
were essentially you know walking in
with $100,000 cash left and right and
literally there were no homes left and
so I just want to say that people are
just going to move away and the fact
that we're charging double what an
average mortgage cost and rent for one
person in a multif family home is
completely nuts to me and they're also
expected it see seems to take care of a
lot of the maintenance essentially do
all of the upkeep for the home as if
they were an owner without being having
opportunity to actually be one so thank
you I'll take any questions thank you
any any questions for
representative seeing none thank you
thank you Nick Norman
thank you once
again I would so my name is Nick Norman
I would start by saying I would ech Echo
the things that Chris Freeman said and
quite well so I'm not sure that I could
add much better description of a lot of
that than what he has already said Real
Estate is can is very the real estate
world industry is very large and complex
particularly when you're talking about
different kinds of multif family and
rental homes it's it's U such a bigger
piece to just say
every sale of every kind of real estate
would have to go through the 60-day
notice period I do believe would be very
owners and it would impede sales um you
know I can't say I know that process of
mobile home conversion but just the the
fact that the market is
fast and sometimes a housing provider
might need to sell quickly and then if
you've got uh the the ability and
requirement actually not the ability to
have this 60 day notice that could
impede the sale suppose you've got a
sale under agreement that this buyer are
they going to are they going to now walk
away because someone else could
effectively compete and beat them out of
that
sale just doesn't make sense to me is it
is it really that possible for tenants
of a multif family property to pull
together and
buy you know this
large this multif family and there's
there's no scope on limit on this you
know development of a thousand units
goes through the same process the the
pro the uh possibility of talking about
the portfolio sales that stuff happens I
I can't imagine what a nightmare that
would be in trying to portfolio sell
your properties and having this in the
middle of
it uh it seems to me it could also
sometimes have a negative effect to the
existing tenants if you've got tenants
that are financially disadvantaged
because that's that's you know who they
are they're renting because they're in
that position and you've got a group of
tenants trying to buy the building it
seems to me that could logically end up
with the people that can't afford it
being
displaced because they can't keep up
with whatever is in required in terms of
their proetta share of costs maintenance
and whatever it would take to to pull
the sale uh to
happen there's also some ambiguity in in
the the way it's written 60-day notice
from what I know representative Reed
said from closing but it doesn't say
that Mr Norman if you could wrap up for
us that'd be great so uh I just think
there's a lot of complications with it
and it
would tie up investors hands we need to
have people invest and create more
housing more than tie up their hands I'd
be happy to take questions thank you Mr
Norman questions representative Gibbs
thank you um Mr Norman you mentioned
that uh tenants who have housing Choice
vouchers otherwise known as Section 8
could not participate in a purchase um
are you aware that there are types of
Section 8 vouchers that allow for
purchase of a home so I don't know all
the intricacies of Section 8 I do know
that the program for Section 8 or let's
say subsidized housing is very large
there's a Section 8 there's another
there's another kind of section there's
a section two and there's a section
something else I don't know all of those
options um what I'm referring to there
is
basically someone that doesn't have
strong financial means is very unlikely
to be able
to
purchase all right seeing nothing thank
you and the last speaker on this is
David Klein
being last and knowing everybody wants
to go I'll try and be as brief as
possible thank you uh my name is David
Klein I just want to start off with
something representative Reed said
that's not true a fourplex is restricted
property unless its owned or occupied
that's an RSA 540
A1A um and one of the things that I feel
about this bill the feasibility of it is
problematic because you have a a real
contrast between mobile home owners who
are in a park than trying to buy a park
you're starting off with people who own
their mobile home they have credit or
they wouldn't have been able to get a
mortgage they've dealt with mortgage
payments they have to maintain the
interior and exterior of their mobile
home as well as the grounds and these
are people have a layer of
sophistication that some tenants will
have and some tenants will not have
versus in in a multif family building we
we run the gamut we have one building
where we have people that
third floor they both work for the
passport center in Portsmouth and
they're hourly workers and then we have
another tenant who she has her father
who's retired and a teenager she works
retail she has enough money to pay a
rent but there's no way she's going to
have to be no way she'll be able to
float the cost of the mortgage on top of
all of the maintenance expenses of the
building as a result we're going to have
a lot of these we're going to have to
offer if we want to sell it the 60 days
go through all of the delays and the
financing issue is as been reported
before in the in 205a it's reasonable
time there's no definition and that's
unclear what a reasonable time will be
and I think we're going to have a lot of
these where are just going to sit there
buildings won't be able to be sold new
developers are going to look at it and
say hey if I develop a building and go
to sell it how long is it going to take
me to be able to sell it we want to
encourage Builders to come into the
state build more Apartments I mean you
heard the uh testimony of earlier where
were only building there was like 4,000
housing permits put out last year that's
ridiculous given our needs let's not put
in something that would be a deterrent
to people building and making it more
complicated to sell the properties after
you build them which is where really we
lie the profit is for the
builders thank you for your testimony
questions from Mr Klein representative
Gibbs thank you uh what it alter your
position on this bill if it were amended
to provide a specified period of time
that would be a reasonable amount of
time to obtain financing no I don't
think so I I still feel that you're
tying it up you're going to need 60 days
right off the bat according to the 205a
to even negotiate a purchase and sale
agreement then it's going to be at least
another 60 days to obtain financing and
then the title search and the other
closing times so it's still going to be
delay in my mind of five to six months
at a
minimum all right any other
questions um representative
kwin thank you um I I just might have
misheard you but did you um say that
having multiple um offers might uh there
be a risk of not being able to sell um
and wouldn't the opposite happen then
that multiple offers would actually
drive up the price I might have
misunderstood I had I said nothing about
multiple offers okay in my testimony at
all sorry thanks uh representative
Paige thank you uh Mr chairman I'm I'm
trying to tease out the distinction that
we're drawing
between folks living in a manufactured
home and renters in a multif family
Union uh multif family building and I'm
I'm just not
understanding what's qualitatively
different about these two types of
individuals you know we have the
successful model with manufactured
housing I hear you talking about one
tenant who's working
retail but you know I've had tenants
working retail who rent from me and then
move on to buy a manufactured home um so
I'm just trying to understand
qualitatively what's the difference
between these two classes of people of
what I said is the tenants are very
diverse and in their knowledge their
financial background their abilities to
handle maintenance issues things of that
nature some of the tenants as you said
the your retail people people worked in
retail put aside money obviously
developed a down payment had good credit
we have tenants that can do that we have
tenants that have terrible credit they
can't handle a dime if they didn't live
on cash paycheck to paycheck that's
that's the way they get by and actually
at one point we're renting weekly during
the big uh recession because that was
the only way we'd get paid so the all
I'm saying is that you got such a
diversity there's going to be a chunk of
those tenants can I quantify it no that
will not be able to buy in they don't
have the resources or uh the
sophistication that's what I was trying
to say as and I also want to point out
something I forgot is don't forget a lot
of these multifamilies are mixed use
buildings how do you address the retail
or the other type of use the commercial
use on the first floor you don't have
that in mobile home parks you do that
have that in many of the down downtown
locations and in fact most towns in the
downtown areas are now requiring it by
zoning any new buildings have to be
commercial on the first floor what do
you do with these retail
tenants and that's not addressed because
205a does not deal with that type of
thing okay any other questions see none
thank you Mr Klein is anyone else here
to testify on HB
444 okay seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing at 327 and hand the
gavl over to my vice
chair okay we'll open the public hearing
on Bill number 399 and recognize
representative Alexander well thank you
Mr chairman members of the housing
committee for the record my name is Joe
Alexander I represent the town of gtown
I'm serving my fourth term um which is
Hillsboro District um 29 um I mainly put
this in and and this is one of the great
bills that has um believe it or not you
know leadership on the Republican and
Democratic side the leaders are both
supporting um as well as bipartisan
support in the Senate and what this
mainly would do and you'll see with the
legislative intent that I wrote um it
would basically establish a commission
to study the historical evolution of the
New Hampshire zoning enabling act so
coincidentally and I did not clain this
but I was really excited to hear that um
it's turning 100 this year so what
better thing to do than to study
something that's turned 100 years old um
so what this bill would do was establish
a commission um a bipartisan commission
it would include housing experts it it
would include members of both parties um
the legislature I believe member of the
public um to really study um the
questions that I outlined
in the commission so that is on that's
going to start on line 25 of the bill is
going to be the questions that um we
would study and the purpose of it is
basically to study how it has evolved
over the years so um you know how the
courts have weighed in on zoning how um
the powers have been construed um it
would basically examine RSA 674 which is
how the state has enabled local zoning
so um with that I have a lot of people
here experts that are willing to speak
in favor of the bill so um I hope you'll
defer questions to them but I think this
is a um something the legislature um
because we give powers to towns I think
it's something that we absolutely have
to study occasionally and I think 100
years is a great time to do it so with
that I'm gonna end my testimony thank
you one I'm sorry one other thing Mr
chair if I could um like unlike most
commissions this one is going to sunset
at the end of this term so it that's
online um 29 on page two so rest assured
this is not going to be one of those
commissions that will be alive through
the the recesses of the rest of time so
this this will go away at the end of
this
term thank you there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you keeping the spirit of moving things
along we'll keep the public testimony to
three minutes I'll call up Greg
Moore morning Mr chairman of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
speak here today for the record my name
is Greg Moore I'm a regional director
with Americans for Prosperity here today
to testify in support of House Bill
399 last year when I was before the
special committee on housing and I'm
sorry that you guys aren't special
anymore you're special to me uh but but
this I said as we were going through a
number of the changes that addressed
local zoning and planning I said we can
continue this process of playing wacka
or we can try to basically open up and
look at the entirety of how we handle
local zoning and planning this
ultimately is is I think if the the
process that this creates is possibly
the most important thing that I think
this committee will do over the Arc of
over the Arc of the the next two years
if we get this right then I think we can
fix a lot of our problems I know the
governor A's working on the agency side
the executive brand stuff she's trying
to do what she can on with the
permitting and things like that and uh
was at a forum last Thursday to hear
about quite quite a few of those but
ultimately this this legislation House
Bill 399 uh looks at the root cause
starts getting into the root cause
analysis and tries to figure out how can
we look at the amount of amount that
we've been Authority we've granted to
local governments and assume and
determine if uh they have overs their
boundaries or whether or whether it's in
the right spot or how it could be
adjusted and adapted after 100 years I
think the people on the commission are
good I think the idea of having uh
National experts is critical for people
who can take a look outside of New
Hampshire look at what's going on in
other states and what they're doing what
the challenges that they're facing so
bringing people to the table who who
come from outside of New Hampshire or or
at least are National experts I think is
adds a real value I think adding the
Judiciary in here is critical because
the Judiciary is uh at least as culpable
as a legislature of getting us to some
of the mess we're in now so having them
have a seat at the table that we believe
is critical and we believe uh to having
the public uh because it is number one
issue facing uh the public in New
Hampshire is is the issue lack of lack
of housing affordable or otherwise we
just have a lack of Housing and so uh
having someone who can bring that uh
experience and bring that the idea of
the impact that it's having from the
public is is the right right method and
so we think that the people involved the
scope is correct and so we we're pretty
supportive of uh the chairman for for
bringing this legislation um I could say
that I said to do it last year and he
listened to me so going to take a little
a little credit here no I'm joking I
know he knows I know that he knows that
this is a problem that needs to be
addressed so with that I'd be happy to
take any questions thank you are there
any
questions seeing none thank you Mr Moore
call Nick Taylor to the
stand sorry have to leave oh he's not
here okay move on to Drew
Klein thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee at Drew Klein the
president of the ji bord Center for
Public Policy uh unlike my friend Greg
Moore I know that it's afternoon and not
morning so good afternoon to you guys we
um have studied this issue extensively
if any of you haven't seen it I will try
to deliver it to you um but you can
Google Josiah Bartlett Center housing
study 2021 we looked at land use
regulations in New Hampshire going back
uh for decades to try to get a sense of
what was the problem why did we have
this housting shortage and you know our
study did conclude that the land use
regulations at the local level are the
the primary cause of New Hampshire's
housing shortage one of the things that
we did in our historical look back which
did not go back um a century in depth in
New Hampshire was um that evolution of
how stated principles and reasons for
land use regulations are not necessarily
the current reasons why Lan use
regulations are being used and they do
change over time so a look back like
this I think is really important for New
Hampshire uh century mark is a great
time to do it you'll find I think based
on what we've done in New Hampshire but
also looked at in other states you will
find massive um Mission creep in these
regulations you'll find possibly that
there are
um that regulations aren't matched up to
what they're supposed to do so for
example in RSA 67417 I believe uh one of
the stated reason for zoning is to
justifications for zoning is to reduce
traffic congestion well we're pretty
well established that zoning increases
traffic congestion so you're going to
find a lot of problems um and a lot of
uh change over time and some of the
stuff you've you've talked about today
um but I agree with Greg's
interpretation that of all the things
this committee does this year this is
probably the most consequential and most
important because until now the
legislature has tried to take these
issues on discreetly one at a time and
you can see
how that has worked out so taking this
approach a holistic approach I think and
getting to the root of the issue is
really going to serve New Hampshire very
very well and it'll give at the very
least everybody in New Hampshire a real
sense of how we got to where we are and
if if we want to keep going in that
direction and I think the stated mission
of this um commission is is really good
the list of things you're going to look
at is just the kind of things that you
want to identify so we think this is a
great effort and just to give you you
know an example with um one of you guys
was mentioning some of the housing data
so every time I mention the statistic um
I think a lot of people find it
surprising so if you look back 50 years
to 1970
3 um the building permit data the most
recent that we have that the states
publish is from 2023 so if you look back
50 years in
1973 uh developers were allowed to pull
or to they were given approved 7,700
building permits in that year for
residentials that's both single family
and multif family in 2023 it was 4500
total in
1973 we had fewer than 00,000 people in
New Hampshire I think as memory serves
it was about 790,000 people so we have
1.4 million people
today and we're building a fraction of
the homes and demand for homes is much
higher and 1973 was the beginning of the
Arab Oil Embargo recession
so that's the situation we're in right
now and our work at J Bartlet Center has
identified those local land use
regulations as the primary cause of that
reduction and building permits and
building in general so taking a
comprehensive look at it is absolutely
the right way to do it and it'll cut
through a lot of the problems that you
guys have been seeing and the
legislature has been seeing trying to
tackle this one little discreet
regulation at a time that's all thank
you there are any questions
representative Reed thank you and hello
Mr C hello representative as you know um
I don't frequently agree with Josiah
Bartlet Center on a lot but um I think
you might appreciate my question sure
which is that is it your opinion that
the state of zoning that we find
ourselves in today as you were talking
about Mission creep has far exceeded
both the uclid V Ambler Supreme Court
decision in 1926 as well as the
analogous New Hampshire Supreme Court
decision both of which had determined
that zoning ordinances really are only
leg legate in that they are for health
and safety and not for arbitrary
aesthetic purposes yeah well so I thank
you for the question representative Reed
and this is one of the things that I
Delight in when the Bartlet Center uh
can find agreement with uh folks from
all different perspectives and points of
view you certainly see in the ENA
Statute in New Hampshire that it enables
Zoning for health safety and uh the
general welfare and as we all know from
the US Constitution that phrase is
problematic it opens up a big hole for
very broad uh use of these statutes and
what we have seen over the decades is a
massive Mission cre is M municipalities
getting away from health and safety and
as I talked about before in the previous
Bill those externalities right so you're
really supposed to just be looking at
harm caused by a building or a
development but we have statues or
ordinances that go down to paint colors
and you know various aesthetic purposes
they get really really detailed and it
gets really silly and that's a far
stretch from the original idea of health
and safety now you could there's a lot
of research online about the actual or
origins of zoning in San Francisco and
New York and we could get into a whole L
conversation about that um but I think
you can certainly look at the last
couple of decades and see that the
zoning has strayed from its what it
should have been in New Hampshire was
very narrowly tailored to health and
safety
any other
questions thank you thank
you we'll call Sarah
Holland good afternoon Sarah Holland New
Hampshire Association of Realtors um we
Echo um the support stated previously um
New Hampshire's housing challenges
require thoughtful data driven Solutions
and this bill offers an important step
towards ensuring that our zoning laws
support growth affordability and
Community
stabilization um for these reasons I
urge the committee to support the
legislation and Advance the formation of
the study commission and the New
Hampshire Realtors would welcome an
opportunity to be a part of this further
discussion and provide resources as may
be appropriate thank you uh short and
sweet any questions representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm happy that we are
on the same side on this one um so being
I'm hoping that you have some
information being with the Realtors on
this particular issue because we just I
just brought up about the health and
safety aspect and how this was what was
what made zoning legitimate according to
a scotus decision and a New Hampshire
Supreme Court decision are you aware of
the practice of redlining that began
around that time and made um made those
decisions kind of necessary um and do
you think that potentially the uh
Mission creep we've seen or the moving
of the goalpost that we've seen might be
kind of get its roots and origin in that
practice Yeah so red Linings Origins
were in the the financial lending aspect
um and and yes absolutely we still see
it today in a number of communities both
inside and outside of the state um and
all of this falls into zoning and and
the power that is given from the state
to the municipalities to be able to
manage their own communities so I do
think that with a 100-year anniversary
this year that it does make sense to
revisit any other
questions thank you Miss Holland is
there anybody else that would like to
testify on this
Bill yes you fill out a pink card after
you're done thank you
um so I'll just Echo what I think
somebody else said which is that uh
revisiting zoning I think is probably
the only thing that we've discussed
today that is ultimately going to matter
um you know we can get into the the ins
and outs of landlord tenant law but at
the end of the day we fundamentally have
an issue with supply and demand and you
can trace that directly back to um the
the land use regulations that we have
here in New Hampshire um if you look at
the report that's compiled by the KO
Institute I believe uh as of the most
recent report New Hampshire ranks 37th
out of 50 for the ease of navigating our
land use restrictions um the other hat
that I wear I I'm an aspiring developer
I'd like to move Beyond just buying the
stuff that already exists to actually
building new stuff uh or or converting
uh underperforming or underutilized off
office space uh into new residential and
what we found uh for the past several
years is that's a very difficult space
to break into and a big portion of that
is because there's so much uncertainty
that comes from the zoning and land use
regulations as somebody else mentioned
um they can be extremely prescriptive in
Keen we we updated it to modernize it
and uh some of those modernizations
included specifying the visible light
transmittance of glass at uh zero
setback properties on Main Street um
specifying the number of inches that
stories above four have to be set back
uh from the story below it unless you
have a decorative spire on the corner
and it started to sound to me listening
through those hearings like uh maybe
they should design the build buildings
and then pay someone to build them um
but I think at the end of the day what
we want is to attract private investment
in the New Hampshire housing stock and
the more we can do to simplify that uh
the better one of the themes that's
going to come up in those conversations
a lot is local control and uh one of the
things I I feel very conflicted on that
because on the one hand I think that
decentralization is a good way to get a
natural laboratory effect and see which
Solutions work and which ones don't at
the same time that concept of delegating
that power to the municipality is
ultimately taking power away from the
people over their own properties there's
a need for this there's an opportunity
for us to address it through new
development and we're just strangling
that possibility out of existence okay
do you anybody have any questions thank
you do there anybody else would like to
testify all right I will close the
hearing at 3:45
right thank you um representative Cole
for that um I guess I want to ask
um I know we we heard a lot of testimony
today from different bills I appreciate
everybody sticking with me this long um
hopefully my scheduling will get better
as time goes on but again you can't
account for um very important questions
from the committee as well so um that's
part of it so um with that are I know I
said I didn't want to ex but are
you we have 15
minutes I guess I want to get the
committee's
um straw pole and their interest in
voting one bill out of committee the the
last one we heard
today um is everybody comfortable voting
I'm not going to ask you how well okay
if voting in favor of HB 399 today
raise your hand if you're
not okay representative
so represent readed can
I yeah let's no let's
um um no I'm gon to at this point I'm
going to open up the executive session
on House Bill 399 so
um as is my write his chair so um at
this point I want to call on
representative Paige who has an
amendment that he has drafted um that uh
I'll let you I'll let you
start all right I and is there can you
are you able to make a
motion uh sure yeah right um so this
amendment which Joe will circulate in
the other
direction
um yeah so I need you to make a favor of
a to pass and move sure I'll move I uh
make a motion of ought to pass on
Amendment 23 H2 HB
399 yes so ought to pass second on your
motion okay ought to
pass you want to move the amend you want
to move ought to pass I seconded it and
now you're going to move the amendment
beautiful and I will second that should
we do it again no does everybody
understand what we just did yes all
right all right now I'm moving the
amendment all right
um so uh the
amendment uh that you have before you
this just changes makes some um modest
changes to the appointing authority of
the various members of the commission um
I think the strength of this commission
is in ensuring that the findings that we
receive from the commission have buyin
from everyone that it's bipartisan and
when we see these find findings it
doesn't become a partisan fight over how
legitimate those findings are I think
this this makes it um makes those
findings more reliable for everyone it
will give us more uh backup when we come
with subsequent bills flowing from the
research this commission conducts so I
think it's um supportive for both
parties thank you represent Paige other
comments on
this all right um I'mma give the clerk a
second so we're going
to we're going to
um call a roll on the the amendment so
that's amendment
number um 20250
0023 and I'm just give the clerk a
minute
okay so I'll while the clerk's getting
organized I just want to say that um in
conferring with representative Paige and
um this came from another Senator as
well um I'm totally down with the
bipartisan nature of this commission I
think that's the most important part of
it is that it maintains it stays
bipartisan I think this is a great way
to start the committee on housing to
start on a good front um from there so
um can I I I also just want to say for
members of my caucus that I that Joe
asked me if I was comfortable or the
chairman asked me if if I was
comfortable with this so I want folks to
know that represent Aon can we have a
moment to read the amendment and the
original or can representative paage
just point out the
differences go ahead and point the
differences out sure so um we
are making the House of Representative
members be twoo appointed by the
majority leader to by the minority
leader so there's parody there the
Senate appointments are made jointly so
essentially with the consent of both the
president and the minority leader um and
then uh when we get to the National
Housing policy experts again these are
joint
appointments um municipal government
appointment is a joint appointment and
um the member of the public is a joint
appointment and again here the goal is
that there's agreement these are
National policy experts who we all trust
to provide that input thank you very
much does that help yeah okay other
questions about the amendment the
makeup okay seeing none is clerk ready
all right clerk will call a
roll okay this is on the
amendment uh Vice chair Vice chairman
Cole
yes re representative Thaxton not here
not here
okay uh representative Aaron
yes representative buer
yes representative
Dumont
yes representative Grant yes
representative miles not
here representative Miner
yes clerk reinford yes representative
Paige yes representative boras yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative hegner
yes representative Kerwin
yes and chairman Alexander yes
go ahead tell us um y's are 16 Nays zero
not here two Bill Bill Amendment passes
1602 awesome so the amendment was
adopted I want to hear discussion from
the committee is there any discussion on
this in this bill as
amended okay I'm going to give the clerk
one
second
so
for e
so this is the first time go ahead
represent move out to pass as amended
okay and I'll second that so the motion
is ought to pass as
amended yep new motion and that's motion
by Paige second by Alexander all right
any other discussion on this bill we'll
get there eventually okay all
right so go ahead and call the role on
this I'm do again yep
okay uh Vice chair Cole
yes representative
Faxton not here representative Aaron
buer
yes representative
Dumont yes representative Grant yes
representative miles not here
representative Miner
yes cleric reinford yes representative
Paige yes representative boras yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative hick yes
representative Howland yes
representative hegner yes and
representative Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander yes
so do I motion yep motion carries 16
motion carries 16 zero to zero okay um
is there objection to this going on
consent for the next object okay all
right so at this point I'm going to have
um would you like to write the majority
report for the committee or do you want
me to do
that all right so I'm G to have
representative Paige write the majority
report and this will go on the regular
calendar for I believe we're going to
have session on the 6th um so just get
it to me within a day or so that'd be
great okay any other business for this
committee I know we had a long day I'm
going to work on scheduling for next
week um next Tuesday plan on having
another full day hearings I also want to
exec a couple bills um I'll confer with
the ranking member on where our caucuses
are at on those um and I believe the
Republicans will meet at some point
later but um any other business for the
committee okay thank you have a great
day
everyone e